welcome to the ultimate data science
tools tutorial video in this
comprehensive guide we will delve into
the world of data science equipping you
with the essential skills and knowledge
to harness the power of various tools
this course is your gateway to
harnessing the immense power of Cutting
Edge tools and technologies that drive
the field of data science discover the
essential tools used by industry experts
to extract insights analyze vast data
sets and make data-driven decisions with
confidence we will explore a wide Diary
of indispensable tools including Excel
python numpy pandas C bone scikit-learn
Metro lib tensorflow Tableau and MySQL
Excel the ubiquitous spreadsheet
software serves as an excellent starting
point for data manipulation and Analysis
Python A versatile programming language
take Center Stage as we dive into its
extensive ecosystem of data science
libraries numpy that enables numer
medical computations and provides a
solid foundation for scientific
Computing while pandas offers powerful
data manipulation capabilities and to
unleash the full potential of your data
visualizations we will explore sea bone
and matte broadly enabling you to create
stunning and informative graphs and
plots scikit-learn scikit line will be
your go to library for machine learning
enthusiasts empowering you to implement
various algorithms and build predictive
models but your journey doesn't stop
there we will delve into the realm of
deep learning with tensorflow a Cutting
Edge library for neural network
development next we will explore Tableau
a popular data visualization tool to
transform raw data into insightful
dashboards lastly we'll Master the art
of data storage and retrieval using
MySQL a robust and scalable database
management system get ready to unlock
the full potential of data science as we
embark on this thrilling tutorial
equipping you with the skills and
knowledge to concur any data driven
challenge in this data science tools
course we will learn the following join
us as we demystify the world of data
science and Empower you to harness the
power of its tool to drive strategic
success let's dive in if these are the
types of videos you would like to watch
then hit the Subscribe button like and
press on the Bell icon to never miss any
further content if you are one of the
aspiring data scientists looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with data
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learn
skeltic post-graduate program in data
science in collaboration with IBM the
link is mentioned in the description box
and you should navigate to the home page
where you can find a complete overview
of the program being offered hello and
welcome to the lesson formatting
conditional formatting and important
functions in this lesson we will learn
about custom formatting how to use
conditional formatting and formulas and
Implement logical statistical and
mathematical functions
let's say we need to differentiate the
sales value from the given data set as
above Target below Target and met Target
as a data set can be huge and complex
differentiating each value manually
would consume a lot of effort and time
here comes the Excel features such as
formatting and conditional formatting
which enables us to perform this task
easily
formatting as the name suggests helps us
to format the data using different
techniques making the data easy to read
in the required format and analyze them
the right formatting technique applied
to the worksheets can help the users
present the data efficiently conditional
formatting a type of formatting helps us
visually explore and analyze data detect
critical issues and identify patterns
and trends conditional formatting helps
to add patterns and Trends to the raw
information using different colors icons
and formula Etc
at times we also need to perform
mathematical operations and calculations
within our data set
Excel provides a large number of logical
statistical and mathematical functions
such as vlookup hlookup and if not rank
quartile and many more that can help the
users to perform calculations ranging
from basic to complex operations
these inbuilt functions help us to
manage data and perform descriptive
statistical analysis
Excel also offers a wide range of
important formulas that help to perform
many common tasks these formula may be
as simple as basic addition or it could
be a complex combination of inbuilt
excel functions before going into
details let us start this lesson by
defining the objectives of the lesson
the worksheets appear more polished and
easy to read if proper formatting
techniques are applied to it we can
format the cells in Microsoft Excel
manually by selecting fonts font color
font size background colors and borders
we can also use numerous predefined
table Styles or quick styles to quickly
format a table automatically this is the
basic formatting in Excel
if these built-in functions do not meet
our needs or do not display the data in
the format that we require we can create
our own custom format in this topic we
will focus on custom formatting in Excel
let's say we want to display 1532
000 as 1.53 M or the 1st of January 2016
date with a weekday as the first Friday
January
2016. here we can use custom formatting
feature of excel let's see how we can
accomplish this in Excel
in this lesson we shall consider the
following fields from our master table
dates order ID
product salesman region number of
customers net sales and profit and loss
here in the given worksheet we have a
column named net sales
suppose we want to display the values of
net sales in terms of thousands for
example
7164 should be displayed at 7.16 k
select the entire column for net sales
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in the numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cells dialog box appears from the
category list select the type as custom
in the type text box enter number column
number number zero decimal zero zero
comma
open double quote capital K close double
quote
here number is the digit holder with
thousand comma separation
each comma after decimal 0 0 indicate
divide value by one thousand
the two zeros after decimal point
indicate number of value after decimal
places
the K component displays a literal K
character to denote thousands
here we can see the preview in sample
box the value shown is 7.16 K
finally click OK button
the values in column net sales are now
displayed in terms of thousands
now let us consider another example of
date formatting
in the column dates we have a date value
written as 1st Jan 2012. we want to
display it as first Sunday Jan 2012.
first select the column containing dates
under the Home tab click the drop down
present in numbers panel
select the option more number formats a
format cell dialog box appears
from the category list select the type
as custom
in the type text box enter DD Dash D D
Dash m m
y y
here d stands for date
m stands for month and y stands for year
the first 2dd is the date
the next four D D D D is for weekday say
Thursday
then mmm is for the month in short form
and YY is for year
here we can see in the preview in the
sample box the value shown is one Sunday
Jan 12.
finally click on OK button
thus the custom formatting helps us in
changing the appearance of the cell
value according to our needs
a worksheet may contain thousands of
rows of data by simply examining the raw
information it would be difficult to see
patterns and Trends conditional
formatting helps us visualize data that
make worksheets easier to understand it
quickly highlights important information
in a spreadsheet by using colors icons
and data bars it changes the appearance
of one or more cells when the cell value
meets certain criteria to do this we
need to create a conditional formatting
rule for example a conditional
formatting rule can be if value is
greater than five thousand color the
cell yellow
by applying this rule we will be able to
quickly see which cells contain values
that are greater than 5000 let us
understand this with the help of
examples
consider the given sales table which
depicts the amount of sales done by each
salesman here we want to highlight the
duplicate order ID values
first select the order ID column
clip Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over highlight cells rules and select
duplicate values
a duplicate values dialog box appears
select a formatting style from the drop
down menu in our example we will choose
green fill with dark green text click ok
here we can see that the conditional
formatting is applied to the column
order ID
Excel highlights all the duplicate cells
with green fill with dark green text
we can also explore other options
available in conditional formatting like
greater than less than between equal to
text that contains a date occurring and
top slash bottom rules
all these rules work in the similar
format
Excel provides predefined styles to
quickly apply conditional formatting to
our data they are data bars data bars
are horizontal bars added to each column
much like a bar graph
color scales color scales change the
color of each cell based on its value
each color scale uses a two or three
color gradient icon sets icon sets add
specific icon to each cell based on its
value
let us consider another example to
explain how icon set rules are used
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to apply the icon set rule
if sales amount is greater than 8 000
then a green arrow should appear in the
upward Direction
if sales amount is between five thousand
and eight thousand then show a yellow
arrow in the horizontal Direction
and if sales amount is less than five
thousand then show a red arrow in the
downward Direction
to perform conditional formatting select
the desired cells
click on Home tab
under Styles panel select the option
conditional formatting
from the drop down menu hover the mouse
over icon set rules and select the first
rule
again click on conditional formatting
select the option manage rules from the
drop down a conditional formatting rules
manager dialog box appears
go to Icon set Rule and select three
icon set rule
click on edit Rule and an edit rule
formatting dialog box appears
by default for three icon set rule Excel
uses the 67th percentile and the 33
percentile rule this means that it shows
a green arrow for values greater than 67
percent
yellow arrows for values between 67 and
33 percent and red arrow for values less
than 33 percent
now let us customize this rule for our
criteria
in the type drop down select the option
as number
in the value reference box enter value
is 8 000 for green color arrow and 5000
for yellow color Arrow
Excel automatically picks the criteria
for the red color Arrow click ok
in the conditional formatting rules
manager window click ok
we can see that the cells are
highlighted as per our criteria cells
which have a value greater than 8 000
have a green arrow in the upward
Direction
values between 5K and 8K are highlighted
with a yellow arrow and values less than
5K are highlighted with a red arrow
we can also apply conditional formatting
rule with the help of formulas consider
the given table which shows the profit
done by each salesman here we want to
highlight the rows in the table wherever
profit is greater than four thousand
select the entire table along with
headings
click on conditional formatting
select the option new rule from the drop
down a new formatting rule dialog box
appears
under select rule type select the option
use a formula to determine which cells
to format
under format values reference box enter
the formula as equals if Open Bracket
dollar sign H2 greater than four
thousand comma true comma false close
bracket
this will apply formatting to a cell if
the profit is greater than four thousand
click on format button
from the format cells dialog box select
the fill tab from the color dialog box
select the color as green
finally click ok
the conditional formatting is
successfully applied to the cells here
we can see that the cells with the
profit greater than four thousand are
highlighted with the green color
logical functions evaluate a cell or
cells for a criteria and returns a
Boolean value true or false
in this topic we will cover various
logical functions like if and or not
true false
consider the given sales table
here on the basis of the sales amount we
want to determine the commission
percentage of each salesman
following is the criteria if net sales
greater than or equal to ten thousand
set commission as five percent
if net sales greater than or equal to
5000 and less than or equal to ten
thousand set commission as 2.5 percent
if net sales less than five thousand set
commission as one point five percent
this is a common condition where we're
required to create a between formula
that picks all values between the two
given values in such conditions we use
if with the and function
let's write the formula in cell I5
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function e if and then type an open
parenthesis the first parameter we need
to pass is a logical test here The
Logical test is if sales cell G5 greater
than or equal to ten thousand assign
value as five percent
then we will pass the second logical
test here we will use and function if
Open Bracket and Open Bracket sale at
cell G5 greater than or equal to five
thousand comma cell G5 less than or
equal to ten thousand comma assign value
as 2.5 percent
in the else parameter we will type 1.5
percent this means that if the first two
cases become false then the formula will
assign the value 1.5
finally close the two braces for the two
IFS thus Excel Returns the result as 2.5
percent for cell G5
now drag the formula with the help of
the fill handle we can see the results
for the other cells as well
the or function returns true if any of
the conditions are true and returns
false if all of the conditions are false
in the given table we are required to
assign performance remarks for each
salesman as per the scaling table
in scaling table we have the criteria
that if net sales greater than 10 000 or
profit greater than five thousand set
remark as good
else set remark as needs Improvement
let's write the formula using IF and or
to check sales and maximum sales in cell
J5
so our formula becomes equals if Open
Bracket or Open Bracket G5 greater than
ten thousand comma H5 greater than or
equal to five thousand comma double
quote good double quote comma double
quote need Improvement double quote
close bracket
let's drag this formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
this formula returned true if any of the
condition is true thus in the given
example the cell j9 returns good even if
profit is less than five thousand
our next function is true false true
slash false returns true and false
respectively if we write them in any
cell
the not function reverses the result of
the function
if result is true it returns false else
true
let's write formula as equal not open
bracket K5 close bracket in cell L5
this Returns the result as false
let us now study about different lookup
and reference functions used in Excel
such as vlookup hlookup match index and
offset function
the vlookup function lets us search for
specific information in the current
worksheet
say we have a list of students with
marks we can search for the marks of a
specific student if our table is in
horizontal format and we want to
determine a specific value then we use
the hlookup function
consider the extract from our Master
sales table
the table depicts sales information
based on order ID Products sold salesman
and net sales now we want to determine
the net sales corresponding to order ID
let's understand how we can accomplish
this using the vlookup function
note that vlookup function is only used
for vertical tables let's use cell I2 to
add the formula
like any other formula we will start
with the equal sign then type our
function name
vlookup and then type and open
parentheses
now we will add the arguments the first
argument is lookup value lookup value
corresponds to the value or item we are
searching for
so in our example it will be order
id1121 cell H2
the second argument is table array table
array is the cell range that contains
the data in this example our data is in
cell B2 to e40.
the third argument is called index num
column index number the column index
number is the column number in which we
are looking for information here in our
table array net sales is the fourth
column so our third argument will be
four
the fourth argument is range lookup this
value corresponds if we are looking for
approximate matches or not and can have
value either true or false true denotes
the approximate match and false denotes
the exact match here we will pass false
finally close the parentheses
so our function has the form equal
vlookup Open Bracket H2 comma B2 colon
E40 comma four comma false close bracket
we can see that the function Returns the
value as 2 2 7 7.
note that the vlookup function works
from left to right that means the lookup
value should always be present in the
leftmost column of our table array
if our table is in horizontal format and
we want to determine a specific value
then we use the hlookup function
consider the given table let's write the
formula in cell I4 we will start with
the equal sign then type our function
name
hlookup and then type open parentheses
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be order ID
equals one one two one
cell eight four
the second argument is table array in
this example our data is in cell G8 to
as11
the third argument is row index number
here our table array net sales is the
fourth row so our third argument will be
four the fourth argument is range lookup
here we will pass false finally close
the parentheses
so our function has the form equals
hlookup Open Bracket H4 comma G8 colon
as11 comma 4 comma fault close bracket
the function Returns the value to 277
note that each lookup function works
from left to right that means lookup
value should always be in the topmost
row of your table array
the match function searches for a
specified value in an item in a single
dimensional array and then Returns the
relative position of that item in the
array
let us understand its functioning with
the help of an example consider the
given sales table shown here we want to
determine the position of the
corresponding date in the original table
so let's write the formula in cell E5
type equal sign
then type the function name
match and then type an open parenthesis
the first argument is the lookup value
so in our example it will be date in
cell B5
the second argument is lookup array the
lookup array is a range of cells that
contains the value we are searching for
in this example we will select the cells
B17 to b1342
the third argument is match type match
type can be either -1 0 or 1. the value
should be 1. if we want to find the
largest value less than or equal to the
lookup value
the value should be zero if we want to
find the first value exactly equal to
lookup value
it should be -1 if we want to find the
smallest value greater than or equal to
lookup value
here we will pass the match type as 0 as
we require an exact match
finally close the parentheses
so our function should look like match
Open Bracket B5 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
B dollar sign one three four two comma
zero close bracket
this Returns the value as three now we
can drag the formula across cells with
the help of the fill handle
similarly we can use the match formula
in cell E3 to determine the position of
the shown field name Excel C3 in range
B17 to I17 for example net sales is at
seventh position in the range B17 to I17
let's write the function in cell E3
write formula as equal sign match and
open parentheses in the first argument
select cell C3
for second argument select cells B17 to
I17
past third argument is zero finally
close the parentheses
so our function looks like equal match
Open Bracket C3 comma dollar sign B
dollar sign Seventeen colon dollar sign
I dollar sign Seventeen comma zero close
bracket so for profit loss field the
value returned is 8.
net sale the value returned is seven
the index function Returns value from a
specified position in a specific column
in a list
suppose we want to determine the value
of a field mentioned in cell C3 from the
sales table on a specified date
the table should dynamically fetch the
value if the value of the cell C3 is
changed
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
if we write net sales in cell C3 then
formula should fetch net sales value for
specified date
so let's use the index function to
determine the value in this worksheet
select cell C5 write formula as equal
sign index and open parentheses
the first argument is the array for our
example enter B17 colon i1342
the second argument is the row num this
corresponds to the row number that has
the value we want to return here we will
enter E5 which denotes the required date
the third column is column
this corresponds to the column number
that has the value we want to return
here we will enter E3 which denotes the
position of the field name in cell C3 in
table
finally close the parentheses
thus our formula Returns the value as
6528 based on the position at cells E5
this is the net sales value on the date
the 2nd of January
now drag the formula with the fill
handle to the other cells as well
the offset function returns a reference
to a range that is the offset number of
the rows and columns from another range
or cell now let's understand how to use
it select cell D5
right formula is equal sign offset and
open parentheses the first argument is
the reference this denotes the starting
range from which the offset will be
applied for our example we will select
the reference cell as B17
the second argument is the rows this
denotes the number of rows to apply as
the offset to the reference this can be
a positive or A negative number
so for our example we will enter E5
minus 1. here we are subtracting 1 to
match number of row which have the value
and the offset from the reference cell
the third argument is the calls this
corresponds to the column number that
has the value we want to return here we
will enter E3 which denotes the position
of the field name and subtract by 1 to
match with the offset referencing
finally close the parentheses
the function Returns the value based on
the position of date from cell B5 and
field from cell C3
now drag the formula across the cells
with the help of the fill handle
if we enter profit loss formula should
fetch the profit loss value for the
specified date
a variety of statistical functions are
available in Excel to perform
calculations ranging from basic function
mean median and mode to more composite
distribution and test binomial or
chi-square
in this topic we will cover various
statistical functions like sumif
countifs percentile quartile standard
deviation and median
sumifs and countifs are the most
frequently used functions in Excel these
functions allow us to perform count and
sum based on one or more criteria the
sumifs function calculates the sum of
cells based on certain criteria
let's understand how to use the function
with the help of an example consider the
given sales table say we want to
determine the net sales done by salesman
Justin
here we will use the sumifs function to
calculate net sales so let's write the
formula in cell N4 type equal sign then
type the function name sumifs and then
type in open parentheses the first
argument is the sum range this is the
input range that contains the required
data so in our example we will select
cells H4 to H 1328
the second argument is the criteria
range this denotes the range that
contains the required criteria here we
will pass the range that holds
salesman's name cells E4 to E 1328.
the third argument is criteria this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require net sales of the salesman
Justin so we will select cell M4
finally close the parentheses note that
we can pass multiple criteria in this
function the function Returns the net
sales done by Justin
countifs function Works in a similar
manner like sumifs it counts the number
of cells in a given range when certain
criteria is met
say in the given sales table we want to
determine the total number of sales for
net sales greater than 8 000. to
determine the count we will use the
countifs function so let's write the
formula in cell N5 type the equal sign
then type the function name
countifs and then type in open
parentheses the first argument is the
criteria range one this denotes the
range that contains the required
criteria here we will pass the cells
containing net sales H4 to h1328
the second argument is criteria one this
corresponds to our required criteria we
only require entries with net sales
greater than eight thousand so we will
enter greater than 8 000. finally close
the parentheses
note that the function allows you to
enter multiple criteria
cell N5 reflects the total number of
sales as 445 for net sales greater than
eight thousand
in this topic we will learn how to use
the function's percentile quartile
standard deviation and median in Excel
consider the given sales table let's see
how to use the percentile function on
net sales to find its 40th percentile
select the cell n6 write the formula as
equal sign percentile Open Bracket
select the column net sales H4 to
h1328 as our first argument
pass the second argument as 0.4 in order
to find the 40th percentile
this Returns the result
5220 this means that forty percent of
the net sales is less than or equal to
5220.
the next function is quartile quartile
function depicts the results for the
first second third and fourth quartile
say we want to find the total number of
sales which are less than or equal to 25
percent let's use the quartile function
to calculate this
select cell N7 to write the formula
type equal sign function name is
quartile and open braces
select net sales column H4 to
h1328 as the first argument
type 1 as the second argument
the second argument must be a number
between 0 and 4. the function Returns
the value as
3822 which means that 25 percent of the
sale is less than or equal to 3822.
note that here we can use the percentile
function to perform the same task the
function percentile H4 to
h1328 comma 0.25 gives us the same
result it's up to us which function we
would like to use for the quartiles
Excel has a function to calculate sample
standard deviations stdev
[Music]
standard deviation determines how
dispersed the data is from the mean
say we want to calculate the standard
deviation for number of customers
so write the formula in cell N8 as
equals
the function name stdev
open braces
select number of customers columns as
its argument
the function returns a result 1.4
the median function Returns the value
from the range for example we want to
find the mid value for net sales to
calculate median in cell N9 write the
formula as equal sign the function name
median then open braces
select net sales column as its argument
this calculates the mid value of net
sales as 6192
rank function is used to compare a
number from the rest of the numbers in a
list in any order whether ascending or
descending this function Returns the
rank of the number relative to the other
values in the list let's use rank
function in cell j4 to calculate rank on
the basis of net sales
select cell j4 and write the formula as
equal sign then type the function name
rank and then type in open parentheses
the first argument is the number
this is the value whose rank we are
required to calculate here we will pass
the argument cell H4
second argument is ref
this corresponds to the array or
reference list here we will select the
column net sales IE cells H4 to H 1328
the third number is order this specifies
how to rank the number zero means
descending order and 1 denotes ascending
order
this argument is optional if we don't
pass any argument Excel automatically
takes the argument zero here we will
pass zero finally close the parentheses
here we can see that Excel has
determined the rank for net sales
7164 as 553
finally we can drag the formula and can
see the rank for the other cells based
on net sales
so what is data
data science is to fill the study that
deals with modern scientific techniques
statistical methods and algorithms to
derive insights from vast volumes of
data companies using data science are
very numerous with companies generating
data of every minute there is a need to
make sense of this data
moo Sigma fractal Fidelity Intel gympact
cubula Amazon trendense connect the dots
just about every business out there
nowadays uses some form of data science
even if it's indirectly to help govern
their business and help them growth and
compete in the business world and we use
the data science to find unseen patterns
within the data analyze and draw
insights from our data and solve
business problems and make decisions and
the data science has a life cycle
we start with our data Discovery then we
go through data preparation exploratory
data analysis data modeling interpret
the results and back to data Discovery
we talk about data Discovery data
Discovery involves asking the right
questions
identifying the business problems
finding the best solution and Gathering
correct data from relevant sources for
analysis
this is in the data science life cycle
the most important step
now in general it only involves like a
small percentage of the time you spend
on this but if you're not asking the
right questions you can't go in the
right direction data preparation data
preparation deals with cleaning the data
finding the inconsistencies tackling
missing values converting it into the
right format and making it ready for
analysis when I'm running the data
science lifecycle this is probably where
the most time is spent data can be so
messy
you have to break it down into different
parts you have to import the different
pieces from different databases are you
dealing with straight numbers off of
spreadsheets and cells or you're dealing
with text documents and natural token
language tokenization exploratory data
analysis analyze and visualize the data
using different charts and graphs to
find significant patterns and hidden
trends that helps to understand the data
better the building of the charts
is very creative probably one of the
more enjoyable Parts is be able to come
in there and describe the data and show
that to the shareholders then we dive
into Data modeling use classification
regression and clustering algorithms to
build machine learning models that can
help predict and forecast future trends
this is where we start getting into
predictions what's next where's it going
to go and then interpret the results
validate the model results draw the
final conclusion and check if the
performance of the model is in line with
the requirements
the final step is the one that you set
up in front of the board members and
give them suggestions as to what's next
where we're going to spend our marketing
money where are we going to start
preparing our fire fires for the next
fire breaks next year what is the
weather patterns coming in this is where
you interpret the results and say how
accurate they are are they valid is it
something we're going to keep are we
going to throw it out and have to start
over we look at data science components
there's the mathematics statistics
domain expertise data engineering data
visualization and machine learning when
we sum this up in data science really
this point
in all of this you want to focus on
first is domain expertise now when
you're taking your classes obviously you
want to go through the mathematics the
statistics the data engineering the data
visualization the machine learning
learning all those tools
but it really in the job field the
domain expertise comes in
because if you're really good with
business and you go into business with
these tools then you're able to ask the
right questions and deal with it when we
talk about the tools in data science and
where they sit there is a data analysis
data analysis focuses more on statistics
and Mathematics where the data science
size
where the data science side focuses more
on the machine learning data
visualization
and then there's database management
which really focuses on the data
engineering part of it and how to manage
that data in the data flow
you can see all these components come
together and then they form the data
science and we talk about Tools in data
science we have SAS we have Matlab we
have SQL you have your Apache spark your
R tab blue python right now in the
programming languages python is probably
the most widely used with r coming in a
close second
the reason for that is these are both
open source and anybody can use them
when we look at SAS and tablu those are
two packages that are paid for which
have a lot of automation behind them so
a lot of the larger companies will pay
for those packages because they help
work out a lot of the the back end stuff
before you even need to use them
and of course we have Apache spark you
almost have to know Apache spark in the
growing data Lakes today that's your big
data how do you distribute this if
you're going to process it over a large
amount of data when we look at data
science applications there's internet
search very common you enter your Google
thing and it uses a data science
algorithms to figure out what to return
Voice assistance analyzing The Voice
coming in and connecting it with
whatever patterns they need to activate
so you can ask it to turn your lights on
in the living room Healthcare biggest
field growing right now how do we
analyze Health Data from a smart watch
and figure out how to know when a
disease is being spread across the world
Healthcare how do we identify cancer
versus non-cancer so we know who to
prioritize and get them in for surgery
where other people might not need that
immediate care and even identifying
problems somebody might have with their
health long before they even happen what
a neat thing to do instead of waiting
until you have a heart attack to know
months ahead of time that you're having
heart conditions Logistics how do we get
from point A to point B if you ever look
at some of the major Distributors they
pre-ship Things based on what they guess
people are going to need this way you
get your stuff right in the mailbox the
day after you order it e-commerce
huge in there because you have to know
what kind of marketing we're going to
put out who are we selling to what's our
target audience robotics one of the
funner ones when you're coming up into
the Futures how do we automate the
different uh tasks we have from
self-driving cars to manufacturing lines
to maybe even a self-robotic chef in the
kitchen so we talk about solving
problems with data science
we have to ask possible questions and
the desired algorithms and these really
are kind of an overview of some of the
terminology you'll want to know in data
science so we talk about that how much
or how many we're talking about
regression regression basically means a
number if you've ever seen stock charts
you see the guess at what the next sales
price is or buy prices that's all on
your regression side
is it a or b classification
is that a dog or a cat that my photo
took a picture of how is this organized
clustering this is where we take things
that look alike and put them together so
that we can then make predictions on it
how different is this
just like you have clustering you have
the opposite anomaly detection how do we
find things that don't fit in where are
the outliers what are things we might
need to look at that aren't in our model
and what to do next reinforced learning
this is probably the newest Market is
how do we set something up whereas the
data comes in it learns from the new
data as to what the next action is going
to take
most of these are combined so when we
talk about regression classification
clustering anomaly detection reinforced
learning a lot of times when you put
your model together you might have
multiple parts of this we might look at
the clustering of data and then feed it
into a classification is this a bad loan
to make it the bank or is this a good
loan to give
and from there we might start looking at
when we start clustering these things as
good and bad and what kind of setup is
we need might run it through a
regression model to say hey what is the
amount dollar amount this person should
be allowed to take a loan out
and you can see that all of these start
coming in and then a lot of the models
reinforce learning
we talk about like bank loans and things
like that once a year
they have to rerun those algorithms and
so that's like a human run reinforced
learning now we're starting to automate
that so that as the data comes in real
time the models start updating
themselves they start figuring out a way
to solve new problems as they occur
and of course in robotics reinforced
learning is one of the biggest growing
Fields algorithms used in data science
linear regression
logistic regression when you're looking
at both of these think numbers we're
talking regression models and so linear
regression figures out the best line
through the data Maybe it's looking for
a curved line
logistic regression starts looking at
data on a Continuum so that
it goes to an exponential you have a
spot where it might be one or the other
and then you know what it is as it goes
to one side or the other
decision tree wonderful tool if you used
to call it a hack now it's becoming
mainstream to look at the back end what
made the decision so it's really easy to
trace back to how you arrived at the
decision decision trees are kind of nice
that way
nearest neighbors okay nearest neighbors
is your clustering K means clustering
hierarchical clustering so hierarchical
starts dividing them and builds a
hierarchy where the K means and the K
nearest neighbor look for things that
kind of connect each other how close are
they in data format
DB scan another form of clustering your
data principal component analysis so we
start breaking up and looking at the
different components in our data coming
in these are all algorithms used in data
science and there are more these are
kind of the mainline ones and each one
of these has many settings which you can
play with to build a better model to
predict your data and where you want it
to go let's go ahead and take a Hands-On
demo and just see what does this look
like
now I'm going to go ahead and use the
Anaconda Navigator and the which is your
Jupiter notebook which will then open up
in Google Chrome this is one of the Ides
or ways of editing python code I like
this one because it one protects my
computer and creates its own kind of
container and two it's got a really nice
visual demo for doing python certainly
you can use a number of other different
tools like pycharm there's another real
popular one you can actually access
pycharm code through the Anaconda
Navigator now and there's a lot of other
tools on there that each have their
benefit and we come into our jupyter
notebook go ahead and create a new
python I've already done that and we'll
start with a lot Logistics regression
model just so you can see what this
looks like in code we'll actually do two
of these
as we go through this and take a look
and see what that code looks like in
Python now the first thing we want to go
ahead and do is
load up all our parts modules that we
need in our python code
I'll go ahead and run that and you'll
see here I'm going to ignore warnings
because some of the stuff we're doing
we're just looking at it and as you go
from one version of python to one
version of whatever the site kit or in
this case the SC package you'll see some
warnings come up they're not really
important right now
and then we're going to go ahead and use
the German Credit Data CSV
and so when I run this this is all
loaded up now let's go ahead and just
open up this CSV file so you can see
what that looks like
and here he is here's our German Credit
Data file we'll go ahead and just open
that up with ah let's do wordpad is fine
because it's a Word document
and when we open that up
you can see right here it's just a bunch
of comma separated values we have across
the top it actually has columns on here
so our first row is a bunch of columns
and then of course we look down here
oops I just move stuff around but that's
okay I'm not going to save it and you
can see the values al1 al4 whatever that
means or A14 I guess and then some sort
of numbers on here
and we'll take a closer look when we get
into the program
and looking at the data for right now
we've loaded that under credit DF
and at this point I want to just kind of
take a detour back to the life cycle of
data science so we can see how that fits
in there
and so we've already done our data
Discovery we have a little data prep but
the data is pretty clean it already
comes in preset on there we'll make do a
little data preparation in here we're
going to start looking at exploring the
data analysis and building a data model
and then interpreting the results so
really we're focusing on the last three
steps of this
the data Discovery would be asking start
asking questions of what do we want in
there is this going to be
is this going to be a good loan a bad
loan what do we want to get out of this
data where are we going with it that
would be part of the data Discovery and
a lot of times that might be a meeting
you have with the management in the
office or whatever
and then data preparation is of course
cleaning the data up making sure you
know where the source came from all
those kind of fun things that go into
making sure you have good data coming in
now you'll notice here we've got we're
using pandas whoops drew it through the
pandas and we're going to go ahead and
read it as a pandas data frame and of
course pandas sits on numpy so a lot of
stuff you do with pandas can go right
into numpy very easily
and the reason I bring this up is
because pandas has a lot of tools in
there for just looking at the data real
quick and easy
and so the first one we want to go ahead
and do is do credit.df or credit
underscore DF our data we read in info
and just see what that looks like
and when we go ahead and print this out
you can see here we have
13 columns remember we were looking at
our data and it had those that row you
couldn't read across the top
and then it has non-null count how many
values don't have null what kind of
objects are they they're an object an
integer
different things like that and we look
at object is it a checking account this
is probably text on here
duration how long credit history amount
savings account present employee
employed since so a lot of different
numbers coming in here and these are
just the columns we're looking at
and if you're going to look at the
columns it's kind of nice to actually
look at the data
and so we'll use the pandas to go ahead
and print it out just like you would on
a spreadsheet
hard to see them all on here but you can
see we have here's our row across the
top because Panda does such a good job
sorting out columns
and the actual data checking account a11
a12 A14 not sure what that means
duration how long they've had it credit
history I'm not sure what the a33 or a34
means I'm sure it has a special meaning
on there the amount here's our savings
account and all the information on that
and this is actually a very a much more
easy to read view than what we had
before as far as like that text file
when you're just looking at data through
the database sometimes those can be
really hard to read this you can really
see and if I take it down a notch I can
get all the columns in here we'll go
ahead and keep it zoomed in just so we
can see that what's going on a little
easier
foreign
and then we can also do credit df.i
location the ilocation feature in the
pandas is going to go ahead and do rows
0 through 5 and we're going to look at
columns one through seven and let's go
and just run that and you can see right
here how we just split it up so it's
real easy to manipulate our data and get
a smaller view of different parts of the
data as we're going through it and just
like we can look at the first seven
columns we can also look at the last
seven columns
same kind of format we're looking at row
0 through 5 column seven to the end if
you leave the number out there
and you can see we can easily now look
at this on a smaller screen much better
for displaying those are just tricks to
help you display
your information so that when you
present this in front of a group of
people
it makes it very easy to read or you can
just copy this out and put it into a
document that kind of thing and then we
also like to go ahead and do like credit
status value counts and things like that
again we're just looking at the
different
sets of information on here
and in our pandas data frame value
counts is we're looking at unique values
so there's a lot of unique values in
here that's um 700 and 300 that's a
significantly uh diverse set of data
and if we look at the data one of the
things we're looking at is the status 0
1 0 0 1
and I'm going to guess that that means
that it is either default or not default
so that's probably what we're going to
want to look for hopefully you've had
your specialty in domain remember we
talked about the different parts of data
science domain is what field it is in
this would be in Banks and loans and so
if we want to figure out what the status
of a new loan is we're going to separate
the status out and so if we take our X
features equals the list of the columns
that's all this is credit underscore
df.columbs we remove status
and then we go ahead and this will print
our features out and you can see it's
everything but the status on the end
because that's what we want to predict
we want to predict the new data whether
that status is zero or one or not and
next we want to do a little bit more
data preparation we're going to go ahead
and encode
and we're going to take an encode credit
DF we're going to create that off of our
setup on here
and you're going to ask well what are we
encoding on here well when we go up to
here let me just go back all the way
when we're looking at all this
information up here
you can see there's a object
object object well if I'm doing a
prediction and something's just a random
object it doesn't really mean anything
there's no numbers to process
and so when we come down a little
further we can see down here that we are
looking at
a65 I'm not sure what a65 means we're
looking at a 93 personal status we're
looking at a143 these aren't actual
numbers there's some kind of code that
the bank put in probably and so for our
model they really don't mean anything
unless we convert them to numbers
and you convert them to numbers by
literally creating a bunch of yes no's
so instead of thinking it as as
a173 and a172 as being 0 1 and if you
had an A7 174 maybe 0 1 2 you would
think of this as a label a173 is true or
false and then you'd have another label
a172 is true or false so for every
unique job in here that it becomes
another feature added in and it's on or
off it's true or false that's what this
encoding is doing
and we'll go ahead and list our encoding
as it comes out and if you come up here
you can see it did exactly what I was
describing we've now encoded it so
here's checking account a13 checking
account
a1214
a31 here's all of our
checking account numbers so there was
three of them uh here's our credit
history a31 a32 a33 34. again the
computer has no idea of knowing what
those are all it knows is those are each
unique features and the same thing with
the savings account a62 and so on going
down and so once we have our nice listed
there we can go ahead and do
let me pull this in here we go let's
look at our new data set
and if we go ahead and run the new data
set we have our in-cone credit DF
checking and we're just going to look at
these and look at the head this is just
the first few of these so we can see
what it actually looks like in the data
and just like I said it's now uh zero
zero zero zero one one zero zero
this First Column is just the count zero
one two three four that's not part of
the data but you can see here
that it just puts a check mark of one
because it's an AC a12 and we have a
checking account aca14 where it's also a
check mark of one going across
so we've done a little data preparation
uh we've come in here and done some
exploratory data analysis
and now we want to start building our
data model and we'll kind of go back and
forth between exploratory data analysis
and data model and then interpreting the
results on this and so when we go ahead
and import our stats models as API
as SM
now a lot of times we use the SK learner
the scikit models and this one we're
going to go ahead and use the SM model
from stats models which is pretty common
for doing a very basic Logistics
regression model and then from the site
kit we're going to have our train test
split
with any data you want to go ahead and
train your model and then you need
something to test it on some unknown
data so you can see how well you did
very common in your day in your setting
up your models is to split it up into
your training set and your testing set
and what I want you to notice on here is
we have X train well what is X Train
That's all the columns except for the
last one which was the status was it
default or was it in in good standing
and then of course our X test is part of
the data we're going to split that up by
0.3 so 30 percent of the data is going
to be 30 of our rows are going to be put
in the X test and the Y train and Y test
is just the status and then we create
our once we've created our data and
split it up we go ahead and create our
model and it's a logit we're just going
to call it logic but you can a lot of
times you end up seeing logic model
with logit
it equals the
sm.logitxtrain
Y train X train and SK learn it's always
x-train y train but in the
stats model it's reversed on there and
then they go ahead and run the fit so we
load the data up and then we fit it
uh and then we can go ahead and
summarize that model and see what it
looks like and let's go ahead and run
that
it takes it just a moment uh and we get
a nice summary of our data again we're
still looking at the data and we have
takes just a moment to to kind of feed
through and you can certainly see where
we have our coefficient which has to do
with the weights in the model standard
error that's very important as we look
at this coefficient and how it affects
the model
p is greater than the absolute value of
Z 0.025 these are all your statistical
notes on here so as you look at these
you might look at like how big is a
standard error that's one of the big
ones that I usually look at as we go up
and we start looking at the different
things the higher the error the less the
more we want to be a little careful of
it the lower the error the better in
more general terms they also have
dealing with the model and inciderations
you can see some general status on here
how many iterations did it have to go
through Drew before I was able to come
up with the numbers because it kind of
guesses it's playing a high low game and
it takes it six iterations till it finds
what it considers the best fit uh and
you can see there's more information up
here as far as when it converts how it
converts and so on now when we have our
summary up there one of the questions
starts coming in remember I told you
we're looking at like our standard error
and you know how these numbers all are
telling us how important each one of
these features is in running our
prediction and if you have a ton of
features and some of them are just kind
of all over the place all they do is
create noise so we really want to get
rid of them they also cause issues in
that if you're running a huge amount of
data and you have to rerun this model
over and over again this can really text
your time and so you're losing both time
money and your results might not be as
good because they might be weighted
based on some of these very fuzzy
numbers
uh so we're going to look at significant
variables and put together a little
routine for that again we're we've come
in if you remember from back here we're
still in kind of an exploratory data
analysis and data modeling they kind of
go hand in hand sometimes we haven't
quite got to interpreting the results in
running predictions and so we'll go
ahead and build this thing on here it
looks at the LM values so that's coming
up here where this was generated
I didn't have to actually look that up
for the this particular model because I
usually use the sklearn version of this
uh so as we look at this we're going to
look at the P values of our variables
and basically we're looking to see how
good the p-values are if they're less
than or equal to 0.05 we probably
those are probably solid values and if
they're greater than that then probably
we're not interested in them
and so let's go ahead and run this and
we see that when we pull out all the
values that are less than or equal to
0.05 for the P values and if we go up
here here we go here's our P I knew it
was up here I just wasn't seeing it
correctly so you probably see duration
that's going to be good amount 0.01 that
looks good instance instant
inst rate
which I'm guessing is the percentage
rate or the interest it's trying to say
in inst and interest at the same time so
we have our interest rate and all this
if we come down here we see duration
amount our instant rate age checking
account a13 checking account A14 credit
history a34 savings account 865. these
are our primary features these ones are
related when we look at the data
these are the ones that are going to
predict whether it's a good or bad loan
and so now that we know which ones work
we want to go ahead and create our
recreate our SM model or our final logit
model and you'll see here we now have
the X-ray the Y train and then instead
of the X train it's x-train significant
variables right there so all we're doing
is is running this just on the
significant variables in the setup and
we'll go ahead and fit it and you can
see here you can actually double bracket
and do it all in one line up above we
had to do it and the two lines which is
how the um setup is for this particular
module and then we'll go ahead and do a
final legit summary and just see what
that looks like and we can see here
here's our P scores remember they're all
supposed to be under 0.0 underneath the
0.05 these are all under 0.05 you can
see up here different statuses as far as
how it ran it still took six iterations
to go through the data the date and so
forth and now that we have a solid model
and that's if you remember correctly let
me flip back on over here we've done our
data modeling we've created a solid
model and so now we need to actually run
a prediction so that we can interpret
the results and weigh in on that and see
how good they are and so for that I'm
going to go ahead and let's see let me
find it over here
uh why predict so we have our model that
we created we want to go ahead and
create our y predict and it's based on
our final object and here's the magic
word predict or dot predict
um and so this is where we're going to
come in and actually get our predictions
on here that our model comes up and
remember we're testing
um X test is going in there's our X test
and it's only the significant variables
so we've created our model now we want
to push in our test version that's never
seen this data before so this is all new
and then we're just going to take a
random sample to see what it looks like
what do those predictions look like
in this random sample we're just looking
at 10 of these and you can see here is
the actual number it says 0.08 gives us
a 1.07
this is our probability number which is
I would have to actually look to see
whether higher or lower is better I'm
guessing the closer to
zero the better it is but I'm not
completely sure on that I have to
actually look up on and see what this
particular framework
uh but you can see the actual prediction
one zero zero zero so I guess this is a
good loan a bunch of defaults and some
good loans that's what it predicts it's
going to come out as now just looking at
the data
um you know it's confusing this is you
have different models they have
different setup they have the predicted
probability comes out on this and other
models it doesn't so you really need a
tool to dig deeper into the setup to
understand what this means and so what
we're going to do is we're going to take
our predicted values which you can see
right here has an actual predicted
probability
and then we're going to go ahead and
insert on there
from a sample let me just run this
because it'll make a lot more sense we
have our actual value and our predicted
value so this is what we predicted and
this is the actual setup if we just look
at this right off the bat we can see
that we predicted zero and this was a
one these all came out correct number
332 came out correct 917 was an actual
they were good on their loan they
predicted it's going to be a default you
start to see that there's some variants
so how do we measure that how do we know
whether our model was any good or not
well for that we're going to go ahead
and load up a nice graft and we'll use
for our graph we'll import matplot
Library Pi plot
in Seaborn Seaborn sits on matplot
Library
in this matplot Library inline is just
because I'm using Jupiter notebook with
the new version I'm in it doesn't even
need it but I tend to leave it in for
older versions and then we import from
our sklearn metrics this is your scikit
site kit is the main package and SK
learn is how it looks on here and we'll
go ahead and run that so it's nicely
loaded and then we'll go ahead and
create a little routine
in just a moment here
to print this out so we can see what
that looks like
and this metrics is kind of a fun
metrics because it it tells you like how
many you have correct on the correct one
how many you had wrong on the wrong one
and this top part is just all a draw
routine
so it comes in here and has our actual
and are predicted and it's our CM
metrics it breaks it up puts it into the
heat map the SN heat map gives it some
colors
add some labels and then go ahead and
show it and we're just going to dump
that in there and run that
and you can spend forever building
Graphics is so much fun
we come in here we have bad credit good
credit
uh we have bad credit good credit we
have predicted label
and so when you look at this you can see
here it had
on the good credit
it tells you how well it predicted it
and how many false positive it has and
on our bad credit
here we have bad credit bad credit it
said 30 of those
we're bad credit it predicted them bad
credit
while 21 were good credit that it
predicted would be bad credit
and then we have here we have 188 that
were good credit
uh but the actual value and then it had
61 there were bad credit that it said
were predicted good credit uh so at this
point you look at this and you'd say
well if I'm predicting
these are
this is our good credit here let me flip
this on over here and this is our bad
credit there we go
uh so we have bad credit good credit you
start looking at and you say okay can we
afford that many defaults after five
years or whatever it is
um and so those are the questions you
start asking is does this model work
good enough to predict whether we should
give these people loans or not you're
always going to have somebody default on
them and again that starts going into
domain uh banking domain something I
don't know very much about clearly I
know whether I default that alone or not
which I don't and I try very hard not to
and then if we're going to draw the
chart which is really nice to have just
a clear visual chart metrics also has
our classification report and you can
see these are just the numbers we are
looking at they let us know the
Precision
our F score and recall and all that
stuff on here you can just print the
straight out metrics classification
report now we looked at a regression
model let's go ahead and look at a
clustering model to see what that looks
like and we'll go ahead and create a new
Troop
python on there
and this is going to be our
clustering setup let me flip this off
and switch on over to my clustering menu
in this case we're going to be looking
at k-means clustering
so let's just put that up here uh K
means clustering
now the last one was a regression model
so it figured out coefficients for lines
you can go back to your old euclidean
geometry or the algebra expression for
slope on a line Y equals MX plus b or
whatever
and it goes on from there as far as
finding distances and figuring out the
lines on there this is a little bit
different we talk about clustering it
uses similar ideas but it has to do with
edges two points and how do you figure
out a distance between two points and
what does that mean
now you'll see here we have our pandas
PD our numpy is NP our matplot library
Seaborn sits on matplot libraries we
talked about
um they've added some perimeters here as
far as colors and then we did an inline
for the matplot library again that's not
really necessary even in the new version
of the Jupiter notebook in the old
version Jupiter notebook if you didn't
do that it would just kind of hang or
disappear
and then we're going to import some data
it's important to have our data set up
in here
and instead of looking at this and
guessing what the data is
usually you open up the CSV file at this
time let's just go ahead and print it
under the DF head
because really those those text files
are so messy and you look at the DF head
and it's easy to look at
whoops had a path issue there so College
data it's a CSV so automatically notice
there's a DOT CSV on there
and we can see here that they downloaded
from a number of colleges
um
Abilene Christian University Adelphi
University Adrian College
and then it has whether it's private I'm
guessing yes or no apps I'm not sure
what that is acceptance rate
applications and bidding and then the
acceptance rate enrollment top 10
percent top two five percent undergrad
so on so these are just statistics based
on the college they're College getting
into a college
and just like we did before let's
explore the data if you can remember
from the chart we were looking at we're
going through our data Discovery data
preparation and exploratory data
analysis so we're really kind of looking
at the data and what do we have here
what came in at this point the data has
already been prepared we're not doing a
whole lot as far as getting rid of null
values and finding out whether it's bad
data or good data and that kind of thing
and data Discovery would be figuring out
which data to sit so that we've already
done
so we're going to go to the exploratory
data jump into Data modeling and
interpret the results just like we did
with the other one
and we'll go ahead and use the panda
tool to get the info DF you'll see DF
very commonly it just stands for data
frame a lot of people use it as a
generic setup when they import from
pandas
and so we have our info and you can see
right here uh
non-null numbers here's our count so
each one of these has 777 non-null
values
and again here's our type of data we're
dealing with
and if you remember from last time
here's an object
um this was our yes or no everything
else looks like it's integer we do have
a float value here uh integer integer
floats and integers usually they're when
you're running them on a prediction
they're pretty interchangeable in a lot
of cases but whether it's private true
or false that's pretty important on here
the fact that they could probably be
switched to a zero or one is pretty
helpful also
and if we're going to look at all that
data we can go ahead and describe it so
there's our data frame describe
and you have the same thing here's our
count all these should be 777.
we have the mean value so you can
actually look at what our average is
standard deviation
minimum different quartiles 25 50 the
third quartile that so on and of course
our max value on there Min and Max
as we explore the data we can do a lot
of fun things on here we're going to use
our Seaborn
and we're going to look at a room and
board versus graduation date we're going
to add this is going to be a heat map so
we're going to add whether it's a
private college or not
how it fits the size the aspect ratio
and all that that's what this line is
here Seaborn you can almost do your own
class on matplot library in Seabourn
because there's so many features in
there but when you look at the very
Basics you can throw up some data
and have a nice colorful map set up
and here we have our graduation rate
compared to room and board costs and in
private or
um public
so you can see that the graduation rate
compared to room and board interesting
thought how much did I spend on room and
board am I going to graduate the more I
spend on room and board and you can see
it numbers go up there on graduation
rate and you can see that the graduation
rate tends to go way up for your private
schools and the room and board also goes
continues to grow on private schools
kind of thing it's kind of just a fun
heat map
and we can explore other things in our
doing our heat Maps we can look at out
of state whether it's out of state
undergrad private again is one of our
setups on here and you can see here that
um
for undergrad there certainly is a lot
more public schools and whether it's out
of state
interestingly enough the out of state
number goes way up how many people
coming from out of state into the school
for the private schools just kind of fun
things if you're trying to figure out
where you're going to go maybe you'd
want to do this for picking a bachelor's
degree or a master's degree or something
or certainly you could also plot this
with fun locations and download
information on
uh tourism sites if you're traveling
that kind of thing you do the same kind
of thing with and we'll go ahead and
throw out another map on here
um let me go and run this this is a
slightly different setup on here with
the out of state
and so we're running let's see pull this
up
uh bins 20
the bins is each how many uh bins are
you going to split it into and this is
kind of a fun one where you can see
private versus public we have how many
out of state and
I'd have to look this up to see what
they picked on here
oh there we go okay so you can see we
have another chart that has to do with
the out of state and the number of
students coming in and private and
public
so a lot of different setups on here as
we dig into the different graphing
so at this point we've just been kind of
looking at the graphs on here let's go
ahead and import our cluster our k-means
cluster
and you can see here we have we're going
to call it km I guess for k-means or
maybe it's K means model I always label
mine with model
equals K means in clusters equals two
random State equals 90.
uh and so where when we cluster it we're
only going to Cluster into two groups
that's what this this is meaning here
um across the different settings on
there and then we're going to go ahead
and fit and we're going to drop private
so we're not we're not going to be
looking at whether it's a private or
public school we're just going to go
ahead and
run the cluster on there
and then once we run the cluster on
there we can actually look at cluster
centers let's go ahead and do that on
this
we talk about K means let me run this
boom there we go so we have
all these different columns and each of
those columns has a center and we start
looking how the data comes together on
those centers that's what all these
numbers this is the hidden stuff behind
the Clusters on here
and so we can now do maybe we'll create
a little converter here if private
equals yes return one else returns zero
we're going to run our cluster private
and apply the converter
uh and then we'll go ahead and print
that out let me just show you what that
looks like so you can see what we're
doing here
go ahead and do uh DF cluster we'll
create a new column on here private
apply converter
and we can see here it creates some
private apps except we've just added on
to our data frame on here
and we did that so that we can run the
confusion Matrix
make sure we import our confusion Matrix
we're going to do a classification
report confusion Matrix and we'll go
ahead and run this on our clustering
and as you can see here as were
predictions here's our confusion Matrix
up here just like we had on the other
setup where it has how many
false true false false uh true false and
false false as your accuracy and our
setup on there this is really if you're
looking at which where you want to go
maybe you're looking at where you want
to go in a I think more of a tourism
thing but um for colleges this is a
great way for looking for a bachelor's
or a masters uh coming in here and you
can start finding out which one you want
to go to based on this accuracy whether
it's private or public
or how many graduations are on there if
you are one of the aspiring data
scientists looking for online training
and graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with data
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learn
skeltic post-graduate programming data
science in collaboration with IBM the
link is mentioned in the description box
and you should navigate to the home page
where you can find a complete order of
the program being offered so let's start
with what is number numpy is the core
library for scientific and numerical
Computing in Python it provides high
performance multi-dimensional array
object and tools for working with arrays
and I'll go a step further and say there
are so many other modules in Python
built on numpy so the fundamentals of
numpy are so important to latch onto for
the python so that you can understand
the other modules and what they're doing
numbers main object is a
multi-dimensional array it's a table of
elements usually numbers all of the same
type indexed by a tuple of position
integers in numpy dimensions are called
axes take a one-dimensional array or we
have remember dimensions are also called
axes you can say this is the first axis
0 1 2 3 4 5. and you can see down here
it has a shape of six why because
there's six different elements in it in
the one dimension array and they usually
denote that as six comma with an empty
node on there and then we have a two
dimensional array where you can see zero
one two three four five six seven and in
here we have two axes or two dimensions
and the shape is two four so if you were
looking at this as a matrix or another
mathematical functions you can see
there's all kinds of importance on shape
we're not going to cover shape today but
we will cover that in part two did you
know that numpy's array class is called
ND array for numpy data array now we're
going to take a detour here because
we're working in Python and two of my
favorite Tools in Python is the Jupiter
notebook and then I like to use that
sitting on top of anaconda and if you
flip over to jupiter.org that's jump e y
t e r dot org you can go in here you can
install it off of here if you don't want
to use the Anaconda notebook but this is
the Jupiter setup the documentation on
the Jupiter Jupiter opens up in your web
browser that's what makes it so nice is
this portable the files are saved on
your computer they do run an IPython or
iron Python and you can create all kinds
of different environments in there which
I'll show you in just a minute I myself
like to use Anaconda that's
www.anaconda.com if you install Anaconda
it will install the jupyter notebook
with the Anaconda separate and you can
install Jupiter notebook and it'll run
completely separate from anaconda's
Jupiter notebook and you can see here
I've now opened up my anaconda Navigator
what I like about the Navigator and this
is a fresh install on a new computer
which is always nice I can launch my
Jupiter notebook from in here I can
bring other tools so the Anaconda does a
lot more and under environments I only
have the one environment and I can open
up the terminal specific to this
environment this one happens to have
python 37 in it the most current version
as of this tutorial and then you open a
terminal if you're going to do your pip
installs and stuff like that for
different modules you can also create
different environments in here so maybe
you need a python36 python35 you can see
we're having a nice framework like
Anaconda really helps so you don't have
to chat track that on your own in the
Jupiter notebook in your different
Jupiter notebook setups we'll go ahead
and launch this Jupiter notebook and
then I've set my browser window for a
deep fault of chrome so it's going to
open up in Chrome and you can see here
this opens up a folder on my computer we
have a couple different options on here
remember I set the environment up as
python 3.7 you would install any
additional modules that aren't already
installed in your python on this and it
keeps them separate so you do have to
for each environment install the
separate modules so they match the
environment on there and in here we have
a couple things we can look up what's
running do you have your different
clusters again this is I just installed
this on a new machine so I just have the
one a couple things in here that were
run on here recently and what we go on
here is we then have on the upper right
new and from the pull down menu you'll
see python3 and this will open up a new
window
and now we're in Jupiter python so this
is a python window and we'll just do a
print
and this of course is this little hello
world
and we'll run that and it prints out
hello world in the command line there's
a couple special things you have to know
we're not going to do today which is on
Graphics if you've never seen this
one of the things you can do is you can
also do a equals hello world and if you
just put the a in there now if you do a
bunch of these we have a equals hello
world b equals goodbye world and you put
a b a then return B it'll only run the
last one but you can see here if you put
the variable down here it will show you
what's in that variable
and that has to do with the Jupiter
notebook inline coding so that's not
basic python that's just jupyter
notebook shorthand which you'll see in a
little bit so back to our numpy numpy
array versus python list python list
being the basic list in your python why
should we use numpy array when we have
python list well first it's fast the
numpy array has been optimized over
years and years by multiple programmers
and it's usually very quick compared to
the basic python list setup it's
convenient so it has a lot of
functionality in there that's not in the
basic python list and it also uses less
memory so it's optimized both for Speed
and memory use and let's go ahead and
jump into our Jupiter notebook since
we're coding best way to learn coding is
to code just like the best way to learn
how to write is write and the best way
to learn how to cook is cook so let's do
some coding here today and just like any
modules we have to import numpy we
almost always import it as NP that is
such a standard so you'll see that very
commonly we can just run that and now we
have access to our numpy module Insider
Python and then the most common thing of
course is to go and create a number
array and in here we can send it a
regular list
and so we'll go ahead and send this a
regular array let's go one two three to
make it simple and then I'm just going
to type in a and we'll run this
and so you can see down here the output
is an array of one two three and we
could also do
print just a reminder that this is an
inline command so that wouldn't work if
you're using a different editor you can
see that it's an array one two three but
we'll go and leave it as a
kind of a nice feature so you can see
what you're doing really quick in the
jupyter notebook and just like all your
other standard arrays I can go a of 0
which is going to be a value of one of
course we do a of one you go all the way
through this
I have one has a value of 2 in it so
whether using that numpy array or the
basic python list that's going to be the
same that should all look pretty
familiar and be pretty straightforward
remember the first value is always zero
and when we set on there so let's take a
look why we're using numpy because we
went over the slide a little bit but
let's just take a look and see what that
actually looks like and what we want to
look at is the fact that it's fast
convenient and uses less memory so let's
take a glance at that in code and see
what that actually looks like when we're
writing it in Python and what the
differences are
and to do this I'm going to go ahead and
import a couple other modules we're
going to import the time module so we
can time it and we're going to import
the system module so that we can take a
look at how much memory it uses and
we'll go and just run those so those are
imported and so we'll do b equals a
range of one yeah 1000 is fine
and so that's going to create a list of
100 0 to 999 remember it starts at zero
and it stops right at the 1000 without
actually going to the 1000. and let's go
ahead and print
and we want system dot get size of
and we'll pick any integer because we
have you know zero to a thousand we'll
just throw one in there five it doesn't
matter because it's gonna whatever
integer we put in there is going to
generate the same value it's looking the
size of how how much memory it stores an
integer in
and then we want to have the link of the
B that's how many integers are in there
and if we go ahead and execute this and
run this in a line we'll see Oops I did
that wrong comma if we multiply them
together
we'll see it generates twenty eight
thousand so that's the size we're
looking at is twenty eight thousand I
believe that's bytes that sounds about
right
so let's go ahead and create this in
numpy and we'll go with C equals NP and
this is a range
so that's the numpy command to do the
same thing that we were just doing in a
list
and we'll also use the same value on
there the 1000
and then once we've created the C value
of C for NP dot a range let's go ahead
and print and we can do that by doing C
dot size
times C dot item size
well that's very similar we did before
we did get the size of so the C size is
the size of the array and each item size
just reversed so it's the size of an
integer five item size is going to be
the integers and C size now let's just
take a look and see what that generates
and wow okay we got 4 000 versus 28 000.
that's a significant difference in
memory how much memory we're using with
the array and then let's go and take a
look at speed let's do oh let's do size
we trade this with lower values and it
would happen so fast that the npra kept
coming up with zero
because it just rounded it off so size
and let's create an L1
Bulls range of size
and we'll do an L2
I'll just set up to the same thing it's
also range
of size on there there we go
and then we can do on A1
equals NP Dot
a range size
and then let's do an A 2 equals NP dot a
range we'll keep it the same size
and what we're going to do is we're
going to take these two different arrays
and we're going to perform some basic
functions on them
but let's go ahead actually just load
these up now we'll go ahead and run this
so those are all set in memory
except for the typo here
quickly fix that
there we go so these are now all loaded
in here and let's do a start equals
time dot time
so it's just going to look at my clock
time and see what time it is and it will
do result equals and let's do oh let's
say we got an array and we're going to
say
let's do some addition here X Plus y
for X comma y
in and we'll zip it up here
two different arrays so here's our two
different arrays we're going to multiply
each of the individual things on here L1
L2
there we go so that should add up each
value so L1 plus L2 each value in each
array
and then we want to go ahead and print
and let's say python list took
and then we'll do
time
dot time
we'll just subtract the start out of
there so time whoops I messed up on some
of the quotation marks on there
okay there we go
time minus the start
and we'll convert that to seconds so
we'll go to this in milliseconds or
times one thousand
and let's hit the run on there it's kind
of fun because you also get a view while
we're doing this of some ways to
manipulate the script
and as you can see also my bad typing
there we go okay so we'll go ahead and
run this
and we can see here that the python list
took 34
actually I have to go back and look at
the conversion on there but you can see
it takes roughly 0.34 of a second and we
can go ahead and print the result in
here too
let's do that
and we'll run that just so you can see
what the what kind of data we're looking
at
and we have the zero two four six eight
so it's just adding them together it
looks pretty straightforward on there
and if we scroll down to the bottom of
the answer again we see python list took
46 a little different time on there
depending on what um core because I have
this is on an eight core computer so it
just depends on what course running on
what else is pulling on the computer at
the time and let's go back up here and
do our start time paste that into here
and this time we're going to do a result
equals and this is really cool notice
how elegant this is It's So
straightforward this is for a lot of
reasons people started using numpy is
because I can add the two arrays
together by simply going A1 Plus A2
makes a lot of sense both looking at it
and it's just very
convenient remember this slide we're
looking at fast convenient and less
memory so look how convenient that is
really easy to read real easy to see and
I don't know if we don't need to print
the result again so let's just go ahead
and print the time on here and we'll
borrow this from the top part
because I really am a lazy typer
this isn't the python list this is the
numpy list or numpy array
and let's go ahead and see how that
comes out and we get 2.99
so let's take a look at these two
numbers 46 versus 2.99 so we'll just
round this up to three that's a huge
difference that's that's like more than
10 times faster that's like 15 times
roughly at a quick glance I'd have to go
do the math to look at it and it's going
to vary a little bit depending on what's
running in the background the computer
obviously so we've looked at this and if
we go back here we found out it's much
faster yes there's different going to be
different speeds depending on what
you're doing with the array very
convenient easy to read and it uses less
memory so that's the core of the numpy
that's why a lot of people base so many
other modules on numpy and why it's so
widely used
so we did glance at a couple operations
we were looking at speed and size let's
dive into a little bit more into the
basic operations
and these are always nice to see I mean
certainly you want to go get a cheat
sheet if you're using it for the first
time you know look things up Google is
your friend we did this we're the most
basic numpy dot array or np.array and
we'll go ahead and create an array let's
do pairs one comma two
and then let's do a three comma four and
if we do that let's do five comma six
let's go and if we go ahead and take
this and run this I can go ahead and do
our a down here so it's in line and I'll
print that out
you can see it makes a nice array for us
so we have a and if you look at that we
have three different objects each with
two values in them and hopefully you're
starting to think well how many
dimensions or indexes is that and you'll
see three by two so let's go ahead and
take a look and let's go how about a dot
in Dimensions speaking of which we'll
run that and we have two dimensions for
each object
and then we can do the item size so a
DOT we saw this earlier we looked up how
many items it was up here where we
wanted to multiply item size times the
actual size of the object so the memory
is being used versus the item size
and we should see four there
memory is compressed down that's always
a good thing
and then the shape the shape is so
important when you're working with data
science and you're moving it from one
format to another
so we have our shape we just talked
about that we have three by two three
rows by two objects in each one
generally I don't look too much at the
size but the dimensions I'm always
looking up this is nice you can automate
it so you might be converting something
you might need to know how many
dimensions are going into the next
machine learning package so that you can
automatically just have it send that
information over
so we looked at a shape let's go and
create a slightly different array NP dot
array let's go ahead and just do as our
original
set up here
and one of the features we can do which
is really important is we can do D type
equals in this case let's do NP
float 64. and so what we've done is
converting all of these into a float and
we type in a
and now instead of having one two three
four five six you see they're all float
values 1.0 there's no actual zero in
there just shows the one dot or the one
period two three period four period five
period six period
and this again data science I don't know
how many times I've had to convert
something from an integer to a float so
it's going to work correctly in the
model I'm using so very common features
to be aware of and to be able to get
around and use
and we'll also do let's just curiosity
item size
we'll go and run that
and we see that it doubled in size so
it's not a huge increase well doubling
is always a big increase in computers
but it's not a huge increase compared to
what it would be if you're running this
in the python list format
and then we did the shape earlier
without having it set to the float 64.
let's go ahead and do a shape with it
set to 64. and it should be the same
three comma two so it all matches so
we've gone through and remember if you
really if this is all brand new to you
according to the Cambridge study at the
Cambridge University if you're learning
a brand new word in a foreign language
the average person has to repeat it 163
times before it's memorized
so a lot of this you build off of it so
hopefully you don't have to repeat it
163 times but we did manage to repeat it
at least twice here if not a little bit
more and let's go ahead and take this
we're going to go look at one more setup
on here and let me just take this last
statement here on the converting our
properties of our data and instead of
float 64
let's do complex let's just see what
that looks like and let's go ahead and
print that out and run it
and so we now have a complex data set up
and you'll see it's denoted by the one
dot plus 0 dot j
and if we flip over here and do a basic
search for numpy data types better to go
to the original web page but pull up a
bunch of these you can see there's a
whole list of different numpy data types
shorthand complex we have complex
complex 64 complex 128 complex number
represented by 264-bit floats real and
imaginary components
one option on there float 16 float 32
float shorthand for float 64 most
commonly used and of course all the
different ones that you can possibly put
into your numpy array so we covered a
basic Edition up there we're comparing
how fast it runs but some very basic
components how to set up a numpy array
how many dimensions it has item size
data type item again we went to item
size and there's also the
shape probably one of the more used I
used a shape all the time very commonly
used
and then down here you can see where we
actually created a numpy complex data
type
so let's look at some other features in
numpy one of them is you could do numpy
Dot
zeros
and we're going to do three comma four
there we go and we'll go ahead and run
this and you can see if I do NP dot
zeros I create an empty array of zeros
this is really important I was building
my own neural network and I needed to
create an array where I initialized the
weights and I want them all to be the
same weight in this case I want them to
start off as zero for the particular
project I was working on and there's
other options that you can do on p1s
and we'll do the same thing three comma
four we'll run that and you can see I've
created a an array of numpy ones in this
case it comes out as a float array
and this is an interesting to note
because we have let's go back to our
Python and do L Range Five
and we'll print the L so there's our
list and if I run that
it doesn't create the range and tell
after the fact until you actually
execute it that's an upgrade in python
python 27 actually created the array
zero one two three four this one
actually creates the script and then
once it's used it then actually
generates the array and if we do that in
numpy a Range remember that from before
and if we do a numpy a range 5
and let's do a
l or we can just leave it as numpy
that's probably there we go just run
that
you can see there we actually get an
array 0 1 2 3 4 for the value of the
numpy arrange a range five generates the
actual array
and for part one we're going to do just
one more section on basic setup
and we're going to concatenation
concatenation example
there we go we're gonna do strings let's
take a look at strings what's going on
with there and let's do
oh let's see print
Let's do an NP character something new
here
and we're going to add and then here's
our brackets for what we're going to add
oh and let's say
um let's do
hello
comma High
and in the brackets on there let's
create another one
and this one's going to be
ABC and we'll do
x y z so we're just creating something
randomly making sum up on here and then
we'll go ahead and just print this
if we run that and come down here and of
course make sure all your brackets are
open and closed correctly and then you
can see in here when we concatenate the
example in numpy it takes the two
different arrays that we set up in there
and it combines the hello with the ABC
and the high with x y z
and if we can also do something like
print oh let's do NP character dot
multiply
so there's a lot of different functions
in here again you can look these up it's
probably good to look them all up and
see what they are but it's good to also
just see them in action let's do hello
space comma three
and we'll run this one
and run that without the error you'll
see it does hello hello hello so we
multiplied it by three and we can also
let's just take this whole thing here
instead of retyping it
and we can do character Center so
instead of multiply this to Center
and over here keep our hello going
the space out of there and let's do
Center at 20.
and fill character
equals we'll fill it with dashes
so if we run this
you can see it prints out the hello with
dashes on each side and we keep going um
with that we can also in addition to
doing the fill function we can play with
capitalize we can title we can do
lowercase we can do uppercase we can
split split line strip join these are
all the most common ones and let's go
ahead and just look at those and see
what those look like each one of them
so we're going to do the hello world
all-time favorite of mine I would like
to say Hello Universe and you can see
here we do Capital H with the world but
so we want to capitalize so capitalize
is the first one in the array so we get
Hello World on there and we can also
take this and instead of capitalizing
another feature in here is title and
let's just change this to how are we
doing
how are you doing
let's run that
and you can see here because we created
it as a title that capitalizes the first
letter in each word
and in this one we're going to do
character lower
two different examples here we have an
array we have Hello World all
capitalized and we have just hello and
you can see that one is an array and one
is just a string if we run that you get
a an array with Hello World lowercase
and hello lowercase and if we're going
to do it that way we can also do it the
opposite way there's also upper
and let's paste those in there and you
can see here we have character Dot Upper
opposite there
python.data and we'll do python is easy
hopefully you're starting to get the
picture that most of the Python and the
scripting is very simple is when you put
the bigger picture together and starts
building these puzzles and somebody asks
you hey I need the first letter
capitalized unless it's the title and
then we have you start realizing that
this can get really complicated so numpy
just makes it simple and we like that
and so in this case we did python data
it's all uppercase python is easy like
shouting in your messenger python is
easy and then if you're ever processing
text and tokenizing it a lot of times
the first thing you do is we just split
the text and we're just going to run
this in P dot character.split are you
coming to the party if we do that it
returns an array of each of the
individual words are you coming to the
party splitting it by the spaces
and then if you're going to split it by
spaces we also need to know how to split
it by lines
and just like we have the basic split
command we also have split lines hello
and you'll see here the scoop in for our
new line
and when we run that if you're following
the split part with the words you should
see hello how are you doing the two
different lines are now split apart
and let's just review three more before
we wrap this up commonly used string
variable manipulations we have strip and
in this case we have Nina admin Anita
and we're going to strip a off of there
let's see what that looks like and then
you end up with nin dominate it
basically takes up all leading and
trailing letters in this case we're
looking for a more common would be a
space in there but it might also be
punctuation or anything like that that
you need to remove from your letters and
words and if we're going to strip and
clean data we also need to be able to
reformat it or join it together so you
see here we have a character joined
we'll go ahead and run this
and it has on the first one it splits
each of the letters up by the colon and
the second one by the dash and you can
see how this is really useful if you're
processing in this case a date we have
day month year year month date very
common things do we have to always
switch around and manipulate depending
on what they're going into what you're
working with
and finally let's look at one last
character string we're going to do
replace if you're doing misinformation
this is good pulling news articles
replacing is and what in this case we're
just doing he is a good dancer and we're
going to replace is with was
and you can see here he was a good
dancer hopefully that's not because he
had a bad fall he just was from like you
know 1920s and it's gotten old
so there we go we've covered a lot of
the basics in numpy as far as creating
an array very important stuff here when
you're feeding it in how do we know the
shape of it the size of it what happens
we convert it from a regular integer
into a float value as far as how much
space it takes we saw that that doubled
it item size you have your in dimensions
and probably the most used is shape I
will cover more on shape in part two so
make sure you join us on part two
because there's a lot of important
things on shaping in there and setting
them up we also saw that you can create
a zeros based array you can create one
with ones if we do a range you can see
how it is a lot easier to use to create
its own range or a range as it is in
numpy you saw how easy it was to add two
arrays we saw that earlier just plus
sign then we got into doing strings and
working with strings and how to
concatenate so if you have two different
arrays of strings you can bring them
together we also saw how you can fill so
you can add a nice headline dash dash
dash we saw about capitalize the first
letter we saw about turning it into a
title so all the first letters are
capitalized doing lowercase on all the
letters upper for all the letters just
lower and upper nice abbreviation we
also covered how to split the character
set how to strip it so if you want to
strip all the A's out from leading A's
and ending A's or spaces you can do that
very easily also how to join the data
sets so here's a character join option
for your strings and finally we did the
character replace now let's go ahead and
dive in there since we're going right
into part two which is getting some
coding going under our belt and here in
our Jupiter notebook we can go under new
and create a new folder python3 I think
I forgot to do this last time but we
could just do the control plus plus
which in any browser enlarges a page
makes it a lot easier to see always a
nice feature another beautiful benefit
of using jupyter notebook and let me go
ahead and show you a neat thing we can
do in Jupiter this is nice if you're
working with people and you're doing
this as a demo on a large screen I'm
going to do the hashtag or pound symbol
array manipulation kind of a title that
we're working on and then I'm going to
call this cell cell type markdown as
opposed to code and you'll see it
highlights it here and then if I run it
it just turns it into array manipulation
and then we're specifically going to be
working on array manipulation changing
shape to start with and we'll go ahead
and Mark this cell also a markdown so as
a nice little look there and then it
comes up and you can see it just like I
said it just highlights it it makes it
very bold print just making it easier to
read not a python thing but a Jupiter
thing that's good to know about
especially if you're working with the
shareholders since they're investing
money in you because the first thing you
want to do is import we're going to
import numpy
as in p and that should be standard by
now by now you you start a Python
program you're doing some data science
numpy is just something you bring in
there and let's go ahead and create our
array and we're going to do that as the
NP dot a range remember that's uh zero
well we're going to do 0 to 9.
and uh we'll print
a little title on the original array
we'll just print that array a remember
from the first lesson so we have our
array which is 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 and
let's add a print space in between
let's create a second array B but we
want this to reshape array a and what
does that mean
and the command is simply reshape and
then we have nine items in here and this
is so important right now so be very
aware if I did some weird numbers in
here it's not going to work
and we want multiples of nine we know
that three times three is nine so we're
going to reshape our a array by 3 by 3
and then we're going to print well let's
give it a title oops added too many
brackets in there modified array and
then let's go ahead and print
RB and let's see what that looks like
and as we come down here you can see
we've taken this and it's gone from 0 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 to an array of arrays and
we have 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8. and so we
split this into three by three and you
can guess that if I tried to reshape
this let's just do a five by three which
is 15. that's going to give me an error
so it's not going to work you're not
going to reshape something unless the
shape all the the data in there matches
correctly
so we can take this nine this flat 9 and
we call it a flex it's just a single
array and we can reshape it into a three
by three array and first you may think
matrixes which this is used for that
definitely I use it a lot in graphing
because they'll come in that I have an
array that's X Y comma X Y 1 white 1
comma X2 Y2 and so the shape of it might
be two by the length of the number of
points and I need to separate that into
X flat array and a y flat array and you
can see this can be very easy to reshape
the array doing that and we can of
course go back we can do B
print
and we'll do B dot Latin remember I said
it's called a flatten array and if we
run that you'll see this goes back to
the original one it takes this zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
flattens it back to a single array
and then one other feature to be aware
of is if we flatten it one of the
commands we can put in there is order
let me just go ahead and do that order
equals
F strangely enough F stands for Fortran
they hold fourtran days I remember
actually studying Fortran programming
language in this case you'll see that it
uses the first like zero three six is
the order so instead of flattening it
like we had before zero one two three
four five six seven eight it now does
zero three six one four seven two five
eight and if you go to the numpy array
page you can see here that they have the
flatten and you just open up the numpy
and D array flatten setup to look it up
and they have three different options
they have c f and a and it's whether to
flatten in C which was based on how the
C code works for flattening originally
worked which is row major Fortran which
is column major or preserve the column
Fortran ordering from a so whatever it
was in the default is the C version so
the default that you saw you could put
orders equals c and it'd have the same
effect as we saw there before you could
even do order equals a that would also
have the same effect because that's the
default so really the only other thing
you really should change on here is to
change it to C if you need it and you
can see right here or F I mean not C the
only thing you really want to change it
to is to your f for the Fortran order
which then does it by column versus by
row and let's look at
here we go reshape so let's create a
range of 12
and let's reshape it
I will do 4 comma 3 for this one and
remember this is numpy I forgot the NP
there
NP dot arrange
and we can type in just a for print or
you can do full print a and of course
Jupiter notebook even have a little
extra print at the beginning we run this
we'll see we create a nice array of 0 1
2 it's reshaped it so we have four rows
and three columns or you could call that
three columns and four rows zero one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
but this one is so important we'll do NP
transpose
a let's go ahead and run that
and it helps if I get all the s's in
there and don't leave an S out and
you'll see here we've taken our array if
you remember correctly we had 0 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 9 10 11 and we've swapped it so
we've gone from a three by four or a
four by three to a three by four
and this really helps if you're looking
at like a huge number of rows and the
data all comes in like let's say this is
your features in row one your features
in row two and this is x y z well when
you go to plot it you send it all of X
in one array all of one another one
array and all Z in another array
so it's really important that we can
transpose this rather quickly
this is kind of a fun thing I can
highlight it and do brackets around it
if you remember correctly
because we're in Jupiter it doesn't
matter where we do the print or not
it'll automatically print it for us and
you see if I hit the Run button it comes
up at the same exact thing and let's
play with the reshape and you know let's
end this up a little bit here
make that even bigger so you can really
see what's going on and let's play with
the reshape just a little bit more we'll
do b equals
NP dot a range let's do eight
reshape I'll do two comma four
let's go ahead and print B
and then run that
and you'll see we have now the two rows
this is a bit more like so we have four
maybe two rows of four things so this
might be all of our X components and our
y components so we can switch it back
and forth real easy important to know
here whether we do two comma four or in
the case of four comma three this has 12
elements and so however you split it up
it's got to equal 12. so 4 times 3
equals 12 that's pretty straightforward
same thing down here 2 times 4 equals
eight if I change this and let's say I
do two comma three let's just run that
in and you'll find we get an error
because you can't split 8 up into two
rows by three
we have to pick something that it can
split up and arrange it in so let's go
ahead and run that and just for fun
let's go um
reshape our B again if I can type
reshape our B again and what else goes
into eight well we could do two by two
by two
so we can take this out to three
different dimensions
and then of course if we um because this
is going to come out you as a variable
we can just go ahead and run it
and it'll print it we can also do a
print statement on there just like we
did before and you'll see we have two
different groups of two variables of two
different dimensions so two by two by
two and let's go ahead and assign this
to a variable C equals B reshape and
let's do something a little different
let's roll the axes roll
axes
and we'll take our C and do two comma
one
and if we go ahead and run this it's
going to print that out whoops
hit a wrong button there let's do that
one again and you roll the axis and you
can see that we now have a set of zero
one two three four five six seven we now
have the zero two one three four six
five seven
so what's going on here we're taking and
we're rolling the numbers around and
let's just simplify this we'll just do
it with C comma 1 and run that and so if
we roll a single axis you get 0 1
and then it rolled the four five up and
then we have two three six seven and if
we do two let me see what happens there
and this is one of those things you
really have to play with and start
filling what it's doing
we've now taken 0 2 4 6 1 3 5 7. so you
can see we've now rolled by two digits
instead of rolling the one set up we now
rolled two digits up there and so if we
go back and we do the one
so we've rolled it up 0 1 4 5 and then
we're going to take the 2 in there and
we've rolled the 0 1 2 3 4 5 and 6 7. so
we start rolling these things around on
here there's a lot of different things
you can do on this
what's another way to manipulate the
numbers on your numpy
and finally let's go ahead and swap
axes we'll do c and let's just go ahead
and run that it's going to error on
there
that's because it requires multiple
arguments left out the arguments so now
we can swap and we get the zero two one
three four six five seven so you can see
everything's been swapped around
so next thing we want to go over is we
want to go over numpy arithmetic
operations
how can we take these and use these let
me just go ahead and put this cell as a
markdown there we go we'll run that so
it has a nice thing all right nice title
on there that's always helpful
and let's start by creating two arrays
we'll do a as an EP NP
range a range nine and let's reshape
this
three by three so by now you should be
saying this reshape stuff and this
should all look pretty familiar we have
our zero one two three four five six
seven eight on there and let's create a
second one b and this time instead of
doing a range let's do NP array we'll
just create a straight up array
we'll do an array of three objects
so it's going to be three by one and if
we go ahead and print B out let me run
that this is actually pretty common to
have something like this where you have
a three by whatever it is in a three by
by three array when you're doing your
math you kind of have that kind of setup
on there
and what we can do is we can go
P dot add
a b don't forget we can always put a
print statement on there so if we add it
you'll see that it just comes in there
and it goes okay we're adding 10 to
everything and we could actually do
something more oh make it more
interesting 11 10 11 12. so it's change
B's now 10 11 12 and let's run that
and you can see that we have 10 and then
you had 1 plus 11 is 12. 2 plus 12 is 14
13 so 10 plus 3 is 13 11 plus 4 is 15
and 12 plus 5 is 17 and so on
we'll put this back since that's how the
original setup was let's do 10 by 10 by
10 and run that and run that and get the
original answer and if you're going to
add them together we need to go ahead
and subtract
a b
and we run that
we get minus 10 minus 9 minus 8 just
like you would expect so we have our
subtraction 0 minus 10 is minus 10 and
so on and if you're going to add and
subtract you can guess what the next one
is we're going to multiply
and we'll multiply
a b
and this should be pretty
straightforward you should expect this
if we multiply 10 times 0 we got 0 10
times 10 is 10 and so on
and finally if you're going to multiply
let's
divide
what happens when we do divide a by B
and we run this
we're going to get 0 and this is 0
divided by 10 is 0 1 divided by 10 is
0.1 2 divided by 10 is 0.2 and so on and
so on so that math is pretty
straightforward it just makes it very
easy to do the whole setup and again if
we went this and let's say let's change
this up up here instead of 10 we do a
hundred
and make this a thousand there we go if
we run that and then we do the add you
can see we got 10 plus 100 plus a
thousand same thing with the subtract
same thing with the multiply
and then you can also see the same thing
here with the Divide so a lot of control
there with your array and your math
again let's set this back to 10 oops
it's right up here wrong section
there we go 10 and we'll just go ahead
and run these and get back to where we
were
and this brings us to our next section
which is slicing and let's put in our
just make this a
[Music]
of course it gives us a nice looking
slicing there and slicing means we're
just going to take sections of the array
so let's create an array NP a range
let's just do 20.
and if remember if we do a we have a 0
to 19.
and then we can do a and remember we can
always print these this can always be
put in a print but because I'm in
Jupiter if you're doing a demo in
Jupiter that is it's just so great that
you have all these controls on here so
we can slice 4 on and this should look
familiar because this is the same as the
python and a lot of other different
scripting languages if we do four we'll
go zero one two three it's the first
four in the thing and the skip summon
starts with this one the first four are
skipped then from there on you can also
do the opposite
and go till the fourth one if we run
that we get 0 1 2 3 quite the opposite
on there we can do a single item so we
can pick object number five on the list
run that and five happens to be five
because that's the order they're in and
then this one's interesting so I can do
s equals slice
and let's create a slice here and let's
do two comma 9 comma
yeah let's leave a 2 on there so we'll
create an S Slice on here and then if we
take our array we do array of s we're
taking our slice in there and let's go
ahead and run that and let's take a look
and see what it generated here first off
we started with two so we have two at
the beginning we're going to end at 9
which happens to be eight so it stops
before the 9. remember when we're doing
arrays in Python and then we step two so
two four six eight we could do this as
three let me run that and you can see
how that changes two five eight
and we could do this as let's leave this
at three and if we change this to 10
oops let's make it 12. there we go
and we run that we have 2 5 8 11. so
that's pretty straightforward it's a
very nice feature to have on here where
you can slice it and take different
parts of the series right out of the
middle so now that we've accessed the
different pieces of our array and let's
get into iterating iteration and this is
interesting because my sister who runs a
college data science division is first
question she asks
is how do you go through data and she's
asking can you do you know how to
iterate through data do you know how to
do a basic for Loop do you know how to
go through each piece of the data and in
numpy they have some cool controls for
that it just sends a mark down there we
go and run it
and it's called the nditter
sure what the ND stands for but ND it or
for iterator
so before we do that though let's create
an array or something we can actually
iterate through we'll call it a equals
NP a range let's do something a little
funny here or funky
and we'll do 0 45 5. I'm not sure why
the guys in the back pick this
particular one was kind of a fun one and
if I run that we do this you can see we
get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40. that's
what this array looks like
and this is from our slice you could
this is just a slice that's all that is
is we create a slice of 0 45 0 to 45
step five and so we can do with this we
can also do a equals V shape let's go
ahead and take and reshape this and
since there's nine variables in there
we'll do a reshape at three by three so
if we run that oops miss something there
that is the a that really helps so if we
do the a reshape and we'll go ahead and
print that out we get 0 5 10 15 20 25 30
35 40. and then we simply do four x in
our numpy ND enter of a
colon and we'll just go ahead and print
X and let's see what happens here when
we run through this and we print each
one of those
it goes all the way through the whole
array so it's the same thing we just saw
before we got 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
so it prints out each object in the
array so you can go through and view
each one of these
and certainly if you remember you could
also flatten the array and just do for a
and that also and get the same result
there's a lot of ways to do this but
this is the proper way with the ND
iterator because it'll minimize the
amount of resources needed to go through
each of the different objects in the
numpy array and hopefully you asked this
question when I just did that
and the question is how can I change
this instead of doing each object so
first of all let's go ahead and take my
cell type and Mark that down run it and
so we're going to work on iteration
order C Style
C because it came from the C programming
and that's because it came from the old
Fortran programming so let's give us a
reminder I will do a print a and we'll
do four x and NP iterate a but we also
want to do this in a specific order and
you know what I'm a really lazy typer so
let's go back up here
this is the ND iterator missing the ND
part of a let's do order equals
C we'll print X on there and let's do
that again and this time order
equals
f
letting it order equals F and let's go
ahead and run this
and see what happens here and the first
thing you're going to notice our
original array 0 5 10 15 20 25 30 35 40.
when we do order C that's the default 0
5 10 15 20 and so on and then when you
come down here
you'll see F order f is 0 15 30. so it
takes the first digit of each on the sub
arrays or the second dimension and then
it goes into the second one 520 35 10 25
40. so slightly different order for
iterating through it if you need to do
that so we've covered reshaping we
covered math we've covered iteration
we've covered a number of things the
next section we want to go ahead and go
over
is going to be joining arrays so we need
to bring them together let me go ahead
and take the cell and make it a markdown
cell type markdown there we go and run
that so let's work on joining arrays so
we can bring them together and what
different options we have
and let's do we'll do an NP array one
two comma three four
we'll go ahead and print
oops
first
these Rays aren't that big so let's just
go ahead and keep it all on one line a
so if we run this first array one two
three four whoops I forgot it
automatically wraps it when you do it
this way so we'll go ahead and keep it
separate
print a there we go and let's go ahead
and do a b
and we'll do five six seven eight and
notice I'm keeping the same shape on
these two arrays depending on what
you're doing those shapes have to match
let's go ahead and print
second array
print
B go and run that up
I've missed something up there let me
fix that real quick
and I was reformatting it to go in
separate lines I messed that up there we
go run all right so we have first array
one two three four secondary five six
seven eight
and we'll put a carried return on there
and the keyword we use is concatenate
and if you're familiar with Linux it
usually means you're adding it to the
end on there and we're going to do what
they call a long axis zero so we have
concatenate a b along axis zero let's go
ahead and run that and see what that
looks like
so we have one two three four five six
seven eight so now we have an array that
is four by two has a nice shape of four
by two one here
and if we're going to do it along the
axis 0
you should guess what the next one is
we're going to do it along the one axes
and let's see how those differ from each
other let's just go ahead and run that
and again all we're doing is adding in
the axes equals one so we have our
concatenate we have a b and then axis
one remember a couple things one these
are the same shape so we have a two by
two same dimensions going in there
you're going to get an error if you're
concatenating and they're not if you
have something that instead of one two
is one two three four five six with a
five six seven eight they'll give you an
error on there in fact let's take a look
and see what happens when we do that let
me just take this
one two three three four five and let's
run that and if we come down here up we
got there it says it says all the input
array Dimensions except for the
concatenation axes M must match exactly
so it will let you know if you mess up
that's always a good thing let's go
ahead and take this back here and let's
go ahead and run that
and so we have our zero axes which is
one two three four five six seven eight
let me bring them together and you'll
see a very different setup here when we
do it along the axis one we end up with
instead of uh four by two we end up with
a two by four one two five six three
four seven eight and this is changing
which axes we're going to go ahead and
concatenate on what I find is when
you're talking about the concatenate or
the joining arrays you really got to
play with these for a while to make sure
you understand what you mean by the axes
it looks very intuitive when you're
looking at it actually 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
axes one is then splitting in a
different way one two five six three
four seven eight
when you're actually using real data you
start to really get a feel for what this
means and what this does
so if we're going to do that let's go
ahead and look at splitting the array
and do that in a markdown and run it
there we go so you have a nice little
title there
and we'll go ahead and create an array
of nine
let's do NP split
we'll do a and we're going to split it
by three
let's just see what that looks like so
if we split it we get an array 0 1 2 3 4
5 we get three separate arrays on here
now remember we're looking at let me
just print a up here
so we're looking at zero one two three
four five six seven eight and then we
can split it into three separate arrays
and let's take this we're going to do
this right down here let's move the a
split down here instead of the three
let's do four comma five put that in
Brackets
and so we do it this way we have zero
one two three four five six seven eight
and that's kind of interesting I wasn't
sure what to expect on that but we get
when you split an a by four comma five
you get a totally different setup on
here as far as the way it split the
array
and to understand how this works I'm
going to change the five to a 7. and
this will visually make this a little
bit more clear
so we had four and five I went zero one
two three four five six seven eight and
you see the markers four and five when
we do four and seven I get zero one two
three four five six seven eight and so
what you're looking at here is the first
markers this is going to go to four
so there's our first split at the four
the marker of four and then the second
split is going to be at position seven
and this is the same thing here a four
position five that's why we're splitting
it in those two sections we could also
do it seven let's just see what that
looks like run and you can see I now
have zero one two three four five six
seven eight
so we could split it in all kinds of
different ways and create a different
set of multiple arrays on here and split
it all kinds of different ways and
before we get into the graphs and other
miscellaneous stuff
let's go ahead and look at resizing the
array we'll go ahead and take the cell
and it sells a markdown and run it
give us a nice title there and we'll do
an array an npro of one two three and
four five six here I'm just going to
just print
let's go print a DOT shape then we'll go
ahead and run that whoops hit a wrong
button there
hit the comma instead of the dot so we
have a shape of two comma three here
and this is important to note because
when we start resizing it it's going to
mess with different aspects of the shape
and so we'll go ahead and do a print
scoop in for a blank line there we go
let's do b equals
NP dot resize
we're going to resize a
and let's resize it with three by two
and then we'll just go ahead and
print
B
and print the period shape not a comma
I'll run that
oops forgot the quotation marks around
the end I'll go ahead and run that and
let's just see what that looks like so
we have one two three four five six
original array with the shape of two
three
and then we want to go ahead and resize
it by three two and we end up with one
two three four five six and we end up
with the shape of three two that
shouldn't be too much of a surprise you
know we got six elements in there we can
resize it by two three was the original
one and then we're actually just
reshaping is how that kind of comes out
as when you resize it like that
but what happens if we do something a
little different
and let's go ahead and just take this
whole thing and copy it down here so we
can see what that looks like
and instead of doing three two remember
last time I did the um to reshape it I
messed with the numbers and it gave me
an error well when you resize it you
don't have to match the numbers they
don't have to be the same dimensions so
we can instead of going from a 2 3 to a
3 2 we can resize it to a three three so
let's take a look and see how it handles
that and we come down here to 3 3 we end
up with one two three four five six and
it repeats one two three
so it actually takes the data and just
adds a whole other Block in there based
on the
and repeating it
all right now at this point you know
we've been looking at tons of numbers
and moving stuff around we want to go
ahead and do is get a little visual here
because it um
certainly you can picture all the
different numbers on there but let's
look at the histogram let's put this
into a histogram let me go ahead and run
that
and to do that we're going to use the
matplot library so from matplot library
we're going to import pipelot as PLT
that's usually the notation you see for
pipelot so if you ever see PLT in a code
it's probably Pi plot in the matplot
library
and then the guys in the back did a nice
job and gals too guys and gals back
there our team over at simply learn put
together a nice array for me 2087 4 40
53 with a bunch of numbers that way we
had something to play with and what we
want to do is we want to do plot the
histogram now remember a histogram says
how many times different numbers come in
and then we're going to put them in bins
and we have been 0 to 20 to 40 to 60 to
80 to 100.
you might in here with the matplot
library they call them bins you might
hear the term buckets or they put them
in buckets as a really common term then
we want to give it a title so the way it
works is you do your plt.hist for
histogram your PLT title and your PLT
show and we're doing just a single array
in here in the numpy array of a and
let's go ahead and run this piece of
code
taking a moment to come out there says
finger size so it's generating the graph
and you can see we have and let's just
take a look at this and go down a size
there we go okay so now we can see we're
taking a look at here so between 0 and
20 we have three values so we have a 20
here we have a four and a 11 and a 15.
zero one two three it's actually Four
values but they start at zeros remember
we always count from zero up
and from 20 to 40 we got 20 this is 142.
3 4
5 6.
and so you can see in the histogram it
shows that the most common numbers
coming up is going to be between the 40
and 60 range least common between the 80
and 100 this looks like an age
demographics is what this looks like to
me and you can see where they would have
put it in the buckets of different age
groups which would be a nice way of
looking at this histograms are so
important and so powerful when you're
doing demos and explaining your data so
being able to quickly put a histogram up
that shows what's common and how it's
trending is really important and using
that with a numpy is really easy and you
know what let's take the same data and I
want to show you why we do bins or why
we have buckets of data I'm used to
calling it buckets why we have bins
let's do it instead of by 20 let's do it
by tens and see what happens
and what happens when you do it by tens
is you miss out on the you can see a
nice curve here on the first one and on
the second one it looks like a ladder
going up and a plummet a letter going up
and a plummet and a ladder going down
so the first would be more indicative of
an age group and the second one would be
what you would get if you divide it
incorrectly you wouldn't see the natural
trend
I don't know what this would be maybe
how much food they eat hopefully not
because I'm in 50 so I'm right in the
middle there that which means I get a
ton of food compared to everybody else
but it's some kind of demographic maybe
it's mental maybe it's knowledge because
we we hit a certain point and we start
losing our marbles start leaking out or
something so you start off knowing
something and then as you get older you
grow more but you can see here we lose
that you lose that continuity in the
thing if you split the histogram into
too many bins or too many buckets
and if you actually plotted this by the
individual numbers it would just be a
bunch of dots on
if it wouldn't mean a whole lot
and in fact that graphs there turns out
there are a ton of useful functions in
numpy
I'm sure there's even new ones that are
aren't going to be in here but let's
just cover some important ones you
really need to know about if you're
using the numpy framework
one of them is Lane space function this
is generating data so you have a line
space we have one three ten and when we
do that we end up with 10 numbers so if
you count them there's 10 numbers
they're between 1 and 3 and they're
evenly spaced we get 1 1.222 but these
are all there's a total of 10 here and
it's right between the one and three
range
that could be there's a lot of uses for
that but they're probably more obscure
than a lot of the other common numpy
arrays set up
a real common one is to do summation so
we'll do summation where you do in this
case we create a numpy array of one of
two different arrays One Two Three or
two different dimensions one two three
three four five and we're going to sum
them up under axes zero which is your
columns and if you remember correctly
columns is the one plus three two plus
four three plus five so we have three
columns and if we change this we'll just
flip this to one
we get two numbers so we get one two
three all added together which equals
six and three plus four plus five which
equals twelve
which is zero
there we go since it says we're looking
at zero
and these probably could have been some
of these could be able to start math
section square root and standard
deviation two very important tools we
use throughout the machine learning
process and data science and simply we
take the NP array we have again the one
two three four five six three four five
I don't know I need to keep recreating
it I probably could have just kept it
but we can take the square root of a so
it goes through and it takes a square
root of all the different terms in a and
we can also take the standard deviation
how much they deviate in value on there
and there's a ravel function we can run
that
and NP array is X we're going to do x
equals hey we changed it from a to x x
equals Ravel and this sets it up as
columns so we have one two three four
five this is all columns on here very
similar to the flattened function
so they kind of look almost identical
but we also have the option of doing a
ravel by column and then another one is
log so you can do mathematical log on
your array in this case we have one two
three and we'll find the log base 10 for
each of those three numbers there's a
couple of them they don't you can't just
do any number here after log but there
is also log base 2. log base 10 is
pretty commonly used on here I'm going
to run that there we go
before we go let's have a little fun
let's do a little practice session here
on some more challenging questions so
you start to think how this stuff fits
together right now we just looked at all
the basics and all the basic tools you
have so let's do some numpy practice
examples and let's start by figuring out
how do you plot say a sine wave in numpy
what would that look like and so in this
project we wouldn't have to do this
because I've already run these but we'd
want to go ahead and import our numpy as
NP and import our matplot library
pipelot as PLT so we get our tools going
here and then we'll break it into two
sections because we need our x Y
coordinates in here so first off let's
create our x coordinates and our x
coordinates we're going to set to an a
range
and we want this error a range since
we're doing sine and cosine it's going
to be between 0 and 0.1
and then we use our NP and we actually
can look up numpy stores Pi so you have
the option of just pulling Pi in there
directly from numpy it has a few other
variables that it stores in there that
you can pull from there but we have
numpy pi and we generate a nice range
here and let's go ahead and run this and
just out of curiosity let's see what x
looks like I always like to do that so
we have
0.1.2.3.4 so we're going 0 to in this
case 9.4 3 times numpy pi remember that
Pi is like three point something
something something that makes sense it
should be about nine and we're doing
intervals of 0.1 so we create a nice
range of data and then we need to create
our y variable and so Y is going to
Simply equal NP or numpy dot sine of X
and then once we have our X and Y and if
we print let's go and just print y you
can see all that we'll do this let's do
this so it looks print
X print y
so we basically have two arrays of data
so we have like our X axes and our y
axes going on there
and this is simply a
plt.plot because we're going to plot the
points and we'll do X comma Y and then
we want to actually see the graph so
we'll do plot dot show and we'll go
ahead and run that and you see we get a
nice sine wave and here's our number 0
through 9 and here's our sine value
which oscillates between -1 and 1 like
we'd expect it to then for the next
challenge let's create a six by six two
dimensional array and let one and zero
be placed alternatively across the
diagonals
oh that's a little confusing so let's
think about that we're going to create a
six by six two dimensional so the shape
is six by six two dimensional array and
let one and zero be placed alternatively
across the diagonals
now if you remember from lesson one we
can fill a whole numpy array with zeros
or ones or whatever so we're going to do
NP we'll create a numpy zeros and we're
going to do a six by six and we'll go
ahead and make sure it knows it's an
integer even though it's usually the
default and just real quick let's take a
look and see what that looks like so if
I run this you can see I get six by six
grid so six by six zero zero zero zero
zero
now if I understand this correctly when
they say ones and zero placed
alternatively across the diagonals they
want the center diagonal maybe that's
going to stay zero all the way down
and then the next diagonal will be ones
all the way across diagonally and then
the next one zeros the next one ones and
the next one zeros and so on hopefully
you can see my mouse lit up there and
highlighting it so let's take a little
piece of code here
and we'll do Z One colon colon two comma
colon colon two equals one and wow
that's a mouthful right there so let's
go ahead and run this and see what
that's doing and so what we're doing is
we're saying hey let's look at in this
case Row one there's one and then we're
going to go every other row two so we're
going to skip a row so skip here skip
here skip here so we're going down
this way and we're going every other row
going this way it's hard to highlight
columns so you can see right here where
the that we're not touching each row is
like this row right here is not being
touched okay so we're going to start
with Row one and then we're going to
skip a row and another one and so we're
going every two rows and then in every
two rows we're looking at every two
starting with the beginning that's what
this thing blank means so we're going to
start with the beginning and we're going
to look at all of them but we're going
to skip every two so starting with Row
one
we look at all the rows but we do we do
it by two steps so we go one Skip One
you know one Skip One One skip one one
if you lift this out and do every one
this would just be ones in fact let's
see what this looks like if I go like
this
and run it you can see that I guess get
ones
so this notation allows us to go down
each row row by row and we're going to
do every other row set up on there and
so if we're going to start with Row one
we also
control Z
try that there we go we'll start with
row zero again we're going to go each
row step two so we'll start with row
zero and we'll go every other row and
this time we'll start with one column
one and again we go every other one
going down
step that's what that step two is
skipping every other one we're going to
set that equal to one so let's see what
that looks like and you can see here we
get our answer we get zero one one zero
zero but it has the ones going in
diagonals on every other diagonal and
zero on every other one
a little bit of a brain teaser that one
trying to get that one to work out so
you can see how you can arrange your
rows and here's your step in your
different axis on there
and then the next one is find the total
number and locations of missing values
in the array the first challenge is to
create some missing numbers so let's
create our array Z we're going to do uh
numpy dot random dot Rand 10 comma 10.
and before we do the second part let me
just take the second part out
and let's just see what that looks like
so let's run that and there we go so we
have a 10 by 10 random array it randomly
is picking out numbers
and next we want to go ahead and take
our random integer size equals 5. and
then we're going to do a random random
10 size equals 5. so in the Z we're
going to select a number of random
spaces here and set them equal to null
value
now let's go ahead and run that so you
can see what that looks like and if we
look at the array
we've created one two
three four this should be a fifth one in
here my eyes may be filling me so we've
created a series of oh because zero zero
to five zero one two three four so we
got five there are different null values
on here and
this is kind of a neat notation to
notice that we can generate
random integers size equals five so this
generates five by five miniature grid
inside of this to tell it where to put
the nands at so that's kind of a cool
little thing you can do
and we want to look up and see how many
null values are in there
and this is simply just NP is Nan of Z
simple so if it is nand then we want to
sum it up so we're going to sum up all
of the different null values on there
now let's do one one more feature in
here which is really cool
let's go ahead and print the indexes so
NP argue where NP is
Nan of Z so we're going to create our
own another NP array and let's run this
and we'll see here there comes up with
the four indexes so we didn't count four
of them up there
it tells you where they are one nine two
zero four six five four
and then let's go ahead and run this
again run run there we go this time I
got five let's get for random numbers
another fun one that I always like to do
it's very similar is we have NP is nand
z dot sum so we're summing the number of
nands and we can get the indexes and you
can reshape the indexes but you can also
just do we'll do an inds where NP is Nan
of Z
and let's just print let's print that
print inds let's see what that looks
like
and it's very similar we have we have
zero one three zero six three eight six
nine three if I have split it into two
different arrays
so we have our X and our y kind of
coordinates going there and what I can
now do is I can now do Z inds
equals and at this point you can also
instead of getting the sum you can get
the means or the well the numbers and
that kind of thing you have or the
average as it is so be one thing you
could do and you can pick up the average
that's very common in data science to
get the average and just use that for a
value
but we're going to set it to zero and
then let's go ahead and print our Z and
run that and you can see we come down
here we have wherever there was a null
value it is now zero
and you could set this whatever you want
this is another way to replace data or
help clean data depending on what it is
you're doing
so wow we covered a lot of stuff so
quick rehash going over everything we
went into there we looked at array
manipulation changing the shape
how to switch that around we even had
the flatten down there which remember we
have another command lower that's
similar we could change the order by F
remember F stands for Fortran very
strange connotation but there's C and F
C is the standard and F switches it to a
different order
to be honest I usually have to look it
up because I almost never use f but when
you need it you're like oh my gosh it
was the other order just do a quick
Google so we talked about reshape making
sure that the dimensions are the same
you don't want to have like something
that has 12 objects in it and reshape it
to C 11 and 5 because it doesn't work it
doesn't divide into 12. we can transpose
so we can switch them so we can go from
a four by three to a three by four Oops
I did that the other way around
three by four to four by three
we covered reshaping the array we did
the roll the axes you can do some weird
things with swapping and rolling axes
and transposing the numbers
we dug a little bit into the arithmetic
so we talked about adding we talked
about subtracting multiplying dividing
and you know at this point it's so
important we just look up the numpy
mathematics and you can see here they
have just about everything your
trigonometry
uh your hyperbolic functions rounding
sums products differences there are so
many all these different miscellaneous
mathematical connotations so you know
Google it go to the main numpy page and
look at the different setups you can do
on there so we covered that and we did
slicing I just break it apart we did
iterating over the array we covered
joining arrays and how to concatenate
remember concatenate just means add-on
to it so in this case how are you adding
B onto a is how you'd read that from
Linux you should catch the concatenate
because that's used regularly there
splitting the array we talked about how
to split the array in different ways so
you can split it in Array of arrays all
kinds of different ways to split the
array up how to resize it and remember
resize does not have to have the same
shape but if you resize it it will take
the data and begin at the beginning and
add new rows on if the size is bigger if
it's smaller it truncates it it just
cuts the end off
we looked at how to do a histogram and
how to plot that
we mentioned buying buckets or bins as
they call them in pi plot and then we
covered a lot of other useful functions
in numpy talked about the line space
setup for doing
um numbers in a series
how to sum the axes up again that's part
of the mathematical formulas there that
we looked at there's a sum there's also
means and median
all of those you can compute in numpy
and you can also do the square root and
standard deviation
the Ravel function very similar to the
flat
to be honest I almost always just use
the flat but you know the Revel has its
own kind of functionality that it does
and then we went into some numpy
practice examples we challenged you to
create a sine wave in numpy and how to
do that we're kind of looking for that a
range remember how we do the a range and
you can
have your beginning value your in value
which they did is three times pot not be
pi and we're going to do intervals of
0.1 and then y just equals the numpy
sine of x there's our math from the math
page we were just looking at remember
that's right at the top
and finally we went down here we had
this kind of a little brain teaser how
to do diagonal zeros and Ones playing
with a different connotations of Z of
the numpy array
and then we did a random size and we
played a little bit with how to with the
null values playing with null values
if you're doing any data science you
know null values are like a headache
what do you do with them big sets of
data you get rid of them small sets of
data you have to factor something in
there like figure out the average or the
median there and then replace it with
that
pandas really is a core python module
you need for doing data science and data
processing there's so many other modules
that come off of it there's actually
sits kind of on numpy so if you've
already had our numpy array hopefully
you've already gone through the numpy
tutorial one and two So today we're
going to cover what is pandas we'll
discuss series we'll discuss basic
operations on series and then we'll get
into a data frame itself basic
operations on the data frame file
related operations on a data frame
visualization and then some practice
examples roll up our sleeves and get
some coding underneath there and let's
start with just some real general what
is pandas pandas is a tool for data
processing which helps in data analysis
it provides functions and methods to
efficiently manipulate large data sets
now this is a step down from say using
spark or Hadoop in Big Data so we're not
talking about Big Data here but we are
talking about pandas when there is some
connections there's like an interface
going on with that so there is
availability but you really should know
your pandas because if you're working in
Big Data you'll know there's data frames
well pandas is a data frame primarily it
has a couple different pieces we'll look
at here and if you've never worked with
data frames before a data frame is
basically like an Excel spreadsheet you
have rows and columns you can access
your data either by the row or the
column when you have an index and
different that kind of setup and we'll
dig more into that as we get deeper into
pandas but think of it as like a giant
Excel spreadsheet that's optimized to
run on larger data on your computer and
then I said it that it's a data frame so
the data structures in pandas are series
one-dimensional arrays and then we have
data frame two-dimensional array and it
really centers around the data frame the
series just happens to be part of that
data frame and here's a closer look at a
pandas series series is a
one-dimensional array with labels it can
contain any data type including integer
strings floats python objects and more
so it's very diverse if you remember
from numpy we studied they had to be all
uniform not in pandas and pandas we can
do a lot more and pandas actually kind
of sits on numpy so you really need to
know both of those if you haven't done
the numpy tutorials and you can see here
we have our index one two three four
five and then our data a b c d and e
very straightforward it's just two
columns and we have a nice index label
and a column label for the data and then
a data frame is a two-dimensional data
structure with labels we can use labels
to locate data and you can see here we
had if we go back one we had our index
one two three four five so in each one
of these series they would share the
same index over there the row index so
you have your row index DF dot index and
then you have a column index df.columbs
and this is like I said this would be
really familiar if you've done any work
with spreadsheets Excel so it kind of
resembles that this does make it a lot
easier to manipulate data and add
columns delete columns move them around
same thing with the rows so you have a
lot of control over all of this now
we're of course going to do this in our
Jupiter notebook you can use any of your
python editors but I highly suggest if
you haven't installed Jupiter and
haven't worked with it it is probably
one of the best ways for easily
displaying a project you're working on I
skip between a lot of different user
interfaces or Ides for editing my Python
and it's just simply jupiter.org
j-u-p-y-t-e-r dot org and then I always
let mine sit on anaconda anaconda.com
and just real quick we'll open that up
for you oops offline mode don't show me
that again but you can see here that I
have different tools that I can actually
install in my anaconda including the
Jupiter notebook which comes by default
and then I have access to the
environments and again that's
anaconda.com named after the very large
one of the largest world's largest
snakes and then Jupiter notebook in this
case jupiter.org and when we're in our
I'm going to go in here to our jupyter
notebook and we're going to go ahead and
just do new and a Python 3 and this will
open up a Python 3 Untitled folder so
diving right in let's go ahead and give
this a title pandas tutorial and we'll
go up to cell and we'll change the cell
type to mark down so it doesn't execute
it as actual code one of those wonderful
tools when you have jupyter notebooks
you can do demos with this and let's go
ahead and import pandas and usually
people just call it PD that's become
such a standard in the industry so we'll
go ahead and run that now we have our
pandas has been imported into our
jupyter notebook
and then oh we can go ahead and let me
do the Control Plus since it's Internet
Explorer I can enlarge it very easily so
you have a nice pretty view oops too big
there we go and whenever you're working
with the new modules good to check your
version of the module in pandas you just
use the in this case PD dot underscore
underscore version underscore underscore
that's actually pretty common in most of
our python modules there's different
ways to look up the version but that's
one of the more common ones and we'll go
ahead and run that we get
0.23.4 and if we go to the pandas site
we see
0.23.4 is the latest release and of
course a reminder that if you're going
to environment you need to install it so
you'll need to do pip install pandas if
you're using the PIP installer we'll go
and close out of that
and the first thing we want to do is
we're going to work with series a lot of
the stuff you do in series you can then
do on the whole data set we need to do
what create one we need to manipulate it
take pieces of it so query it query it
delete so you can delete different parts
of it so we want to do all those things
with the series and we'll start with the
series and then almost all the code in
fact all the code does transfer right
into
the actual data table so we go from a
series of a single list of one column
and then we'll take that and we'll
transfer that over to the whole table
and we'll start by creating let's put up
there we go creating a series from
list
and let's just call this ARR equals and
we'll do 0 1 2 3 4. if you remember from
our last one we could easily do R equals
range of five which would be zero to
four but we'll do R equals zero to four
and we'll call this S1 and we'll go PD
and series is capitalized this one
always throws me is which letters do you
capitalize on these modules they're
getting more and more uniform but you
got to watch that with python and we're
just going to go ahead and do ARR so
we're just going to take this python
list and we're going to turn it into a
series and then because we're in Jupiter
we don't have to put the print statement
we can just put S1 and it'll print out
this series for us and let's go ahead
and run that and take a look
and you'll see we have two rows of
numbers so the first one is the index
now it automatically creates the index
starting with zero unless you tell it to
do differently so we get 0 index row 0
is 0 1 1 2 2 3 3 4 4. and because it's a
series it doesn't need a title for the
column there's only one column so why
title it
and this also lets you know that it's a
data type of integer 64. so we print
this out this is our series our basic
series we've just created now let's do
second series
PD and we'll use the same
data list and let's go ahead and do
order we'll give it an order equals oh
let's do it this way
let's go index equals order
and it helps if we actually give it an
order so we'll do order equals and let's
do one two three four five so instead of
starting with zero we're going to give
it an order starting with one we're
going to run that and we'll go ahead and
print it out down here S2
and we'll see that we now have an index
of one two three four five and that
represents zero one two three four in
the series and we're still data type
integer 64. and very common as you're
missing with numpy arrays is we can
import our numpy as NP remember that
from our numpy tutorials we can go ahead
and create a numpy at a random with the
random numbers of five and let's just
see what that end looks like so we can
see what our number looks like so we
have some nice random float values here
2.33 so on and that's from our last
tutorial the numpy tutorial one and two
and instead of calling it order let's
call it index and we're going to set our
index equal to a b c d and e I want to
show you that the index doesn't have to
be an integer so it can be something
very different here and then let's go
ahead and create our we'll just use S2
again and here's our NP for numpy
series capital s
and N is our NP for numpy PD for pandas
there we go switching my anachronisms so
we have pd.series of N and we go and do
our index equals our index we just
created
and then let's go ahead and see what
that looks like S2 is a print it and
let's run that and we can see here we
have a nice Series going on a b c d and
e for our indexes so instead of it being
0 1 2 3 or 4 we can make this index
whatever we want and you can see the
numbers here going down that we randomly
generated from the numpy array so we use
numpy to create our Panda Series right
here
and so continuing on with creating our
Series this one I use so often we create
a series from a dictionary so we have
our dictionary in this case we went
ahead and did a of one B is 2 C of three
D4 EF5 so each one of those is a key and
then a value and then we're going to use
oh let's use S3 equals PD for pandas
series and then we want to go ahead and
just do D in here
print out S3 here and let's go ahead and
run this and you can see we got a is one
B is 2 C is three D is four e is 5. and
it's still of integer 64 Because the
actual data is one two three four five
and it's all integers 64 type 64. and
the last thing we want to do in the
creating section of our series is to go
ahead and modify the index because we're
going to start modifying all this data
so let's start with modifying the index
of the series and if you remember let's
do a print this time S1
I'll go ahead and run this and the
reason I did print is because it only
prints out the last variable so if I put
S1 up here and we're going to do another
variable back down lower it won't print
the first one just the last one and
we're going to go ahead and take S1
the index and we're just going to set it
equal to a new index and obviously the
number of objects in our index has to
equal the number of objects in our data
and then because it's the last variable
we can go ahead and just do an S1 and
let's run that and you can see how we
went from 0 to 0 0 1 2 3 4 as our index
we've now altered it to a b c d and e so
this would be much more readable or
might be representational of a larger
database you're working with
So Cool Tools we've covered creating
database based on my basic array python
array we've showed you how to reset the
index
that we showed you how to use a numpy
array so you can put a numpy array in
there it's all the same you know
pd.series numpy array and then we can
set the index on there and the same
thing with the dictionary so it's very
versatile how it pulls in data and you
can pull in data from different sources
and different setups and create a new
series very easily in the pandas and
then we looked on changing your index so
now we have a new index on here
and then we want to go ahead and do some
selection let's do some basic
slicing most common thing you'll
probably do on here and we'll just do S1
this notation should start to look
really familiar again this is going to
put an output so I'd usually it doesn't
change S1 this just selects it so we
might do a equals S1 and then print a
and you'll see that it just looks at the
first three zero one two and we can do
the same thing by not having the a in
there I'll go ahead and take that out
but it's just a reminder that it's not
actually changing S1 it's just viewing
S1 so simple slicing on here and we can
likewise do an append oops before we do
a pin let's just do a quick kind of fun
one we'll do two minus one and you'll
see it covers everything but the E of
course you can do minus two on this side
so one another way to select it is to go
how far from the end and likewise we can
do a 2 here c d e to the end so it
starts at the second one and another way
we can do this is we can do a minus 2
over here and that looks at just the
last two in the slice so you can see how
easy it is to slice the data and of
course there's no reason to do this but
you could select all of them if you
wanted to view all of them on there oops
32 there's not 32 so it's just going to
show the first three there we go and
then we can also append so I can take
and oh let's create another series and
append one to it and if you remember we
had S3 there's our S3 and we have our S1
I'm going to do S1
and let's go ahead and do oh let's call
it S4
equals S1
a pin S3
so we're just going to combine those two
into S4
and if we go ahead and print S4 on here
you'll now see that we have a b c d e a
b c d e zero one two three four one two
three four five because we started the
data at one so very easy to compend one
series to the next and if we're going to
append one series to the next we need to
go ahead and drop or delete one and drop
is a keyword for that and let's just do
e our index e and so if I run this
you'll see that it'll print it out and
ABCD there's no e and remember all these
changes if I type in S4 again you'll see
that S4 still has e in it so this change
does not affect the series unless you
tell it to so I'd have to do like x S4
equals S4 dot drop e and there's another
way to do that which we'll show you
later on let me just cut this one out
there we go all right so we've covered
all kinds of Cool Tools here we have
appending we have slicing we did all the
creating stuff earlier as you can see
here on the setup how easy it is to
manipulate the series
so next what we want to get into is we
want to get into
operations that happen on the series so
let me go ahead and change this cell to
mark down there we go and
run so series operations what can we do
with the series and let's start by
creating a couple arrays we'll call it
array one and we'll do 0 through 7 and
array two six through six seven eight
nine five I don't know let me through
the five on the end but let's go ahead
and run those so those load up into
Jupiter and we'll do this a little
backwards we're going to do S5 equals a
panda series of array two so I'm doing
this in reverse and then when we do S5
you'll see that we have zero to four it
automatically assign the index
67895 for our series and let's go ahead
and do the same and we'll call this S6
and we'll set this equal to pde series
for our first array and if we do an S6
down here to print it out
we'll see something similar I got zero
through six zero one two three four five
seven for the data so those are two
series we just created series six five
and six
and one of the first things we can do is
we can add one series to the next so I
can do S5 dot add S6 and let's see what
that generates and just a quick thing if
you've never used pandas what do you
think is going to happen with the fact
that this only has five different values
in it and this one has seven values
so let's see what that does and we end
up with 6 8 10 12 9 and it goes oh I
can't add this there's nothing there so
it gives us a null return very different
than the numpy that would have given you
an error this instead tells you there's
no value here because we couldn't
generate one so we can easily add S5 dot
add S6 and likewise we can do S5 Dot
sub for subtract S6 and we'll run that
and on the add the subtract and you
guessed it we're going to do multiply
and divide next again you can see
there's the null values where it can't
subtract the two because there's no
values there to subtract we can also do
S5 multiply mul they're all three
letters on these that's one of the ways
to remember how they figured out the
code for this so remember these are all
three letters mole we'll go ahead and
run this and you can again you can see
how they're multiplied together and then
we can also do the S5 div three letters
again S6 and run that
and you'll see here this goes to
Infinity because we have 0 in the wrong
position so it actually gives you a
whole different answer here that's
important to notice and then in the null
values because there's no data and it
can't actually produce an answer off of
null off of missing data and since we're
in data science let's do S6
median so let's look at the median data
which is simply median sorry for those
who are following the three letters
because median is not three letters and
you can see an S6 is 3.0 and let's do a
print here and we'll do median
or average S6
and let's print Max
minus S6 and just like median there's
max value and if we're going to have a
max value we should also have a minimum
value so let's pop in minimum
we'll go ahead and run this and you're
starting to see something that would be
generated like say an R where you're
starting to get your different
statistics we have a median value of
three max value of 7 and a minimum value
of zero and what it does when it hits
these null values if there is no values
in there because we could still do that
we could actually you know what let's go
up here and do
let's pick this one where we multiplied
let's go s seven equals
I'm going to print the S7 just so I keep
it nice and uniform so I still have my
S7 down there and run it and then I want
to take the S7
because S7 now has null values and an
Infinity value and let's see what
happens
this is going to be interesting because
I want to see what it does with infinity
and we end up with a median of six
maximum of 27 and minimum of zero which
is correct it drops those values so when
it gets to there and it doesn't know
what to do with them it just drops those
values and then it computes it on the
remaining data on there so that's
important to know when you're making
these computations you're looking at Min
and Max and median you're not going to
know that there's no values unless you
double check your data for the null
values that's a very important thing to
note on there so just a real quick
review on there we've done our created
our PD series and we've gone ahead and
done addition subtraction multiplication
division all those are three letters so
sub Min div add and then we looked at
median maximum and minimum so we're
going to go ahead and jump into the next
big topic which is to create a data
frame so now we're going to go from
series and we're going to create a
number of series and bundle them
together to make a data frame
there we go cell type markdown and
so we have a nice title on there it's
always good to have a good title all
right so our first data frame we'll jump
in with some stuff that looks a little
complicated we'll break it down first
I'm going to create some dates and you
know what let's just go ahead and do
this I want you to see what that looks
like what I'm creating here I've created
a series of dates PD date range and
we're going to use these for the index
okay so when you look at this you'll see
that it's just basically it comes out
kind of like a basic python list or
numpy array however you want to look at
it with our different dates going down
and we've generated six of them and it's
going to have whatever time it is right
now on your on the thing for the date
for the time that's that time stamp
right there and then you'll see we have
11 19 2008 11 20 11 19 and looking into
the future there so that's all this is
is generating a series of dates that
we're going to use as our index and this
is a pandas command so we have a date
range which is nice that's one of the
tools hidden in there in the handles
that you can use and next we're going to
use numpy to go ahead and generate some
random numbers in this case we'll do the
np.random.random and six comma four you
can look at this as rows and columns as
we move it into the pandas and of course
you could reshape this if you had those
backwards on your data but we want the
six to match the rows and we have six
periods so our indexes should match
along with the rows on there and then
you know before we do the next one let's
go ahead and just print out our numpy
arrays and see what that looks like here
we have it one two three four by one two
three four five six four by six so it's
a nice little setup on there and since
working with data frames can be very
visual let's give our columns we have
four columns and we're going to give
them names A B C and D so now we have
columns on there also and then let's put
this all together in a data frame and we
can actually you know what let's do this
since I did it with everything else
let's go ahead and do columns and you
can see there's our columns on there
and we'll go ahead and do df1 equals
pandas dot data frame and note that the
D and the f are capitalized series it
was just the S and I always highlight
this because you don't know how many
times these things get retyped when you
forget what's capitalized on there it's
a minor thing you'll pick it up right
away if you do a lot of it and the first
thing we want to do is we want to go
ahead and take our numpy array because
we're going to create our data frame off
of it's a numpy array and then we want
our index equal to our dates so there's
our index in there and then we also have
columns equals columns and then finally
let's see what that looks like now
remember we had all the different data
that just looked like a jumble of data
we have our column names and everything
else our numpy array kind of just a
jumble array over there four by six you
can sort of read it but look how nice
this looks I mean this is you come into
a board meeting you're working with your
shareholders
this is pretty readable this is you know
this is our date this is our a b c d
whatever it is maybe it's one of these
dates has your leads
closures lost leads total dollar made
you know whatever it is if it's in a
business maybe it's measurements on some
scientific equipment whether searching
material you know where this is like a
higher the temperature low of the day
humidity of the day whatever it is so
you can see that we can really create a
nice clear chart and it looks just like
a spreadsheet you know we have our rows
and we have our columns and we have our
data in there now this one I use all the
time if we're going to create we can
create it like you saw here with our
numpy array very easy to do that and
reshape it you can also create it with a
dictionary array so here we have some
data and let me just go down a notch so
you can see all the data on there we
have an animal in this case cat cat
snake dog dog cat snake cat dog we have
the age so we have an array of Ages we
have the number of visits and the
priority was it a high priority yes no
and then we're going to take that we're
going to create some labels we have a b
c d e f g h i and what I want you to
notice on this is we have a title animal
and then we have basically a python list
and these lists they don't necessarily
have to be equal because we can have
non-data you know np.net numpy array
null value but we want to go ahead and
create labels that are equal to the
number in the list so a the first cat B
the second cat C the snake D the dog and
so on so we'll go ahead and create our
labels which we're going to use as an
index and we'll call this DF let's do it
this way we'll call this df2
equals PD for pandas data frame and then
we have our data just like we did before
and then we have our index equals
labels
and if we're going to go from there
let's go ahead and print it out so we
can see what that looks like df2 so
let's go ahead and run that and another
again you have a nice very clean chart
to look at we've gone from this mess of
data here to what looks like a very
organized spreadsheet very Visual and
easy to read animal age visits priority
and then a through J cats and all the
different animals so on and so on and
then when you do programming a lot of
times it's important to know what the
data types are so we can simply do df2
D types
and if we run that we can see that our
animal
is an object because it's just a string
but it comes in as an object age is a
float64 integer 64 and then priority
again is just an object
and exploring this this one's very
popular let's go df2 head and if we
print that out the df2 head Returns the
first five and we can change this you
don't have to do five you might want to
just look at the top two maybe you want
to look at let's see let's do six so
maybe we'll look at just the top six in
the database in your data frame and you
can actually this creates another data
frame so I could have a df3 equal to df2
and this now takes the df2 and just the
first six values so if we do df3
run get the same answer
and if we do it the head of the data we
can also do the tell it's the same thing
DFT you can look at the last we'll just
do the tell which by default does five
the last five and of course you can just
look at the last three of those real
quick just to see what's at the end of
the data and this is the tell I love
doing the tell of one because I'll have
like the index or something like that
and it will just show me the last
whatever the last entry was looking at
stock values and I might want to look at
just the last five days of the stock
values I can do that with the data frame
tail
and some other key things to look up are
the index so we can do df2 dot index
and I want you to notice that this isn't
a call function so if I put the brackets
on the end it'll give me an error
because index is not callable it's just
an object in there so we do df2 dot
index there's also columns
so we can go ahead and let's do uh let's
print this remember the first one is not
going to show unless I print it and then
df2 columns so now we can see we have
our indexes and we have our columns
listed here df2. columns animal age
visits priority that tells you what kind
of object it is or what kind of data
type it is and they're both object
and then finally df2 dot values and
again there's no brackets on the end of
df2.values because this is an actual
object it's not a callable function so
we'll go ahead and run that and it
creates this displays a nice array a
very easy way to convert this back to a
numpy array basically so before I go
into the next section let's just take a
quick look at what we covered so far
with the data frame we came up here we
created our data frame we did it from a
numpy array first setting the columns
and the index the index is setting it up
is the same as when we set up the series
so that should look very familiar so is
the whole format the numpy array the
index dates and the columns columns and
remember in our numpy array we're
looking at row comma column so six rows
four columns is how that reads in the
data frame
and we went ahead and also did that from
a dictionary in this case animal was the
column name with all the date data
underneath that column and then age with
that data visits that data priority that
data and then of course we added our
labels in there for our index so there's
no difference in there but it
automatically pulled the column names
important to know when you're dealing
with the data frame and importing a data
frame this way
and then we did looking up D type we
looked at head and tail looking at your
data really quick we also did index and
columns and values and note these don't
have the brackets on the end
so the next thing we want to do is go
ahead since we're dealing with data
science is we want to go ahead and
describe the data so we have def2 dot
describe to do that and we're going to
manipulate it in just a minute but let's
just see what this generates
and you can see right here we have age
and visits so looking at our data from
up above let me just go all the way up
here animal age business priority
and it does a nice job generating your
age versus visits which has all the data
you have your account your means your
standard deviation your minimum value 25
or in this group 50 75 and your maximum
value so this should look familiar as a
data science setup with your describe
for a quick look at your data Frame data
so let's start manipulating this data
frame and moving stuff around and we'll
start with transposing and it is simply
capital T for transpose and when we run
that it flips The Columns and the
indexes so now the indexes are all
column names and the columns are all
indexes animal age visits priority so if
we had come in here with our data shaped
wrong up above where we had a four by
six we can quickly just swap it if we
had it backwards not a big deal and we
can also sort our data so something that
you can't deal which is more difficult
to do with a lot of other packages and
the data frame is really easy to do take
our data frame df2 and we're going to
sort underscore values buy equals age
and so when we run this you'll see the
default is ascending so we have 0.5 to
2.53 and everything else is organized so
if you look at your indexes they've been
moved around because each index it moves
a whole row not just the one piece of
data is not being sorted so a very quick
way to sort by age are different data in
the data frame and in addition to
sorting it we can also slice the data
frame so I could do df2 and this should
look familiar from earlier we'll just do
one to three so we're going to pull out
oops it does help if I use the DF
instead of just D and we're going to
pull up just between one and three so we
have not zero which is a we have B which
is 2 or B which is one and C which is
two so one two and then it does not
include 3 which is the standard in
Python and we can even do something like
this we can combine them which is always
fun because remember this returns a data
frame so if I take df2 dot sort foreign
values and we'll do by equals age this
is just kind of fun and then I'm going
to slice it there we go double check my
typing and run it and now you should see
fa because F A are now one and two on
there
I'm seeing very quickly create a whole
string on here which narrows it you know
that you can sort it then slice it and
do all kinds of fun things with your
data frame we'll just go back to the
original one run there we go and if we
can slice it by row we can also query
the data frame so we can do df2 and this
is a little different because I'm going
to create an array within an array and
in this case we're going to look at oh
let's do age comma
visits so look at the different format
in here we have one to three so we've
done this by slicing by an integer value
and then on here I've done df2 age comma
visits in an array and when I run this
you can see that we get just these two
columns on here we get age and visits so
it's a quick way to select just two
columns or select number of columns
you're working with
and if you stop there we did the slicing
almost identical to slice is I location
which uses the integer location one
comma three there's a push in pandas to
move to this particular setup instead of
doing just a regular slice and that's
because this can be confusing when we
slice one to three and then we select
agent visits so there is a push to go
ahead and move to an eye location which
does the same thing you can see here BC
it's the same as up above there's also a
copy command so we can do df3 equals df2
copy we're just going to create a
straight copy of it
next we do df3
that'll be the same as the df2 on there
so df3 equals df2 dot copy and then
let's do df3 dot is null so we're
looking for null values and this will
return a nice map and you'll see that
everything is false except when you go
up here under the cat or H they had a
null there and so if we go to have a
couple up here also underneath of let's
see the dog okay there's a bunch of
nulls in here there's D up here so let's
look at D down here and you'll see false
true there it is there's our null value
so we can create a quick chart of null
values you can use this to do other
things we can leverage that null value
to maybe take an average or something
and fill those null spaces with data and
we can also modify the location so
here's our df3 location
and notice this is location not I
location I location has I for integer
location uses the in this case the
variables on the left and what we can do
on here and we're going to set this
equal to 1.5 and
some I'll pick a spot let's go back up
here where we had let's do F A just
let's see what were they looking at oh
here we go let's do F and age and up
here f is set to age of 2.0 and we find
out that that's incorrect data so we go
ahead and switch to df3 equal and then
we go and print out our df3
and if we go to F and H it is now 1.5 so
we're just changing the value in the df3
and this is changing the actual data
frame remember a lot of our stuff we do
a slice and like it returns another data
frame this changes the actual data frame
and that value in the data frame
so we've covered location and I location
is null making a copy here's our I
location which is equivalent of a slice
and also selecting columns so now we
want to dive just to take a little
detour here and let's look at df3 means
and this is kind of nice because you can
do this you can either do this by as you
can select a single column here by the
way you can just add the column
selection right here like we did before
so we could have age
look up the mean that just creates a
series if I run that there's our age
but if I take that out instead of
selecting it we can do the whole setup
and it has age and visits so why doesn't
it have priority or animal well those
are not integers so it's really hard
they're non-numerical values so what is
the average I guess you could do a
histogram which probably will look at
that later on but the only two things we
can really look at is age and visits and
we have the average or the mean on the
age is 3.375 and the mean on visits is
1.9 and let's do df3
visits we'll go ahead and steal the
visits again
and remember all those different
functions we looked at for a series well
we can do those here we can do the sum
so if we run that we'll see that these
sum up to 19. we can also look up
minimum if you remember that from before
the minimum is 1 Max so all that
functionality is here so we'll just go
back to summing it up and adding it all
together so real quick we've shown you
how to take the series operations and
put them into the data frame and then we
can actually this is interesting one we
can just do df3 sum run and you'll see
the different summations on there it
just combines them I like the way it
just combines the strings on there for
priority and animal we've looked at is
null we've also looked at copying along
with the different slices which we
talked about earlier so let's talk about
strings let's dive into the string setup
on there and let's go ahead and create a
string series string equals PD series
and we just put it right in there we
have a c d a a b a c a popped in a null
value cow and Al I don't know why they
picked Cal and Al in the background
someone must like those animals and of
course we can just do string if we run
that you'll see leave the r out we'll
get an error but if we put it in there
you'll see that we have a simple series
0 a 1C 2D and it automatically indexes
it zero to eight and then we can go
string dot lower so when we're talking
about our data frame in this case or our
data series string in this case we use
the string function Str and we're going
to make it lower and we go ahead and put
the brackets on there and you'll see
that we've gone from capital a Capital C
so on to ABC and Baka CBA cow Al they
were all lowercase already and of course
if you want to go lower you can also do
upper and we'll go ahead and run that
and you can see we now have ACD AAA
everything's capitalized except for the
null value which is still null all right
so we looked at a few basic string you
can see that string functions upper and
lower we're going to jump into a very
important topic I'm even going to give
it its own header on here because it's
such an important topic what do you do
with missing values Panda has some great
tools for that so we'll dive into those
and we'll call we'll work with df4 and
if you remember the DF copy from above
we're just going to make a copy of df3
and let's just take a quick look at the
data we're working with oops df3 forgot
the three on there there we go so here
we have our cat snakes and dogs
hopefully not all in the same container
because that would be just probably mean
to all of them so we made a copy we're
going to be working with df4 and the
reason we made a copy is we want to go
ahead and fill the data and we just
simply do fill in a and then we're going
to give it the value we want to put in
there we'll go at the value 4. so I can
run in here and you'll see now that df4
now has where the N A was is filled with
the value of four same thing down here
a lot of times we'll compute the mean
first so I might do a mean page equals
df4 and then we want to go ahead and do
age
dot mean
and then I'll do something like this df4
I only want to select the age and I want
to fill that
with the mean h i run in there and
you'll see that our df4 age now has the
means in there just a quick way of
showing you how you can combine these
let me go back to our original one there
we go and run that and keeping with good
practices df5 equals df3 dot copy
a little printer df5 which should be the
original one
and then on the df5 we can now drop our
missing data
so I'm going to Simply drop in a and
we're going to use how equals any so I'm
going to drop any row that has missing
data in it and you'll see we had D here
with missing data and H and then let's
go ahead and see what df5 looks like
when we do that
there we go and there it is D is gone
and so is H so we create a new data
frame off of this missing those values
now if you have a lot of data dropping
values is a good way to take care of it
because you don't miss some data if you
have not a whole lot of data you're
working with like the iris data set or
something like that or something small
you want to start trying to find a way
to fill that data in so you don't lose
your computational power of the data you
got so just a quick look at processing
null values
or missing values you can fill them
usually with the means some people use
medium or the mode there's different
ways you can fill it one way is means
and we can also just drop those rows
those are the two main things we do with
missing data
here we go uh we're going to cover next
this is I so love data frames for this
file operations it saved me so much time
because they have so many different
tools for bringing data in and saving
data so we're looking at the data frame
file operations it's really streamlined
I don't know how many times I'll go on
to different data downloads and they'll
have Panda download standard on there
just because it's so widely used so
let's start with the most common file is
a CSV so we have df3 to CSV or animal
and let me just show you the folders
going into right now I have some
Untitled and a few things in here but
nothing labeled animal so we go ahead
and run this and this is now save the
animal to my hard drive and you can now
see the animal folder up here and if I
let's do edit with a notepad oh let's
open up with just a regular notepad
there we go or word pad if I open that
up you can see it's comma separate did
our titles they don't have an index on
the categories on the top in the index
comma then all the different data is
separated by commas
standard CSV file on there and if we're
going to send it to CSV and notice the
format is dot 2 underscore CSV and it's
just the name of the file we're sending
it to you can also put the complete path
by default it's going to go whatever the
active directory this program is running
on that's why those other folders are in
there so we have our df3 to CSV and then
if we're going to put it in there we
want to also get it back out and we'll
call this one DF underscore animal
equals PD read underscore CSV I always
have to remember is two underscore CSV
and read underscore CSV I always want to
do like a capital in there and not the
underscore we're going in here again
it's the active directory so if I now do
print out my DF animal
and let's just do the head we only want
to look at the first three lines so if I
go ahead and run this we'll see the
first three lines and they should match
up here what we saved to our CSV so very
easy to save and import from our CSV
files on here
and it turns out DF 3 also has a two
Excel they actually have a lot of
different formats but you know old
school Excel was real popular for so
long still is we can go ahead and save
it as animal dot xlsx we're going to
call the sheet named sheet1 and then I
can also do DF we'll call it animal 2.
two and this one's going to come from
and the same format on here there we go
so we still have our animal xlsx
the sheet 1 that's where it's coming
from index columns equals none so we're
not going to we're going to suppress the
indexing on the columns n a values and
it'll just assign that zero one up on
your indexes so if it says index columns
equals none that's what it does and then
we've added null values because null
values in here and we want to just make
sure that they're marked as n a and
we'll go ahead and just print out the
animal animal to there we go and let's
run that let's make this let's just do
the whole thing so we'll go ahead and
run that and it probably doesn't help
that I completely forgot the read so
animal 2 equals PD dot read
Excel there we go Excel so now we go
ahead and run it and what we expect is
happening here we have the same data
frame on here and if I flick back to my
folder you can now see that we have the
animal one of these is in Excel and one
of these is a CSV on here and so there's
our two file Types on there and they
have other formats these are just the
two most common ones used and I don't
know how many times I've had stuff from
Excel I need to pull out if you've ever
played with Excel it's a nightmare on
the back end because of the way they do
the indexing
so this just makes it quick and easy to
pull in an Excel spreadsheet so we
looked at two different ways to bring
data in and save it to files we've
looked at all kinds of different ways of
manipulating our data set and slicing it
and creating it for our data frame let's
get in there put your visualization
always a big thing at the end because
one it lets you check to see what you
did make sure it looks right and then
also if you're going to show somebody
else it makes it very clear what's going
on if they see something visual so this
is where a really important part of data
science is so let's go ahead and bring
in our tools we're going to do import
numpy as NP we want to make sure we have
our Amber sign matplot library in line
this just lets Jupiter know that we're
going to print it on this page if you're
using a different IDE you don't really
necessarily need that but this does help
it displays quickly in Jupiter notebook
and if you remember for earlier we could
create a we're going to call it TS we're
going to create a pandas which are cute
cuddly creatures versus a pandem short
for pandemonium no so we have TS equals
PD series and we're just going to create
a random setup of 50. we'll do an index
we'll set it equal to the pandas date
range today periods equals 50. so the
50s should match and I want you to
notice something here I did not import
the matplot library why because it's
already in there pandas already has its
built-in connection and interface with
matplot Library so you don't have to
import it and we'll go ahead and do TS
equals TS dot cumulative sum we're going
to do the cumulative sum
it's a little reformatting there and
we'll go ahead and plot it and let's
take a look at what that looks like so
we have a nice graph here we have the
dates on the bottom we set this up so we
have a nice range between in this case
minus four to looks like about two maybe
or one minus four and one so what we've
done here we've plotted a basic series
just a single row of data and we've set
indexes on there but we can also do the
whole data frame on there and let's see
what that looks like so first let's go
ahead and create the data frame we have
here random number so we're going to do
50 by 4 and then we'll go ahead and
create columns a b X and Y just because
we can index is a ts.index on there so
we're going to use the same index as
before just to keep it nice and uniform
we've already generated the dates to go
with it and then we can do just like we
did with the series we can also do with
the data frame
DF equals DF cumulative sum so we're
going to sum the whole data frame and
then we'll do simply DF plot and this
puts that in and let's go ahead and run
this and look how easy and quick that
was to generate a nice graph with all
the different data on there so we have
our shared index we have the shared
columns and then we have the different
data from each one that we can easily
look at and compare so very quick way of
displaying data you can imagine if you
were working in oh I think I mentioned
stock earlier because I've been doing
some analysis of stock lately so you'd
have your date down here and then you
would have stock a Stock B stock X Y
whatever it is and you can put them all
in one chart and see how they what they
look like next to each other and this
isn't too far off from what some of
those graphs looks like and this is just
randomly generated so stock has a lot of
Randomness in it which is one of the
reasons I actually play with it for
doing some of my models on for testing
them out now there are a lot of features
in pandas so we're going to show you one
more thing on here there's some of the
things like I didn't go too deep we
looked at the top two for importing data
from a CSV and from an Excel spreadsheet
showed you how to quickly plot the data
there's more settings in there you can
do we're going to do one more thing down
here and this is kind of a fun one
changes to a mark down and run that so
how would you remove repeated data using
pandas
and this is where you have a data set
that comes in and maybe it's feeding
from one location and in instead of
noting that it's repeated the date like
oh let's go back to stocks that's a good
visual we have the stocks from the 23rd
and it adds another row and it's the
same row it's importing the 23rd again
and again so now you have that data
repeated three times and you need to go
back and figure out how to get rid of it
how do you track that down so let's
start by creating a quick database our
data frame not a database I keep saying
databases the data frame and we'll just
make this data frame has using our
dictionary going in this data frame only
has one data Series in it which is fine
so if we do DF to print it out you'll
see a one two two two two four five six
seven and so on and so how would you
remove that well there is a neat feature
in data frames called shift
along with another feature that lets us
select just certain date information and
we'll go with the location function put
that in Brackets remember that from
above location and then in the location
let me just spread this out a little bit
so it's really easy to read in fact I'm
going to go upscale on that since we're
doing some a little bit more complicated
here
what you can see on this on the location
is I have DFA dot shift so this is going
to shift up one by default you can
actually change this to two or three you
could even do a minus one and it shifts
the other way but it's going to shift up
by one by default that's going to say if
that does not equal DF of a then we want
that if you look down here we had one
two two two two when we run this Logic
on here and we do the shift it now gets
rid of all the duplicates so we went
from one two two two two four four five
whatever it was here it is one two two
two four four four five five five six
six six two one two four five six seven
eight and you'll see on the index it
just deletes them out of there so the
index stays the same obviously you don't
want the dates to change if you're
working with an index dated setup so it
just deletes those duplicates out of
there this is just a quick way to
introduce you to one the fact that you
can add logic gates into here and two
the I location allows you to use shift
so there's the shift function and then
the I location selects that based on
true or false
wow so we've actually covered a lot
today in pandas we've really covered
into the basics of selecting your
different series out of your column out
of your data frame how to index rows how
to slice how to plot hopefully you'll
take this beyond that and start
combining these different things and you
can create long strings and really
explore your data generate some nice
graphs if you're in Jupiter notebook
it's a great demo to show others and I
didn't know this about Jupiter notebook
you can do this in Jupiter notebook and
then you can download and I always I
never really look too closely at all the
downloads but you download as an HTML
and post it to your blog so it's got a
neat feature in there but any of this is
really powerful tool all of this is
really powerful tools for doing your
data science if you are one of the
aspiring data scientists looking for
online training and graduating from the
best universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with data
analytics by learning from the experts
then drag using a show to Simply learn
skeleton postgraduate programming data
science in collaboration with IBM the
link is mentioned in the description box
and you should navigate to the home page
where you can find a complete order of
the program being offered so let's start
with what is matplot library matplot
library is an open source drawing
Library which supports Rich drawing
types it is used to draw 2D and 3D
graphics and there are so many packages
in the matplot library we're going to
cover the basics and there are so many
packages that sit on top of the matplot
library that we can't even cover them
all today but we'll hit the main one so
that you have a good understanding of
what the matplot library is and what the
basics can do you can understand your
data easily by visualizing it with the
help of matplot Library you can generate
plots histograms bar charts and many
other charts with just a few lines of
code and here we have some basic types
of plots you can see here that we'll go
into we have the bar chart the histogram
boy I use a lot of histograms in my
stuff a scatter plot line chart pie
chart and area graph let's start
plotting them and to do this I'm going
to be using Jupiter notebook you can use
any of your python interfaces for
programming or scripting and running it
of course we here really like the
Jupiter notebook for doing basic a lot
of basic stuff because it's so visual
but in our jupyter notebook which opens
up in this case I'm using Google Chrome
you can go up here to New and we'll
create a new Python 3 and set that up if
you're not familiar with Jupiter
notebook we do have a tutorial that
covers some of the basics of that you'll
look at any of our tutorials they
usually cover a number of them showing
how to set up Jupiter and Anaconda I
myself use Jupiter through anaconda in
fact let's go ahead and open that up and
just take a look at what they see what
that looks like you can see your
anaconda Navigator if you install it it
will automatically install the Jupiter
notebook but it also installs a lot of
other things I know some people like the
QT console for doing python or spider
I've never used them I actually use
notepad plus plus as one of my editors
and then I use the jupyter notebook a
lot because it's so easy to have a
visual while I'm programming and even
simple script in Python I'll take it
from The jupyter Notebook and then do a
save as you always go under file and you
can download as a Python program so
that'll download it as an actual python
versus the IPython that this saves it as
so let's go ahead and dive in and see we
got going here and go ahead and put
matplot Library tutorial and I'm going
to turn this cell into a markdown so it
doesn't actually run it but you can see
it has a nice little title there that's
all Jupiter notebook and then from
matplot library let's import
Pi lab
1 and then let's go ahead and just print
we'll go pylab and the version let's go
ahead and run this so we're going to
import our pylab module from the matplot
library and we find out that we're in
version
1.15.1 always important to note the
version you're in probably I was reading
an article that said the number one
thing that python programmers struggle
with is remembering what version they're
working in and making sure that they're
going from one platform to the other
with the same version and if we're going
to graph things I think we need some
data to graph so we're going to import
numpy as NP now if you're not familiar
with numpy definitely go back and check
out our numpy tutorial there's so many
different things you can do with it
dealing with reshaping the data and
creating the data we're just going to
use it to create some data for us and
there is a lot of ways to create data
but we're going to use the np.line space
so we're going to create a numpy array
and the way you read this is we're going
to create numbers between 0 and 10 and
we're going to create 25 of these
numbers so we're just going to divide
that equally up between 0 and 10. and if
we have x coordinates we should probably
have some Y coordinates and we'll do
something simple like x times X plus two
and let's just take a look we're going
to print X and print
why let me go ahead and run this and
let's see we got going on here so we
have our x coordinates which is 0 0.4.83
Etc and you can look at this as an X Y
plot so we have 0 we have two and we
have 0.416 we have 2.17 and just as a
quick reminder we're going to do print
in pra X comma y dot reshape 25 comma
two and the reason I want to do this is
I want to show you something here a lot
of times a program returns X comma Y and
it's an array of X comma y x comma y x
comma Y and so when you're working with
the pi plot
you have to separate it out and reshape
it so if I start off with pairs like
this I can reshape them if I know
there's 25 pairs in there I can switch
the 2 and the 25 and this is kind of
goofy but we'll do it anyways reshape so
I'm going to reshape my 25 by 2 back to
2 by 25.
and if I run that you'll see I end up
with the same output as the X Y the two
different arrays in here
and this is important that we want X and
Y separate again that's all numpy stuff
but it's important to understand that
this is a format that matplot Library
works with it works with an array of x's
and they should match your array of y's
so each one has 25 different entities in
it and then for our basic plotting of
this data it only takes one command to
draw a graph of this data and so we use
our from up here we imported pylab we
take our PI lab and the keynet lender
there is plot for plotting a line and
then we want our x coordinates and our Y
coordinates and we'll throw in R and the
r simply means red so we're going to
draw the line in red let me go and run
that
you can actually switch this around if
you wanted to do different there's B for
blue we have a lot of fun yellow hard to
see yellow there we go but we'll go
ahead and stick with red run and when
you're doing presentations with these
try to be consistent you know if the
business and the shareholders send you a
spreadsheet and they have losses in red
you use red for losses in your graph try
to be consistent use green for profit
for money you don't have to necessarily
use green but it's whatever they're
using whatever the company is using try
to mirror that that way people aren't
going to be confused if you switch your
data around and every time one graph has
red for loss and one graph has blue for
loss it gets really confusing so make
sure you're consistent in your graphs
and your coloring and something to know
because we're going to cover this in a
minute this is your canvas size so we
have a canvas here and what we're going
to do next is we're going to look at sub
graphs okay so let's take our PI lab and
create a sub plot
and one of the things also to know when
we're working with the matplot library
I'm not setting when I do this this is
my drawing canvas the pi lab so once
I've imported the pylab I'm drawing my
images on there very important to know
and with the subplot we're going to give
it some different values and we're going
to represent by rows columns and indexes
and let's do one two one so it's going
to be the first row second column and
the index is like you can stack your
graphs and things like that we don't
worry too much about indexes but rows
and columns we want to go ahead and use
Row one and column two and if we're
going to have one object we should
probably have two but before we do that
we have to plot data onto the subplot so
the order is very important and we'll go
ahead and stick with our X comma Y and
let's do this we're going to add in a
third parameter here remember we did Red
we're going to add shorthand dash dash
for dashed lines so this this plots the
data into Row one column two and if
we're going to do that let's do another
one pilab dot subplot and if we're going
to do Row one let's do column two and
index two
and this time we're going to add G for
green and this denotes a style and if
we're going to set up our pylab subplot
there we go my lab we gotta go ahead and
plot that pi
lab plot
and instead of X Y we want y comma X
Oops I messed up this is in the wrong
spot there we go we'll move that down
here real quick because that goes in the
plot part so the subplot tells that the
row column and index and the pi plot
tells it what data in this case we
switch them and the color and then the
style shorthand and let's go ahead and
run that
and you'll see it takes this canvas
splits it in two and now we have two
different graphs and we have the red one
with dashed lines and we have the green
one which is has a little stars going up
and if we take this and let's just um
just for fun let's change this and run
that with an index of one it puts them
both on the same index it also gives me
a warning because it's a strange way of
doing two subplots there's this
depreciated there's another way to do it
but most people just ignore that warning
because it's not going to go away
anytime soon now that's using the same
setup what happens if we do instead of
this let's change the column on here and
find out what happens
and if we do the column
I didn't really like that on the setup
it just disappears so let's keep our
column as 2 and let's change the row on
the second one to two and run that
and you'll see again it kind of squishes
everything together it can cause us some
issues so let's take the index so these
need a unique index and you can see here
where I made some changes I said row two
and look what happens when I change to
column two so I now have Row 2 column
two index two I squished it up here so
you could put another graph underneath
is what that does and there's all kinds
of different things if you really have
to just play with these numbers so you
get a handle on them because
you know we get repeated 164 times
according to Cambridge University if
it's completely new to you and you can
see right here where we go three run
there we go but you can see it takes a
little bit sometimes to play with these
and get the numbers right I hope they
hit the wrong one that's why let's go
three there three there run
there we go now it's overlapping so I
have this doubled over here on the right
for now we'll just go ahead and leave
this with the where we have column and
row two and the two different indexes so
they appear nice and neatly side by side
and then as we just saw as we were
flashing through them we can put them on
top of each other
and let me just highlight that and copy
it down here
paste it down there and here we have one
two one and then we'll do one two one
also for this one and that puts the two
subplots directly on top of each other
gives us that warning and you can see we
now have two different sets of data
graphed on top of each other and you can
also see how it did the indexes since
one of them is from 0 to 10 that's the
green one on the x-axis and the other
one is from 0 to 10 on the y axis so it
took the greatest value of either one
and then used those as a shared value
so let's next look at operator
description and we'll go ahead and turn
this cell into a markdown and run that
so it looks nice so fig and remember I
talked about the canvas earlier I
briefly mentioned it we're going to look
a little bit more at the canvas later on
but that's what the figure is FID we're
going to add axes so we're going to
initialize a subplot add the subplot in
rows and columns and all kinds of
different things with this that you can
do let's look at that code and see
exactly what's going on and I want you
to notice that there's fig which is the
actual canvas in the matplot library and
ax is commonly used to refer to the
subplots so we're creating subplots
you'll see ax equals PLT subplot
earlier we did the pi lab so let's go
ahead and import Pi plot from matplot
library and we're going to do it as PLT
you'll see that a lot that's really the
standard in the industry is to call it
PLT just like pandas's PD and numpy
array is NP certainly you can import it
as whatever you want but I would stick
to the standards and we're going to do
the same graph as we did above with the
pi lab but with the PLT so if it looks
familiar there's reason we're doing this
because we want to show you how the
figure part works and working with the
canvas goes but we're going to do the
same plot as we did before and we'll
call it fig and we're going to set that
equal to plot figure so there's our
figure or our canvas on there and let's
create a variable called axes and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
axes
and in this we're going to control the
Left Right the width the height of the
canvas from zero to one and so we can go
ahead and I'm just going to put some
stuff in there I got 0.5
0.1.8.8 so when you're looking at this
this is a zero to one or you could say
50 percent 10 80 80 percent but it's a
control it's going to control your left
and your right along with the width and
the height so the width and the height
we're going to use 80 percent and we're
going to have like a little indent on
the left and the right and this would
look familiar from above xcs.plot X
comma Y and then let's give it a color
how about red since we're recreating the
same graph let's keep it uniform oops
and it helps if I use a ax i s instead
of axes I don't know where that came
from but this looks identical to the one
we had up above so here's our axis plot
X comma y of red same graph same setup
but this time we've added a variable
equal to the figure dot add axes so our
plot figures our canvas our axes is what
we're working in and then our axis.plot
X comma Y and again we can draw Sub
graphs we put that down here
[Music]
just like we did before and a little
different totation here we have fig
comma axes equal
plt.subplots
and in here it's going to be the number
of rows we're going to do one row
in columns equals two so if you remember
before that's what we did we had one row
with two different graphs on it we're
going to do the same thing but know how
we did this here's our figure our canvas
and our axes we're going to create
actually two different axes we're going
to create Row one column two and so axis
is an array of information so we can
simply do
4 well let's do X in axes
this will now look familiar X Dot Plot
we're going to do X comma y we'll go
ahead and make it red keep everything
looking the same remember nice uniform
graphs everything looks the same and if
we go ahead and run this
you'll see we get two nice side by side
graphs so just as we had before the same
look the same setup and just for fun
let's change in columns to three we'll
run that and now you'll see we'll have
three on there and let's see if we make
it a little bit more interesting we'll
do in rows equals to two and you can see
down here we're going to get into
tribute there because it's trying to
scrunch everything together so it does
have a limit how much stuff you can put
in one small space that's important to
know you can fix that by changing the
canvas size which we'll look at in just
a minute and there's other ways to
change it on here but here we go we can
do in rows two and columns equals one
you can see two nice images right above
each other we'll go back to the original
one row two columns side by side left to
right and we can also draw a picture or
graph inside another graph
and that's kind of a fun thing to do
it's important to note that we can layer
our stuff on top of each other which
makes for a really nice presentation so
let's have a fig create another figure
so we're going to start over again with
our canvas we set that equal to
plt.figure
so there's our new canvas and let's do
axes we'll call it axes one and two axis
one equals fig dot add axis remember
this from earlier
and this here similar numbers we used
before saying how big this axis is this
figure in the axis is so this is going
to be the big
axes and let's do axes two equals
another figure at axes and then
0.2.5.4.3 and if we're going to do this
they need data on them so let's go ahead
and plot some data on our axis so axis1
Dot Plot
and we'll make this simply X comma y
comma make it red and then let's go axis
2 Dot Plot and let's reverse them y
comma X comma green there we go doing
what I told you not to do you shouldn't
be swapping axes around and plotting
your data in five different directions
because it's confusing let's go ahead
and run this and see what this looks
like and then let's talk a little bit
about this we talked about the
0.2.5.4.3 and let me just grab The
annotation for that that's left right
width and height so we have in here that
this is going to be left right so here's
our left is point one n 0.5 and we you
know what let's just play with this a
little bit what happens when I change
this to 0.1 it moves it way over to the
left so there's our 0.1 so we can make
this point four run that there we go so
you can see how you can move it around
the branches on here 0.2 0.5 is the left
so that's the right so see what happens
when we do point oh let's make this
point one that actually is they had it
down uh left right I thought this was
wrong it's actually how far from the
bottom let me switch that on here bottom
there we go so we had here on this we
can go ahead and put that back to 0.5
and run that and this and this point
three let's make this point three also
and that is the width and then of course
height we can make that really tiny
actually let's do 0.2 and let's run that
and you can see it changes the height on
there we can make it even smaller 0.2 by
0.2 and as you can see you can get stuck
playing with this to make it look just
right it could sometimes take a little
bit certainly once you have the settings
if you're doing a presentation you try
to keep it uniform unless it doesn't
make sense for the graph you're working
on try to keep the same color as the
same position and the same look and feel
and I mentioned earlier we can adjust
the canvas sides so this is from earlier
I just copied it down below we're going
to re-plot the same data we've been
looking at and what we can do is we can
change the figure size to 16 by nine and
let me run that and show you what that
looks like so it fills the whole screen
and then if you are normally when you're
working on the screen you don't worry
too much about this we can set the DPI
to 300 run that
there it goes this is your dots per inch
and if you are doing an output of this
and you're printing a hard copy you want
the higher quality I would suggest
nothing under 300 if it's a professional
print you might get a little less than
that but whenever I'm doing professional
graphics and printing them out on
something 300 dots per inch is kind of
the minimal on there
you can go a lot higher too but keep in
mind the higher you get the more memory
it takes the more lag time and the more
resources you use so usually 300 is a
good a solid number to use your dots per
inch and you can see it drill These are
nice it draws a nice large canvas here
which is 16 by nine and then the DPI is
300 on here it's a little higher quality
and just out of curiosity I wonder how
long it takes to draw something double
that size 600 and you can see here where
at 600 DPI it's going to take a while
there it goes just because it's
utilizing a lot more graphics on there
and let me just go back to the 300 and
we'll actually do let's do a 100 you're
not going to see a difference on this
because it is web based Graphics are
pretty low
and up here you saw I did this with the
plot figure this works the same if I do
figure axis subplot figure size and then
we'll go ahead and do actually
plot
X comma y comma we'll stick to red
let's go ahead and run this and you
should get almost the same thing here
here's our axes on the subplot on here
with the fixed size and the DPI let me
take this all out let me just
remove all that real quick run it again
there we go now we're back to our
original figure and let's look at some
of the other things you can do with this
one of the things we do is we can set a
title for the axis so axis set title
you'll see right here since I put this
on the axis it's the main title for the
whole graph
and if you're going to have a title you
should also label so we can label our X
label and we can set our y label in this
case we're just going to call it X and Y
keep it nice and uniform and if we run
this you'll see that we've added a nice
X label and Y label whoops where'd they
go and it turns out in this environment
that you have to put it before the title
so let me go ahead and put it before the
title and there's our x y and we run
that and of course we can also do upper
size a little bit so you can see what's
going on a little better so here we have
X label X if you come down here you'll
see our X label and our y label we can
of course change this to X
label you can change this to y
and be whatever you want on here of
course and our title graph there we go
run so here we have a title of graph our
y label and our X label all set up on
our nice little plot and then before we
move on to the next section let's do
more thing on here we have a thing
called The Legend and we're going to do
we're going to set our ax Legend label
one label two up here that's a format
for it but let's go down here and
actually use it I'm going to do two
different plots we're going to have axes
plot X by x times x squared and X cubed
and if I run this you'll see it puts two
nice graphs on the setup on there but
it's nice to have a legend telling you
what's going on so for the legend we can
actually do axes since we have the two
plots Legend and on here we've created
an array and we have y equals x squared
Y equals X cubed you can actually put
this as whatever you want those are just
strings and then location two and let's
go ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and you can see it puts a
nice Legend on the upper left hand
corner location two we can do location
three and run it and it drops it down to
the bottom
one I can't remember where that's at
there we go upper right so each one of
these is a number that refers to the
different locations on the screen zero
kind of have to play with them or look
them up to remember where they're at but
they do work it just kind of moves
around depending on where you want your
Legend data on there so on this section
we cover the title the graph the Y
labels and legends this is we're getting
into some starting to look really fancy
here so we now have something we can
actually put out you'll see the title of
the graph looks a little fuzzy so I
might in a web setup put the DPI up a
couple notches maybe put it at 200 100
might work fine just so you know
something to notice on here when you're
playing with these different things we
had our subplots DPI equals oh let's do
200 and see what that looks like so you
can see it now it's a lot clearer it's
also larger so it's a nice little
feature you can throw in there with your
DPI dots per inch so the next section is
let's look at some graph features we're
going to look at line color transparency
size and a few more things on here and
oops I forgot the main title so we have
our figure in our axes equals our plot
and subplots and I'll go ahead and do a
DPI equals 150 so the graph comes out
nice and large and easy for you to see
and let's go ahead and do three plots on
here we'll do X by X plus one so it's
just going to be a straight line plot
X Plus X plus two
and axes Dot Plot
plus three this looks like we're doing
nearest neighbor setup we're showing how
it uh located data and putting your
lines on there between the nearest
neighbors there we go so it draws a nice
little graph with three lines on it one
of the things we can do is we can
control the alpha on this oops and you
can actually see the when they did these
lines it automatically pulls in
different colors for your setup so some
automatic automatic things going on in
there and a lot of times we do that
comma R but we're going to do color
equals red another notation on here
let's go ahead and run this now we have
a bright red line down there and with
the matplot library you're not limited
to Red you can also use the one of many
different color references as you see
here with the pound sign
1155dd which just is just blue and we
could do the same thing with another
color on here which it turns out to be
green I can just as easily do this green
blue oops there we go blue and run that
and you'll see here we have red blue and
green and what I want to do is I want to
make this we're going to say What's
called the alpha on this and we're going
to set this equal to 0.5
so this is halfway see-through when I
run this and it's almost going to look
pink because you can see through it and
let's change this just a little bit just
to make this kind of fun let's Square it
there we go run it so now we have this
nice square that comes up and you can
see when it crosses it because I plotted
these two lines after it and they have
no Alpha the red is behind those lines
or in this case pink because we did the
alpha halfway through so let's go ahead
and do this Alpha equals 0.5
and oh you know what instead of squaring
it let's take it to the 0.5 power
that'll be kind of interesting to see
what that does we'll just go to keep it
squared there we go and run that and
let's go back and look at this where it
crosses over and the first thing you see
right here is on the blue is kind of
light blue now you can see how the two
colors add together you get almost a
purple on there so I can clearly see
where the Red Cross is the blue line and
then the green just blanks it over
because I didn't do any opaqueness no
Alpha on there so this is great if you
have lots of data that crosses over and
you need to be able to track those lines
better and we'll go ahead and do this
0.5 and we'll run that oops I Did you
equals 0.5 let me go ahead and run that
and so you can see right here now you
can easily see the red line how it
crosses the green and the blue down here
and if we want to we can do this as the
default is one is solid so we can change
this all to 0.8 let me just do that oops
58 8 there we go run up so it must have
hit a wrong button there let me try that
again I actually get rid of a bracket
and let's go ahead and run that and we
come down here and look at this you can
still see where it passes behind them
but the green dominates and the blue
dominates because we're now at 80
percent instead of 50 percent when you
can do less that's kind of fun although
at some point the lanes kind of fade
so 0.5 is usually the best setting on
there we have a nice pastel here at 0.3
and you can easily see where they cross
over and just like you can play with the
colors we can play with line width and
you know Let's do let's try DPI 100 and
see what that looks like on my screen
equals 100 and we'll go ahead and just
take our ax plot
let's do four of these lines just so you
can see how they look next to each other
click here there we go
and if I run this they should all appear
the same that automatically does
different colors on there so let's do
color equals blue
forgot my quotation marks there we go
and we'll go ahead and just make these
all blue just for purposes of being nice
and uniform and then what I want to do
is I want to do the line width
line width equals
0.25 and let's just copy copy and paste
that down here
let's do equals one
about 1.5 and let's do one let's make
this equal to two let's see what that
looks like and we do that you can see it
goes from a very thin line at 0.5 a 1 or
1.5 and 2 which is twice the width of
the one and if we're going to do
different sizes we had different colors
we had our Alpha scheme let's take this
whole thing here let's paste it down
here and do another one but instead of
line width let's look at Styles and
something to note here you can actually
abbreviate this with LW so line width
can also be Point let's just do
everything point two and let's set up a
line style we'll do the first one dashes
and let me just paste that down here so
I'm not doing a lot of extra typing
there we go
take this out so we have our dashed we
can do a dash dot let's do the dash dot
here and a colon here there we go and
there's a lot of different options we'll
look at a few more as we go down for
different ways of highlighting data but
when you look at this we have everything
as a line width of two and now we have a
straight line we have a dashed line or a
dot dash and a dot dot dot line
and then another thing we can add on
here is we're going to do here's our ax
plot and we did X plus two X plus four
so it goes right on the top and do color
black line width 1.5 so it's a smaller
line and we're going to take the line
and we're going to set dashes so look
I've changed some of the notation here
for my line and my X plot so I can set
my line comma equal to X plot and then I
can change the line settings this way
and when I run this let me run that on
here you'll see the 5 10 15 10 creates a
series of dashes that are varied in
length Link in this case they alternate
between a short Dash and a long Dash and
we can play with these numbers curiosity
always has me what happens when you play
with the numbers just to see what they
look like let's do this and let's paste
this down here I'll do two of these just
because they're kind of fun to play with
and let's change this from 10 to 3 and
we're going to change this one from 15
to to 4. and let's run that
you can see the differences in the lines
oops very a little bit confusing on
there because I forgot to change the
lines are all on top of each other so
let me change that really quick here and
let's run that and now you can see
here's our original dashed line
alternating when I change these numbers
on the second one the very end value to
3 you can see now we have the dashes of
five let's see I'm going to guess this
is a dash is a five skip ten dashes of
15 skip 3 and then it goes back to the
beginning dashes five dashes skip 10 15
dashes skip three and of course the last
one we just switched up a little bit it
looks a lot more uniform because I'm
using two sets of 10 or if I did
something like this and changed it to 30
it really becomes pronounced as far as
the distances between them and instead
of four let's go let's put 30 here also
30 by 30 there we go really pronounced
on that one and let's look at one more
important group for plotting our data
and in this we're gonna here's our plot
we started with with the the X Plus One
X plus two X plus three and did it in
Blue on this one's three or four
different blue lines
and this property we want to add the
actual plots so you can see where the
plots are on the graph and for that we
might have marker equals o and if we run
this you'll see it puts a DOT for each
of these and there's 25 dots because we
have 25 x values so we actually have
zero in each of the different values of
X Y are then plotted here with the dots
and we don't want to just limit
ourselves to dots
we can also do plus sign that's another
option dots is most common I'll actually
like the dots the best if we do the plus
signings here puts a nice crosshairs or
plus sign on there and we can do a
marker there's a number of different
markers you can use
I think this one was it s is another one
which is a nice square and that's
actually a good one s for square o for
period okay that's just kind of weird so
you can see that probably on these
markers another one is uh the number one
so if we run that you'll see we now have
these little hatch marks and let's take
all this just go with the o on this one
by the way this works with square really
nicely some of the stuff we're going to
do here on just a second let's do Marker
size equals two
change that to five and run that and you
can see here it's a nice little tiny dot
versus uh the size dot here and this is
interesting because it said two I
thought it would be bigger
but if you do 0.5 you can see even
smaller and let's just do 10 to see what
that looks like run that looks huge so
marker size a lot of these are dependent
on the DPI and the setups there's things
that switch around as far as the way the
size shows up you got to be a little
careful when you change one setting it
can change all the other markers all
right then let's take our Square on here
and we'll do we have marker size we also
have marker face we'll set that equal to
Red of course we're going to take change
the so it's up one notch we'll run that
whoops must have missed typed something
on here and I did is marker face color
equals red and so when I run that you
can now see I have the squares on there
with the marker face color of course we
can mix and match these come down here
and we'll make this instead of this
let's make this plus seven and we'll
make this
15 in
marker face color equals and we'll do
what green just because there we go run
very hard to actually see what's going
on there still 25 dots that kind of
overlap as you can see they print them
over each other and of course if we
really wanted to make it look horrible
we could just make that really huge
generally though you'd want something a
little bit smaller and cuter we'll just
try doing it this way there we go that's
too small to even see the face so four
you start to see the face on there
around four and maybe on eight eight
might be a good number for this there we
go eight again that all just depends on
what you're trying to show on display so
we've covered a lot of stuff here as far
as our lines we've covered opaque with
our Alpha setting on there give us some
nice pastels you can see how they
overlap and how they cross over we
covered the line width different size on
there different formats for the line
itself and these are all you can combine
all these so you can have our line width
equals two line style equals you can
bring this down here also to the markers
and then we added markers in just
entered a circle a plus sign the square
a little tick which uses a one then we
had a marker size and a marker color
face and we combine those you see we get
a nice different series of
representations we also briefly
mentioned color where you didn't have to
use like in here we used color black
someplace up here I'd have to find it we
use the actual number for the color as
opposed to I change them to red and blue
so you can get very precise on the color
if you have very specific color set that
you need to match your website or
whatever you're working on all of those
are tools in the matplot library so we
have one more piece to formatting the
graph so we want to show you and then we
have two big sections we're going to go
over the different graphs that they have
along with a challenge problem so let's
go in the last section we're going to
look at is limits we're going to limit
our data so this first parameter is
going to paste in there we're going to
create our subplots one two so one row
two columns we're going to do a figure
size a 10 comma five this should all
look familiar now since we've done a
number of them and we're going to go
ahead and plot and this is an
interesting notation you should notice
here our ax is zero so one we've used
instead of you can just iterate through
them but they're just an array so it's
an array of zero is still the axes of
the first axes out of two and we're
going to plot x x squared x x cubed line
width two so we're going to go ahead and
just plot two graphs right on top of
each other without doing multiple plots
on here and we'll set the grid equal to
True one here and let's go ahead and run
that and you can see here are two plots
with the x value going across and I'm
going to do something similar and by the
ways you can just if you look at it you
can see the Grid on there that's all
that is easier to spot the data going
across we're going to take the same data
for axes one so we have our plot of x x
squared x and x cubed line with two and
this time we're going to take our axes
one and do y limit that's actually set
underscore y limit this is the y-axis so
it's going to be an array of two two
values and we'll do zero comma 60. I'm
just making these numbers up the guys in
the back actually made a map I'm just
using their numbers and we're going to
set the x limit
and let's set the x limit as um don't
forget our brackets there 2 comma 5. so
it's the same data going in and but
we're setting a limit on it let's go
ahead and run that and let's see what it
comes out of and here we have the Y
limit 0 to 60. so we're looking at just
the lower part of this curve here up to
here and we have the X limit two to five
so that starts right here at 2 and you
can see very different graphs this is
kind of nice because you could actually
put one of these on top of the other if
you wanted to draw Focus to one part of
a graph remember how we did that earlier
one inside the other but just a quick
note you can easily limit your graph and
re kind of reshape the way it looks
quite easily and we can also add that
grid down there if you want a grid
we'll run that and add the Grid in there
oops I guess you have to do the grid
beforehand
switch that there we go sometimes the
order on this is really important so you
may double check your order when you're
printing these things out and also helps
if I change it to one so in this case it
might not be the order I wonder if I'll
go back here as one there we go so it
doesn't matter the order and grid but
you can set the grid for easy viewing in
here nice setup on there but you can see
how we can limit the data so let's start
looking at some other 2D graphs and make
the cell a markdown so we run it as a
nice pretty title to it and let's go
ahead and create some data with an NP
array we'll do 0 to 5 on here there we
go and let's look at four common graphs
we'll put them side by side so we'll do
a figure our axis equals plot subplots
one four columns and then figure size
hopefully it'll fit nicely on here it
seems to do a pretty good on here and
I'll go and just run that since we're in
there run you'll see I have my four
blank plots on here
and we'll start with axes of zero let's
set title
and we want this to be a scatter plot
a scatter plot just means it has a bunch
of dots on it so here's our axes of zero
dot scatter easy to remember scatter a
bunch of plots on there we'll do our in
we can do X or n
ope and let's go ahead and do axis set
title scatter up already did that we're
just going to do scatter
that's how you do it on there notice how
you create a scatter plot with simply
with the scattered control and we'll do
let's do the variable X X Plus let's
throw some Randomness in here use these
Scatter Plots are have a lot of random
numbers connected to them that's why
they do them on there and so the bigger
the X gets the bigger the randomness so
0.25 times the randomness and what we
should end up down here is with the
scatter plot and you can see as you go
up it just kind of has some random
numbers and moves up and down the line
but plus just the points so if you
remember from back up here where we did
marker this is plotting basically just
the marker so it's a scatter plot
probably less used is a step plot so for
X is one we'll go ahead and do a step
plot so you can see what that looks like
and this time I'll use our n value
instead of X we generated that n value
up here and so for this we have n n
times two or N squared n times 2 N
squared line width equals two and if we
run that it creates a nice Step Up
let's see so we've got a scatter plot
we've got a step plot let's do a bar
plot
and we'll use the same formula N N
squared alignment centered because you
can have them left or right width 0.5
and Alpha if you remember correctly
that's how opaque it is let's see what
that looks like on there so we have some
nice you can see here a nice bar plot it
should look very similar to the step
plot but color it in
and we can change the width let's see
what happens we do 0.9 run and if we
take width out completely
run that you can see it starts coming
together on there and we can change the
alpha we can take the alpha out too and
run that so now you have the solid
colors and if we take out the center
and run that everything you really can't
see the shift on here because that's
actually the default on this but these
are common settings for the bar graph
let me just put them back in there there
we go alignment center and Alpha now I
can't say I have Hues to step craft very
much there's certain other certain I
guess domains of expertise that require
a step graph but the scatter plot and
the bar graph very common especially the
bar graph and we'll look at histograms
here in just a minute so I use
histograms a lot especially in data
science but this is nice if you have
very concrete objects somebody how many
people are wearing yellow hats that kind
of thing but if we're going to do that
let's go ahead and do the last one which
I see a lot more in the Sciences
certainly using the data science but
more like for mapping I saw publication
on solar flares and they were discussing
the energy and so filling in the graph
gives it a very different look so we're
going to do the fill between and it's
just like you think it'd be it's fill
between but with a underscore between
them and we'll do x and x squared and x
and x cubed and we'll do color green and
Alpha again in case you had other data
you want to plot on there you can see it
forms a nice squared coming up here and
also if you look at the bottom one is
your squared value the upper line is
your cubed value and then it fills in
everything in between
if you remember from calculus this would
be if you had like a car a motor an
efficiency they would talk about the
efficiency going up and the loss and
you're looking for the space or the area
between the two lines so it gives you a
nice visual of that now let's look at a
few more basic two-dimensionals so we
have our figure figure size on here
we're going to do a radar chart to be
honest I've never used a radar chart in
business or in data science I have to
find a reason to use one now so the
first line for doing a radar chart we
have to add axes and the figure and with
this this actually creates our oh this
let's run it so you can see what it
creates it creates a nice looks like
you're on a submarine and you're
tracking The Hunt for Red October or
something like that and it needs all of
these the polar is the fact that we're
doing polar coordinates 0 0.6.6 has to
do with the size if you take out any of
these things and run them you get just a
box if you take out the other half you
pretty much get nothing in there and if
you change these numbers and change them
a little bit you can see it gets bigger
they had 0.6 on here I'll go ahead and
leave it as one because that's just kind
of fun that's all about the size on here
the height and the width and then let's
create some data T equals NP line space
and this is 0 to 2 times NP times pi so
if you remember that is the distance
across and we're going to generate a
hundred points so this is just a thing
of data we're putting together let me
simply do an ax Dot Plot and in this
case let's do T comma T which would be a
diagonal line and a regular chart and
we'll give it a nice color equals blue
and line width equals three let's see
what that looks like and we can see here
a spiral coming out remember this would
be just a diagonal line on a regular
chart what happens if we take this and
instead of T time 0.5 there we go and
you can see it slightly Alters the way
it spirals out we could do T times two
it spirals out a little quicker so it's
kind of just a fun like I said I've
never used a radar chart it's a column
but you can always think of radar under
submarine kind of looks like one of
those or on an airplane and none of this
would be complete if we didn't discuss
histograms oh my gosh do I use a
histogram so much and we'll use our
numpy that we have set as NP to generate
oh looks like we have a hundred thousand
variables we're going to set equal to n
and of course we create our figure and
our axes from subplots one two figure
size 12 14. so we're going to look at
two different variations of the
histogram and we'll set a title default
histogram set our title there and then
this is simply hit for histogram and
we'll just go ahead and put in our n in
there and let me run this and see what
that looks like
and let's talk about what is going on
here so we generated an array here of
data 1000 random arrays it looks like
they're mostly between minus four and
four and then it adds up each one it
says zero you have 35
000 that are zero so that's what's most
common on here and we have 20 000 that
are somewhere in this range right here
between the minus two and well it looks
like one and minus two and somewhere
between zero and one there's thirty
thousand numbers so all this is saying
is this is how common these variables
are and this gives you this is a point
in so many directions when you're
looking at data science to go ahead and
run your histogram so you should always
have your histogram and you can always
put limits and all the other different
things on your rate just like you did on
the other graphs on there and then we're
going to do a cumulative detailed
histogram and all it is is a histogram
let me just do that
and we set cumulative equal to true
and bins equal 50. and I really want to
highlight the the cumulative equals true
is important but we can now choose how
many bins we have in the first one it
kind of selected them for us in this
case let me go ahead and run this and
you'll see it has the printed data out
for us and here's our whoops I must have
missed there we go doesn't help that I
put it over the old one there we go okay
so now you have your default histogram
and now we have a cumulative histogram
and we should have 50 steps in there and
let's just find out if that's true not
So Much by counting them I'm not going
to count them if you want to you can
count them let's just change it to 10
and see what happens and we see here we
have now 10 counts of that
set that for five
and run that
and then we have our five on there and
we go ahead and take the cumulative
equals true out just so you can see what
that looks like and let me run that on
here too
that looks just like it did before I
think there's what one two three four
five six seven eight they have eight
different bins on here is what the
default came out of
that back in there run and so now it
should look almost identical and it does
and then we can put the cumulative back
in see what that looks like with the
cumulative
and run that
and we can see how that shifts
everything over and has a slightly
different look wait it shifts it all to
the right no it doesn't actually shift
it to the right it's cumulative so it's
the total of the different currencies
and so what that means is like if you
consider this like for the year of
rainfall we have like day one you had a
little bit of rain day two we have more
rain and so if you look at the number
this is a hundred thousand thirty five
thousand so it's a cumulative detail the
histogram the currents as it grows and
rainfall is a good one because that
would be a cumulative a histogram of how
much rain occurred throughout the year
and we're going to look at two more
graphs we've already looked at a bunch
of them we looked at our radar graph
we've looked at scatter step bar fill in
basic plots we've looked at different
ways of showing the data and we can
increase the size of the line the look
the color the alpha setting
so let's look at contour maps just put
that in there there we go draw a contour
map and before we draw a contour map we
need to go ahead and create data for it
and if you have Contours your data is
all going to have three different values
so let's go ahead and create the data
here we have our you'd import your
matplot library your numpy so we have
our numbers array I will import
metplot.cm and that's your color Maps so
you have all these different color maps
you can look at there's like hundreds of
color Maps so if you don't want to do
your own color you can even do your own
color map they're pretty diverse and of
course our PLT we're going to our PI
plot and to generate our different data
we're going to create a Delta 0.025 and
we'll start with X and we're going to
create an array between -3 and 3 and
Delta increments of 0.025
and we'll have our y we'll do something
similar and then we'll create our X Y
into a mesh grid again these are all
numpy commands so if you're not familiar
with these you'll want to go back and
review our numpy tutorial and we'll do
an exponential line here minus x squared
minus y squared for our Z1 we'll do a Z2
so we have two different areas and Z
equals z of one minus Z2 times 2. so
we've created a number of values here
and let me go ahead and run this and
let's plug that in so you can see where
those values are going so once we've set
these we're going to create our figure
and our X from our PLT subplots we're
going to create the variable Cs and this
is going to be our Contour so right here
CS is our Contour service and we're
feeding it X Y and Z if you remember X Y
we created as our X and Y components
using our mesh grid and you know what
let's do this just because it's kind of
good to see this let's go ahead and
print X and let's print Y and I always
like to do this when I'm working with
something this either is really
complicated in this case is what we're
looking at or you don't understand yet
so we've created a mesh grid and we have
x y and when we're done with this we end
up with here's our X
and this set of values in our y so those
are X and Y coordinates and then we've
also created Z based on our X and Y so
we have x capital x capital Y and
capital Z is our three components X and
Y being the coordinates well Z is going
to be our actual height since we're
doing a contour map so we created our
contour map from our X Y and Z
coordinates and we want to go ahead and
put in a c label maybe we want to go
ahead and do an title on here
we'll put that in our set title and this
is a contour there we go contour map and
let's go ahead and run this and see what
that looks like and you'll see we
generated a nice little contour map
there's different settings you can play
with on this but you can picture this
being you're on a mountain climb and
here we have a line that's represents
zero maybe at sea level and then moving
on up you have your Contours of 0.5 and
minus one and different setups little
Hills I guess if it's minus that's like
a pit so I guess you're going down into
a pit at minus five and minus one but on
the other side you can see you're going
up in levels so here's a mountain top
and here's like a basin of some kind and
in data science this could represent a
lot of things this could also be
representing two different values and
maybe profits and loss I don't know if
I'd ever really do that as a contour map
but I'm sure you can be creative and
find something fun to do with a contour
map and then we're going to look at one
last map which is the 3D map and those
are can be really important as a final
product because they can show so much
additional information that you can't
fit on two-dimensional graphs
there we go draw a 3D image and so we're
going to import from our MPL toolkits
the implant 3D and the axis 3D we're
going to import axis 3D this is what's
going to let us work with the 3D image
and this should look familiar we're
going to create another figure just like
we did before figure size 14 by 6 that's
a good fit on the screen we'll go ahead
and run that so we have our figure and
let's go ahead and take our ax and we're
going to set that equal to Fig dot add
subplot that should also be familiar
from earlier and we're going to work
with this sets the settings for the
projection we're going to use one two
one projection 3D and we'll see what
that looks like in just a minute and we
just created some three-dimensional data
here before where we had X Y and Z
capital X Y and Z so we're going to
reuse that data we're just going to use
that since this also this is also a
three-dimensional image so let's use
that for a three-dimensional graph and
we simply do ax plot underscore
surface and a capital x capital y
capital Z so there's our data coming in
and we're going to add some settings in
here we're going to do R stride 4 C
stride 4 and line width 0. I'll show you
what that is here in just a minute let's
go ahead and run that so we can see our
graph and of course it helps if I don't
add an extra comma in there and you can
see it generates this really beautiful
three-dimensional graph
so let's take a little bit time to
explore some of these numbers we have
going in here
we have the r stride 4 the C stride four
and the projection 3D projection 3D is
the important one because that's telling
us that this is a 3D graph here
so what are these first numbers one two
one let's just change one of these I'm
going to change this to five
and it's going to give me an error let's
change it to 1.
and oop that didn't work let's change
this middle one to three instead and
you're going to see how it starts
reshaping the size and how it fits on
the screen and we'll change the first
one to two and we'll run that one and
again it's changed the dimensions and
the size and how it fits on here play
with these numbers to get a nice look
and feel for it part of it is the Tilt
and the angle
we'll do seven on this one
there we go you can see it really
shifted it there
but again that changes the size and
outfits on the canvas but we'll leave it
at the one
two and just so you get a good look at
what that we're talking about here this
is column width and index from before
if we do one one one you can see that it
now spreads it out all the way across
uses the whole setup on there so this
has to do with the size and how big you
want it to be now there's one term that
we didn't cover in this yet but we've
used it throughout the whole setup
and I'm just going to type that down
here even though we're not going to go
into detail and that's the term heat map
you might see that is kind of starting
to lose ground as far as a common
reference but there sure are a lot of
people still talk about heat Maps what
is a heat map well it is simply a color
map that's all it is so if you ever see
the term heat map
that refers to the fact this is in
different colors representing different
heights
that one is in the heat map but you can
see up here we switched into let me go
back up here here we go this one has
different colors for the different
values a lot of times you'll use like
instead of X and Y you might do a heat
map
where you have a fourth value and the
fourth value represents the color and so
you'll see this 3D image into nice
colors represented by heat map that's
all it is so if you see the term heat
map that only means we're plotting some
of the data in color to make it stand
out or to give it a fourth dimension in
this case
so we've covered a lot of things on
matplot and that brings us covered all
the basics so that brings us to practice
example and this is going to be the
challenge for you and let me go ahead
and change our cell cell type mark down
and run that so it looks pretty
practice example write a Python program
to create a pie chart of the popularity
of programming languages
okay excellent
and if you're going to have a challenge
we need some data and I'll just throw in
our import our matplot library at the
beginning you should do that
automatically and so for our data to
plot we're going to have our languages
we're going to have python we're going
to have Java PHP JavaScript c-sharp C
plus plus so those are six categories
and then we have our popularity oops
misspelling there popularity we'll give
the first one 22.2 percent Java 17.6 and
I don't know if these are real numbers
they pulled my guess is that they might
have just been made up because I don't
know if Python's really that much more
popular than the other ones maybe
specific to data science because
Python's very popular in data science
right now because it has so many options
the only other program that's highly
used and exclusively for data science is
R so Python's big and python also does a
lot more it's a full programming
language where R is primarily for data
science they didn't put R in here so we
have python we have Java we have our PHP
see the different values they've given
it or different percentages
and I did add these up does not add up
to 100 it adds up to 71 percent or
something like that
and then we're going to give colors and
we've chosen these guys in the back
brought in these colors I'm not sure
what these colors are we'll find out in
a minute so I'll be exciting but you can
see they're using the actual color
values you can pull off of a color wheel
or something like that it could have
just as easily done blue red green if
you're too lazy to pick the exact colors
and then let's go ahead and solve this
and see we got here we're going to do
something a little fancy just because we
can the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to use a variable called
explode and you'll notice that there's
six variables in here so that matches
our six different categories and the
first one we've done is 0.1 and then
zero zero zero zero zero point one when
we put this in here under the explode in
the plot you'll actually push that
square out so it's a really cool feature
to highlight certain information on a
pie chart
and this is simply PLT dot pi and we're
plotting
popularity there we go and before we add
in all the really cool settings for this
let's go ahead and run it and you'll see
we generate a nice flat pie not too
exciting there and then we'll go ahead
and put in all the extras I talked about
explode or we can explode one of the
values out so here's our explode equals
explode labels as languages because we
want to know what the different colors
mean here's our colors equals colors our
Auto picture and this is standard print
format so that's a python setup on there
and that's just going to put the value
on the pi slice and then we're going to
add Shadow because it just looks cooler
with the shadow gives a little 3D look
and we'll do a start angle of 140. let's
go ahead and run this and take a look
and see what comes out of that
and look how that changes the whole
setup so here's our labels there's our
value we put on there there's our slice
it's pushed out there's our shadow a 3d
effect and then we started at 140. we
could also rotate this let's just do
this angle 90.
and if we run it
you'll see the blue pie slices moved up
a little bit we could actually do
actually let's just take the whole
starting triangle out and run he'll
default to zero
this is what it looks like if it
defaulted to zero so depending on where
you want the highlighted slice to appear
usually you want that to appear on the
left because people read left to right
and so it draws a focus onto in this
case Python and how great python is I'm
a little biased we're teaching a Python
tutorial so it should be understandable
that we're looking at Python and one
last reference before we close you can
go over to the matplot library.pi plot
setup and if you go underneath there the
different functions on there you can
look this up on their website you'll see
a full list and this is why it's so
important to go through a tutorial like
this because this list is just so
massive I'm trying to figure out like
here's our bar plot there's a bar H you
can add barbs there's a box plot we
didn't cover C labels a totally
different kind of for your Contour plot
you can set up in there if you go down
here we have our figures we used on
there we showed you the basics how to do
the figure you'll see some closer
references on those there's a histogram
down here hist there's also the hist 2D
makes a 2d histogram plot H lines all of
this these are all the different
commands that are underneath of here and
you can see it's pretty extensive we've
covered all the basic ones so that you
know have a solid ground to look at
these different options so when you come
to these functions some of them are
going to look a little off or not off
will look unfamiliar but you'll still
have the availability to probably
understand most of this and have a basic
understanding of your matplot library so
what is the site kit learn it's simple
and efficient tool for data mining and
data analysis it's built on numpy scipy
and matplot Library so it interfaces
very well with these other modules and
it's an open source commercially usable
BSD license BSD originally stood for
Berkeley software distribution license
but it means it's open source with very
few restrictions as far as what you can
do with it another reason to really like
site kit learn setup so you don't have
to pay for it as a commercial license
versus many other copyrighted platforms
out there what we can achieve using the
scikit learn we use class the two main
things or classification and regression
models classification identifying which
category an object belongs to for one
application very commonly used is Spam
detection so is it a Spam or is it not a
Spam yes no in banking it might be is
this a good loan bad loan today we'll be
looking at wine is it going to be a good
wine or a bad wine and regression is
predicting an attribute associated with
an object one example is stock prices
prediction what is going to be the next
value if the stock today sold for 23
dollars and five cents a share what do
you think it's going to sell for
tomorrow and the next day and the next
day so that would be a regression model
same thing with weather weather
forecasting any of these are regression
models where we're looking at one
specific prediction on one attribute
today we will be doing classification
like I said we're gonna be looking at
whether a wine is good or bad but
certainly the regression model which is
in many cases more useful because you're
looking for an actual value is also a
little harder to follow sometimes so
classification is a really good place to
start we can also do clustering and
model selection clustering is taking an
automatic grouping of similar objects
into sets customer segmentation is an
example so we have these customers like
this they'll probably also like this or
if you like this particular kind of
features on your objects maybe you like
these other objects so it's a referral
is a good one especially on Amazon.com
or any of your shopping networks model
selection comparing validating and
choosing parameters and models now this
is actually a little bit deeper as far
as a site kit learned we're looking at
different models for predicting the
right course or the best course or
what's the best solution today like I
said we're looking at Wines it's going
to be well how do you get the best wine
out of this so we can compare different
models and we'll look a little bit at
that and improve the model's accuracy
via different parameters and fine-tuning
now this is only part one so we're not
going to do two much tuning on the
models we're looking at but I'll Point
them out as we go two other features
dimensionality reduction and
pre-processing dimensionality reduction
is we're reducing the number of random
variables to consider this increases the
model efficiency we won't touch that in
today's tutorial but be aware if you
have you know thousands of columns of
data coming in thousands of features
some of those are going to be duplicated
or some of them you can combine to form
a new column and by reducing all those
different features into a smaller amount
you can have a you can increase the
efficiency of your model it can process
faster and in some cases you'll be less
biased because if you're weighing it on
the same feature over and over again
it's going to be biased to that feature
and pre-processing these are both
pre-processing but pre-processing is
feature extraction and normalization so
we're going to be transforming input
data such as text for use with machine
learning algorithms we'll be doing a
simple scaling in this one for our
pre-processing and I'll point that out
when we get to that and we can discuss
pre-processing at that point with that
let's go ahead and roll up our sleeves
and dive in and see what we got here now
I like to use the Jupiter notebook and I
use it out of the Anaconda Navigator so
if you install the Anaconda Navigator by
default it will come with the jupyter
notebook or you can install the jupyter
notebook by itself this code will work
in any of your python setups I believe
I'm running an environment of 3.7 setup
on there I'd have to go in here and
environments and look it up for the
python setup but it's one of the three
x's and we go ahead and launch this and
this will open it up in a web browser so
it's kind of nice it keeps everything
separate and in this Anaconda you can
actually have different environments
different versions of python different
modules installed in each environment so
it's a very powerful tool if you're
doing a lot of development and Jupiter
notebook is just a wonderful visual
display certainly you can use I know
spider is another one which is installed
with the Anaconda I actually use a
simple notepad plus plus when I'm doing
some of my python script any of your
Ides will work fine jupyter notebook is
iron python on because it's designed for
the interface but it's good to be aware
of these different tools and when I
launched the Jupiter notebook I'll open
up like I said a web page in here and
we'll go over here to New and create a
new python setup like I said I believe
this is python37 but any of the three
this the site kit learn works with any
of the three X's there's even two seven
versions so it's been around a long time
so it's very big on the development side
and then the guys in the back guys and
gals developed they went ahead and put
this together for me and let's go ahead
and import our different packages now if
you've been reading some of our other
tutorials you'll recognize pandas as PD
pandas library is pretty widely used
it's a data frame setup so it's just
like columns in rows and a spreadsheet
with a lot of different features for
looking stuff up the Seaborn sits on top
of matplot libraries this is for a
graphing and we'll see that how quick it
is to throw a graph out there to view in
The jupyter Notebook for demos and
showing people what's going on and then
we're going to use the the random Forest
the SVC or support vector classifier and
also the neural network so we're going
to look at this we're actually going to
go through and look at three different
classifiers that are most common some of
the most common classifiers and let's
show how those work in the scikit learn
setup and how they're different and then
if you're going to do your setup on here
you'll want to go ahead and import some
metrics so the sklearn.metrix on here
and we're going to use the confusion
metrics and the classification report
out of that and then we're going to use
from the sklearn pre-processing the
standard scalar and label encoder
standard scalar is probably the most
commonly used pre-processing there's a
lot of different pre-processing packages
in the sklearn and then model selection
for splitting our data up it's one of
the many ways we can split data into
different sections and the last line
here is our percentage matplot library
in line some of the Seaborn and matplot
Library will go ahead and display
perfectly in line without this and some
won't it's it's good to always include
this when you're in the Jupiter notebook
this is Jupiter notebook so if you're in
ide when you run this it will actually
open up a new window and display the
graphics that way so you only need this
if you're running it in a editor like
this one with the specifically Jupiter
notebook I'm not even familiar with
other editors that are like this but I'm
sure they're out there I'm sure there's
a Firefox version or something Jupiter
notebook just happens to be the most
widely used out there and we can go
ahead and hit the Run button and this
now has saved all this underneath the
packages so my packages are now all
loaded I've run them whether you read it
on top we run it to the left and all the
packages are up there so we now have
them all available to us for our project
we're working on and I'm just going to
make a little side note on that when
you're playing with these and you delete
something out and add something in even
if I went back and deleted this cell and
just hit the scissors up here these are
still loaded in this kernel so until I
go under kernel and restart or restart
and clear or restart and run all I'll
still have access to pandas yeah
important to know because I've done that
before I've loaded up maybe not a module
here but I've loaded up my own code and
then changed my mind and wondering why
does it keep putting out the wrong
output and then I realize it's still
loaded in the kernel and you have to
restart the kernel just a quick side
note for working with a jupyter notebook
and one of the troubleshooting things
that comes up and we're going to go and
load up our data set we're using the
pandas so if you haven't yet go look at
our pandas tutorial a simple read the
CSV with the separation on here so let
me go ahead and run that and that's now
loaded into the variable wine and let's
take a quick look at the actual file I
always like to look at the actual data
I'm working with in this case we have
wine quality Dash red I'll just open
that up I have it in my open Office
setup separated by semicolons that's
important to notice
and we open that up you'll see we have
go all the way down here it looks like
1600 lines of data minus the first one
so 15
1599 lines and we have a number of
features going across the last one is
quality and right off the bat we see the
quality is uh has different numbers in
it five six seven it's not really I'm
not sure how how high of a level it goes
but I don't see anything over a seven so
it's kind of five through seven is what
I see here five six and seven four five
six and seven looking to see if there's
any other values in there looking
through the demo to begin with I didn't
realize the setup on this so you can see
there's a different quality values in
there alcohol sulfates pH density total
sulfur dioxide and so on those are all
the features we're going to be looking
at and since this is a pandas we'll just
do wine head and that prints the first
five rolls rows of data that's of course
a pandas command and we can see that
looks very similar to we were looking at
before we have everything across here
it's automatically assigned an index on
the left
if you don't give it an index and for
the column names it has assigned the
first row so we have our first row of
data pulled off the our comma separated
variable file in this case semicolon
separated and it shows the different
features going across and we have what
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven features 12 including
quality but that's the one we want to
work on and understand and then because
we're in Panda's data frame we can also
do wine dot info and let's go ahead and
run that this tells us a lot about our
variables we're working with you'll see
here that there is
1599 that's what I said from the
spreadsheet so that looks correct
non-null float 64. this is a very
important information especially the
non-nullness there's no null values in
here that can really trip us up in
pre-processing and there's a number of
ways to process non-null values one is
just to delete that data out of there so
if you have enough data in there you
might just delete your non-null values
another one is to fill that information
in with like the average or the most
common values or other such means but
we're not going to have to worry about
that but we'll look at another way
because we can also do wine is null and
sum it up and this will give us a
similar it won't tell us that these are
float values but it will give us a
summation oops there we go let me run
the he'll give us a summation on here
how many null values in each one so if
you wanted to you know from here you
would be able to say okay this is a null
value but she doesn't tell you how many
are null values this one would clearly
tell you that you have maybe five null
values here two null values here and you
might just if he had only seven null
values and all that different data you'd
probably just delete them out where if
ninety percent of the data was null
values you might rethink either a
different data collection setup or find
a different way to deal with the null
values we'll talk about that just a
little bit in the models too because the
models themselves have some built-in
features especially the forest model
which we're going to look at this point
we need to make a choice and to keep it
simple we're going to do a little
pre-processing of the data and we're
going to create some bins and bins we're
going to do is 2 comma 6.5 comma 8. what
this means is that we're going to take
those values if you remember up here let
me just scroll back up here we had our
quality the quality comes out between
two and eight basically or one and eight
we have five five five six you can see
just in the just in the first five lines
of variation in quality we're going to
separate that into just two bins of
quality and so we've decided to create
two bins and we have bad and good it's
going to be the labels on those two bins
we have a spread of 6.5 and an exact
index of eight the exact index is
because we're doing zero to eight on
there the 6.5 we can change we could
actually make this smaller or greater
but we're only looking for the really
good wind we're not looking for the zero
one two three four five six we're
looking for wines with seven or eight on
us so high quality you know this is what
I want to put on my dinner table at
night
I want to taste the good wine not the
semi-good wine or mediocre wine and then
this is a panda so PD remember stands
for pandas pandas cut means we're
cutting out the wine quality and we're
replacing it and then we have our bins
equals bins that's the command bins is
the actual command and then our variable
bends to comma 6.58 so two different
bins and our labels bad and good and we
can also do let me just do it this way
wine quality since that's what we're
working on and let's look at unique
another pandas command and we'll run
this and I get this lovely error why did
I get an error well because I replaced
wine quality and I did this cut here
which changes things on here so I
literally altered one of the variables
is saved in the memory so we'll go up
here to the kernel restart and run all
that starts it from the very beginning
and we can see here that that fixes the
error because I'm not cutting something
that's already been cut we have our wine
quality unique and the wine quality
unique is a bad or good so we have two
qualities objects bad is less than good
meaning that's going to be zero and good
is going to be 1. and to make that
happen we need to actually encode it so
we'll use the label quality equals label
encoder and the label encoder let me
just go back there so this is part of
sklearn that was one of the things we
imported it was a label encoder you can
see that right here from the
sklearn.processing import standard
scalar which we're going to use in a
minute and label encoder and that's what
tells it to use that equals 0 and good
equals one and we'll go ahead and run
that and then we need to apply it to the
data and when we do that we take our
wine quality that we had before and
we're going to set that equal to label
quality which is our encoder and let's
look at this line right here we have dot
fit transform and you'll see this in the
pre-processing these are the most common
used is fit transform and fit transform
because they're so often that you're
also transferring the data when you fit
it they just combine them into one
command and we're just going to take the
wine quality feed it back into there and
put that back in our wine quality setup
and run that and now when we do the wine
and the head of the first five values
and we go ahead and run this you can see
right here underneath quality zero zero
zero I have to go down a little further
to look at the better wines
let's see if we have some that are ones
yeah there we go there's some ones down
here so when you look at 10 of them you
can see all the way down to zero or one
that's our quality and again we're
looking at high quality we're looking at
the seven and the eights or six point
five and up and let's go ahead and grab
our or was it here we go wine quality
and let's take another look at what else
more information about the wine quality
itself and we can do a simple pandas
thing value counts hopefully I type that
in there correctly and we can see that
we only have 217 of our wines which are
going to be the higher quality so 217
and the rest of them fall into the bad
bucket the zero which is uh 1382 so
again we're just looking for the top
percentage of these the top what is that
it's probably about a little a little
under 20 percent on there so we're
looking for our top wines our seven and
eights and let's use our let's plot this
on a graph so we take a look at this and
the SNS if you remember correctly that
is let me just back at the top that's
our Seaborn Seaborn sits on top of
matplot Library it has a lot of added
features plus all the features of the
matplot library and also makes it quick
and easy to put out a graph we'll do a
simple bar graph and they actually call
it count plot and then we want to just
do count plot the wine quality so let's
put our wine quality in there and let's
go ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and nice in line remember
this is why we did the inline so make
sure it appears in here and you can see
the blue space or the first space
represents low quality wine and our
second bar is a high quality line and
you can see that we're just looking at
the top quality wine here most of wine
we want to just give it away to the
neighbors now maybe if you don't like
your neighbors maybe give them the good
quality wine and I don't know what you
do with the bed quality wine I guess use
it for cooking there we go but you can
see here it forms a nice little graph
for us with the Seaborn on there and you
can see our setup on that so now we've
looked at we've done some pre-processing
we've described our data a little bit we
have a picture of how much of the wine
what we expect it to be high quality low
quality checked out the fact that
there's none we don't have any null
values to contend with or any odd values
some of the other things you sometimes
look at these is if you have like some
values that are just way off the chart
so the measurement might be off or
miscalibrated equipment if you're in the
scientific field so the next step we
want to go ahead and do is we want to go
ahead and separate our data set or
reformat our data set and we usually use
capital x and that denotes the features
we're working with and we usually use a
lowercase y that denotes what in this
case quality what we're looking for and
we can take this we can go wine it's
going to be our full thing of wine
dropping what are we dropping we're
dropping the quality so these are all
the features minus quality I'll make
sure we have our axes equals one if you
left it out it would still come out
correctly just because of the way it
processes on the defaults and then our y
if we're going to remove quality for our
X that's just going to be 1 and it is
just the quality that we're looking at
for y so we put that in there and we'll
go ahead and run this so now we've
separated the features that we want to
use to predict the quality of the wine
and the quality itself the next step is
if you're going to create a data set in
a model we got to know how good our
model is so we're going to split the
data train and test splitting data and
this is one of the packages we imported
from sklearn and the actual package was
train test split and we're going to do X
Y test size 0.2 random State 42 and this
returns four variables and most common
you'll see is capital x train so we're
going to train our set with capital X
test that's the data we're going to keep
on the side to test it with why train
why remember stands for the quality or
the answer we're looking for so when we
train it we're going to use x train and
Y train and then why test to see how
good our X test does and the train test
split let me just go back up to the top
that was part of the sklearn model
selection import train test split there
is a lot of ways to split data up this
is when you're first starting you do
your first model you probably start with
the basics on here you have one test for
training one for test our test size is
0.2 or 20 percent and random State just
means we just start with a it's like a
random seed number so it's not too
important back there we're randomly
selecting which ones we're going to use
since this is the most common way this
is what we're going to use today there
is and it's not even an sklearn package
yet so someone's still putting it in
there one of the new things they do is
they split the data into thirds and then
they'll run the model on each of they
combine each of those thirds into
two-thirds for training and one for
testing and so you actually go through
all the data and you come up with three
different test results from it which is
pretty cool that's a pretty cool way of
doing it you could actually do that with
this by just splitting this into thirds
and then or you know have a test site
one test set third and then split the
training set also into thirds and also
do that and get three different data
sets this works fine for most projects
especially when you're starting out
works great so we have our X train our X
test our y train and our y test and then
we need to go ahead and do the scalar
and let's talk about this because this
is really important some models do not
need to have scaling going on most
models do and so we create our scalar
variable we'll call it SC standard
scalar and if you remember correctly we
imported that here wrong with the label
encoder the standard scalar setup so
there's our scalar and this is going to
convert the values instead of having
some values that go from zero if you
remember up here we had some values are
54 60 40 59 102. so our total sulfur
dioxide would have these huge values
coming into our model and some models
would look at that and they'd become
very biased to sulfur dioxide it'd have
the hugest impact and then a value that
had
0.076.098 our chlorides would have very
little impact because it's such a small
number so when we take the scalar we
kind of level the playing field and
depending on our scalar it sets it up
between 0 and 1 a lot of times is what
it does let's go ahead and take a look
at that and we'll go ahead and start
with our X train and our X train equals
SC fit transform we talked about that
earlier that's an sklearn setup it's
going to both fit and transform our X
train into our X train variable and if
we have an X train we also need to do
that to our test and this is important
because you need to note that you don't
want to refit the data we want to use
the same fit we used on the training is
on the testing otherwise you get
different results and so we'll do just
oops not fit
form we're only going to transform the
test side of the data so here's our X
test that we want to transform and let's
go ahead and run that and just so we
have an idea let's go ahead and take and
just print out our X train oh let's do
first 10 variables very similar to the
way you do with the head on a data frame
you can see here our variables are now
much more uniform and they've scaled
them to the same scale so they're
between certain numbers and with the
basic scalar you can fine tune it I just
let it do its defaults on this and
that's fine for what we're doing in most
cases you don't really need to mess with
it too much it does look like it goes
between like minus probably minus two to
two or something like that that's just
looking at the train variable I'm going
to cut that one out of there so before
we actually build the models and start
discussing the SK learn models we're
going to use we covered a lot of ground
here most of when you're working with
these models you put a lot of work into
pre prepping the data so we looked at
the day data notice that it's separated
loaded it up we went in there we found
out there's no null values that's hard
to say no no values we have there's none
there's none nobody I can't say it
and of course we sum it up if you had a
lot of null values this would be really
important coming in here so is there a
null summary we looked at pre-processing
the data as far as the quality and we're
looking at the bins so this would be
something you might start playing with
maybe you don't want super fine wine you
don't want the seven and eights maybe
you want to split this differently so
certainly you can play with the bins and
get different values and make the bins
smaller or lean more towards the lower
quality so you then have like medium to
high quality and we went ahead and gave
it the labels again this is all pandas
we're doing in here setting up with
unique labels and group names bad good
bad is less than good that could be so
important you don't know how many times
people go through these models and they
have them reversed or something and then
they go back and they're like why is
this data not looking correct so it's
important to remember what you're doing
up here and double check it and we used
our label encoder so that was to set
that up as equality zero one good in
this case we have bad good zero one and
we just double check that to make sure
that's what came up in the quality there
and then we threw it into a graph
because people like to see graphs I
don't know about you but you start
looking all these numbers and all this
text and you get down here and you say
oh yes you know here this is how much of
the wine we're going to label as subpar
not good and this is how much we're
going to label as good and then we got
down here to finally separating out our
data so it's ready to go into the models
and the models take X and A Y in this
case X is all of our features minus the
one we're looking for and then Y is the
features we're looking for so in this
case we dropped quality and in the Y
case we added quality and then because
we need to have a training set and a
test set so we can see how good our
models do we went ahead and split the
models up X train X test y train y test
and that's using the train test split
which is part of the sklearn package and
we did as far as our testing size 0.2 or
20 percent the default is 25 so if you
leave that out it'll do default setup
and we did a random State equals 42. if
you leave that out it'll use a random
State I believe it's default one I'd
have to look that back up and then
finally we scaled the data this is so
important to scale the data going back
up to here if you have something that's
coming out as a hundred it's going to
really outweigh something that's .071
that's not in all the models different
models handle it differently and as we
look at the different models I'll talk a
little bit about that we're going to
only look at three models today three of
the top models used for this and see how
they compare and how the numbers come
out between them so we're going to look
at three different setups change my cell
here to mark down there we go and we're
going to start with the random Forest
classifier so the three sets we're
looking at is the random Forest
classifier support vector classifier and
then a neural network now we start with
the random Forest classifier because it
has the least amount of Parts moving
parts to fine tune and let's go ahead
and put this in here so we're going to
call it RFC for random force classifier
and if you remember we imported that so
let me go back up here to the top real
quick and we did an import of the random
fourth classifier from sklearn Ensemble
and then we'll all we also let me just
point this out here's our svm or we
inputted our support Vector classifier
so svm is support Vector model support
vector classifier and then we also have
our neural network and we're going to
from there the multi-layered precipitron
classifier kind of a mouthful for the P
percepatron don't worry too much about
that name it's just it's a neural
Network there's a lot of different
options on there and setups which is
where they came up with the precipitron
but so we have our three different
models we're going to go through one
here and then we're going to weigh them
here's our metric so we're going to use
a confusion metrics also from the SK
learn package to see how good our model
does with our split so let's go back
down there and take a look at that and
we have our RFS equals random forest
classifier and we have n estimators
equals 200. this is the only value you
play with with a random Force classifier
how many forests do you need or how many
trees in the forest and so how many
models are in here that makes it pretty
good as a startup model because you're
only playing with one number and it's
pretty clear what it is and you can
lower this number or raise it usually
start up with a higher number and then
bring it down to see if it keeps the
same value so you have less you know the
smaller the model the better the fit and
it's easier to send out to somebody else
if you're going to distribute it now the
random 4 is classified fire everything I
read says it's used for kind of a
medium-sized data set so you can run it
in on Big Data you can run it on smaller
data obviously but tends to work best in
the mid-range and we'll go ahead and
take our RFC and I just copied this from
the other side dot fit X train comma y
train so we're sending it our features
and then the quality in the Y train what
we want to predict in there and we just
do a simple fit now remember this is
sklearn so everything is fit or
transform another one is predict which
we'll do in just a second here let's do
that now predict
FC equals and it's our RFC model predict
and what are we predicting on well we
trained it with our train values so now
we need our test our X test so this has
done it this is going to do this is the
three lanes of code we need to create
our random Force variable fit our
training data to it so we're programming
it to fit in this case it's got 200
different trees it's going to build and
then we're going to predict on here let
me go ahead and just run that and we can
actually do something like oh let's do
predict
RFC just real quick we'll look at the
first 20 variables of it let's go ahead
and run that and in our first 20
variables we have three wines that make
the cut and the other 17 don't so the
other 17 are bad quality and three of
them are good quality in our predicted
values and if you can remember correctly
we'll go ahead and take this out of here
this is based on our test so these are
the first 20 values in our test and this
has as you can see all the different
features listed in there and they've
been scaled so when you look at these
they're a little bit confusing to look
at and hard to read but we have there's
a minus 01 so this is 0.36 minus so one
so 0.164 minus 0.09 or no it's still
minus one so minus 0.9 all between 0 and
1 on here I think I was confused earlier
and I said 0 between 2 negative two but
it's between minus one and one which is
what it should be in the scale and we'll
go ahead and just cut that out of there
run this we have our setup button here
so now that we've run the prediction and
we have predicted values well one you
could publish them but what do we do
with them well we want to do with them
is we want to see how well our model
model performed that's the whole reason
for splitting it between a training and
testing model and for that remember we
imported the classification report
that was again from the SK learn there's
our confusion Matrix and classification
report and the classification report
actually sits on the confusion Matrix so
it uses that information and our
classification report we want to know
how good our y test that's the actual
values versus our predicted RFC so we'll
go ahead and print this report out and
let's take a look and we can see here we
have a Precision out of the zero we had
about 0.92 that were labeled as a bad
that were actually bad and out of
precision for the quality wines we're
running about 78 percent so you kind of
give us an overall 90 percent and you
can see our F1 score our support set up
on there a recall you could also do the
confusion Matrix on here which gives you
a little bit more information but for
this this is going to be good enough for
right now we're just going to look at
how good this model was because we want
to compare the random force classifier
with the other two models and you know
what let's go ahead and put in the
confusion Matrix just so you can see
that on there with Y test and prediction
RFC so in the confusion Matrix we can
see here that we had
266 correct and seven wrong these are
the missed labels for bad wine and we
had a lot of mislabels for good wine so
our quality labels aren't that good
we're good at predicting bad wine not so
good at predicting whether it's a good
quality wine important to note on there
so that is our basic random forest
classifier and let me go ahead of cell
change cell type to mark down and run
that so we have a nice label let's look
at our svm classifier our support Vector
model and this would look familiar we
have our clf we're going to create
what's it we'll call it just like we
call this an RFC and then we'll have our
clf DOT fit and this should be identical
to up above X
train comma y train and just like we did
before let's go ahead and do the
prediction and here is our clf predict
and it's going to equal the clf dot
predict and we want to go ahead and use
x underscore test and right about now
you can realize that you can create
these different models and actually just
create a loop to go through your
different models and put the data in and
that's how they designed it they
designed it to have that ability let's
go ahead and run this and then let's go
ahead and do our classification report
and I'm just going to copy this right
off of here
they say you shouldn't copy and paste
your code and the reason is is when you
go in here and edit it
you invariably will miss something we
only have two lines I think I'm safe to
do it today and let's go ahead and run
this
and let's take a look how the svm
classifier came out so up here we had a
90 and down here we're running about an
86 percent so it's not doing as good now
remember we randomly split the data so
if I run this a bunch of times you'll
see some changes down here so these
numbers this size of data if I read it
100 times it would probably be within
plus or minus three or four on here in
fact if I ran this 100 times you'd
probably see these come out almost the
same as far as how well they do in
classification and then on the confusion
Matrix let's take a look at this one
this had 22 by 25 this one has 35 by 12.
so it's doing not quite as good that
shows up here 71 percent versus 78
percent and then if we're going to do a
svm classifier we also want to show you
one more and before I do that I'll kind
of tease you a little bit here before we
jump into neural networks the big save
all deep learning because everything
else must be shallow learning that's a
joke let's just talk a little bit about
the svm versus the random Forest
classifier the svm tends to work better
on smaller numbers it also works really
good on because a lot of times you
convert things into numbers and bins and
things like that the random Forest tends
to do better with those at least that's
my brief experience with it where if you
have just a lot of raw data coming in
the svm is usually the fastest and
easiest to apply model on there so they
each have their own benefits you'll find
that again that when you run these like
a hundred times difference between these
two on a data set like this is going to
just go away there's Randomness involved
depending on which data we took and how
they classify them the big one is the
neural networks and this is what makes
the neural networks nice is they can do
they can look into huge amounts of data
so for a project like this you probably
don't need a neural network on this but
it's important to see how they work
differently and how they come up
differently so you can work with huge
amounts of data you can also many
respects they work really good with text
analysis especially if it's time
sensitive more and more you have an
order of text and they've just come out
with different ways of feeding that data
in where the series and the Order of the
words is really important same thing
with starting to predict in the stock
market if you have tons of data coming
in from different sources the neural
network can really process that in a
powerful way to pull up things that
aren't seen before when I say lots of
data coming in I'm not talking about
just the high lows that you can run an
svm on real easily I'm talking about the
data that comes in where you have maybe
you pulled off the Twitter feeds and
have word counts going on and you've
pulled off the the different news feeds
the business are looking at and the
different releases when they release the
different reports so you have all this
different data coming in and the neural
network does really good with that
pictures picture processing Now is
really moving heavily into the neural
network if you have a pixel 2 or pixel 3
phone put out by Google it has a neural
network for doing uh it's kind of goofy
but you can put Little Star Wars
Androids dancing around your pictures
and things things like that that's all
done with the neural network so it has a
lot of different uses but it's also
requires a lot of data and is a little
heavy-handed for something like this and
this should now look familiar because
we've done it twice before we have our
multi-layered precipitron classifier
we'll call it an mlpc and it's this is
what we imported mlpc classifier there's
a lot of settings in here the first one
is the hidden layers you have to have
the hidden layers in there we're going
to do three layers of 11 each so that's
how many nodes are in each layer as it
comes in and that was based on the fact
we have 11 features coming in then I
went ahead and just did three layers
probably get by with a lot less on this
but yeah I didn't want to sit and play
with it all afternoon again this is one
of those things you play with a lot
because the more hidden layers you have
the more resources you're using you can
also run into problems with overfitting
with too many layers and you also have
to run higher iterations the max
iteration we have is set to 500. the
default's 200 because I use three layers
of 11 each which is by the way kind of a
default I use I realized that usually
have about three layers going down and
the number of features going across
you'll see that it's pretty common for
the first classifier when you're working
in neural networks but it also means you
have to do higher iterations so we up
the iterations to 500 so that means it's
going through the data 500 times to
program those different layers and
carefully adjust them and we do have a
full tutorials you can go look up on
neural networks and understand the
neural network settings a lot more and
of course we have you're looking over
here where we had our previous model
where we fit it same thing here mlpc fit
X train y train and then we're going to
create our prediction so let's do our
predict and mlpc and it's going to equal
the mlpc and we'll just take the same
thing here predict X test
just put that down here dot predict test
and if I run that we've now programmed
it we now have our prediction here same
as before and we'll go ahead and do the
copy print again always be careful with
the copy paste now because you always
run the chance of missing one of these
variables so if you're doing a lot of
coding you might want to skip that copy
and paste and just type it in let's go
ahead and run this and see what that
looks like and we came up with an 88
percent we're going to compare that with
the 86 from our tree our svm classifier
and our 90 from the random forest
classifier and keep in mind random
Forest classifiers they do good on
mid-size data the SPM on smaller amounts
of data although to be honest I don't
think that's initially the split between
the two and these things will actually
come together if you ran them a number
of times and we can see down here the
noun of good wines mislabeled with the
setup on there it's on par with our
random Forest so it had 22 25 should be
surprised it's identical it just didn't
do as good with the bad wines labeling
what's a bad one and what's not so yeah
because they had 266 and seven we head
down here 260 and 13. so mislabeled a
couple of the bad wines as good wines so
we've explored three of these basic
classifiers these are probably the three
most widely used right now I might even
throw in the random tree if we open up
their website we go under supervised
learning there's a linear model we
didn't do that almost most of data
usually just start with a linear model
because it's going to process the
quickest I'm going to use the least
amount of resources but you can see they
have linear quadratic they have kernel
Ridge there's our support Vector of
stochastic gradient nearest neighbors
nearest neighbors is another common one
that's used a lot very similar to the
svm gaussian process cross decomposition
naive Bayes this is more of an
intellectual one that I don't see used a
lot but it's like the basis of a lot of
other things decision tree there's
another one that's used a lot Ensemble
methods not as much multi-class and
multi-label algorithms feature selection
neural networks that's the other one we
use down here and of course the forest
so you can see there's a in sklearn
there are so many different options and
they've just developed them over the
years we covered three of the most
commonly used ones in here and went over
a little bit over why they're different
neural network just because it's fun to
work in deep learning and not in Shallow
learning as I told you that doesn't mean
that the svm is actually shallow it does
a lot of it covers a lot of things and
same thing with the decision true the
random forest classifier and we notice
that there's a number of other different
classifier options in there these are
just the three most common ones and I'd
probably throw the nearest neighbor in
there and the decision tree which is
usually part of the decision for us
depending on what the back end you're
using and since as human beings if I was
in the shareholders office I wouldn't
want to leave them with a confusion
Matrix they need that information for
making decisions but we want to give
them just one particular score and so I
would go ahead and we have a
sklearnmetrics we're going to import the
accuracy score and I'm just going to do
this on the random 4 since that was our
best model and we have our CM accuracy
score and I forgot to print it if you
remember in jupyter Notebook we can just
do the last variable we leave out there
it'll print and so our CM accurate score
we get is 90 percent and that matches up
here we should already see that up here
in Precision so you can either quote
that but a lot of times people like to
see it highlighted at the very end this
is our Precision on this model and then
the final stage is we would like to use
this for future so let's go ahead and
take our wine if you remember correctly
we'll do one head of 10. we'll run that
remember our original data set we've
gone through so many steps now we're
going to go back to the original data
and we can see here we have our top 10
our top 10 on the list only two of them
make it as having high enough quality
wine for us to be interested in them and
then let's go ahead and create some data
here we'll call it X Nu equals and this
is important this data has to be we just
kind of randomly selected did some data
looks an awful lot like some of the
other numbers on here which is what it
should look like and so we have our X Nu
equals
7.3.58 and so on and then it is so
important this is where people forget
this step X Nu equals SC remember SC
that was our standard scalar variable we
created if we go right back up here
before we did anything else we created
an sc we fit it and we transformed it
and then we need to do what transform
the data we're going to feed in
so we're going to go back down here and
we're going to transform our X new and
then we're going to go ahead and use the
where are we at here we go our random
forest and if you remember all it is is
our RFC predict model right there let's
go ahead and just grab that down here
and so our y Nu equals here's our RFC
predict and we're going to do our X new
in and then it's kind of nice to know
what it actually puts out so according
to this it should print out what our
prediction is for this wine and oh it's
a bad wine okay so we didn't pick out a
good wine for our X new and that should
be expected most of wine if you remember
correctly only a small percentage of the
wine met our quality requirements so we
can look at this and say oh we'll have
to try another wine out which is fine by
me because I like to try out new wines
and I certainly have a collection of old
wine bottles and very few of them match
but you can see here we've gone through
the whole process just a quick rehash we
had our Imports we touched a lot on the
SK learn our random Forest our svm and
our MLP classifier so we had our support
vector classifier
our random forests and we have our
neural network three of the top used
classifiers in the sklearn system and we
also have our confusion Matrix and our
classification report which we used our
standard scalar for scaling it and our
label encoder and of course we need to
go ahead and split our data up in our
implot line train and we explored the
data in here for null values we set up
our quality into bins we took a look at
the data and what we actually have and
put a nice little plot to show our
quality what we're looking at and then
we went through our three different
models and it's always interesting
because you spend so much time getting
to these models and then you kind of go
through the models and play with them
until you get the best training on there
without becoming biased that's always a
challenge is to not over train your data
to the point where you're training it to
fit the test value and finally we went
ahead and actually used it and applied
it to a new wine which unfortunately
didn't make the cut it's going to be the
one that we drink a glass out of and
save the rest for cooking
of course that's according to the random
Forest on there because we use the best
model that it came up with if you are
one of the aspiring data scientists
looking for online training and
graduating from the best universities or
a professional who elicits to switch
careers with data analytics by learning
from the experts then try giving a show
to Simply learn skeleton postgraduate
programming data science in
collaboration with IBM the link is
mentioned in the description box and you
should navigate to the home page where
you can find a complete order of the
program being offered
so what is C born in Python the c bond
library in Python is a widely popular
data visualization library that is
commonly used for data science and
machine learning tasks
it is built on top of the matplotlab
data visualization Library
and allows you to perform exploratory
data analysis
using c bond you can create interactive
plots to answer specific questions about
your data
it helps you find Trends in your data
that you can't notice just by looking at
the data
now to understand the C1 library in
detail and how to create different plots
and know the data better we will be
using two data sets in our demo
the first one is the empty cast data set
and the second is the popular Iris
flower data set
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and start with our
demonstration
so I am on my jupyter notebook let me go
ahead and rename the notebook I'll say
c bond
demo
will rename it
all right
you can see I have
the first two cells already filled in so
while working on an exploratory data
analysis project using python you will
need numpy pandas matplotlib and cmon
libraries for data manipulation and
visualization
so let's import these libraries first so
I've already written input numpy as NP
pandas SPD matplotlib dot Pi plot as PLT
C bonus SNS
all right so I'll hit shift enter to run
this first cell
all right
Now using the read underscore CSV
function that is present in the pandas
Library I am importing my data set that
is empty cars I'll tell you what empty
cars is about this is a CSP data set and
here I have given the location where my
data set is present
let's run it
all right
now
let me go ahead and print the first
five rows
of my empty cars
data frame
for that I am using the head function if
I run it
okay you can see here it has given me
the first five rows the index starts
from 0 till 4 so total five rows of
information and
you can see these are the columns that
are present in the empty cast data set
the first is the
model of the car
now just let me give you a background
about this data set so the data is taken
from the 1974 Motor Trend U.S magazine
it has information about fuel
consumption and 11 different aspects of
automobile design and performance of 32
cars
all right
so here we have the First Column as the
model of the car and then we have MPG
which is miles per gallon
then we have C by L which stands for the
number of cylinders in the vehicle or
the car
then we have disp which is displacement
in cubic inches so these all values are
in cubic inches
after that we have HP which is cross
horsepower
then we have something called as dret
which is basically the rear axle ratio
then we have WT which is the
weight of the
car in pounds
so think of it as weight multiplied by
thousand pounds
all right and then we have q SEC which
is one fourth mile time this is a
measure for acceleration
then we have something called as vs this
is
the type of engine for each of the
vehicles so 0 stands for v-shaped engine
and one stands for straight engine
then we have am which is basically
the mode of transmission so 0 is for
automatic transmission and one is for
manual transmission
then we have the number of
forward gears present in the vehicle and
then we have something called as carb or
carb
this stands for the number of
carburetors so carburetors is a device
for supplying a spark ignition engine
with a mixture of fuel and Air
all right
now
we'll use the info function to print the
summary of the data frame so the info
function returns information regarding
the index data type column data types
then we have the information about
non-null values and memory usage
so I'll write my data frame name which
is empty cars
dot I am going to use the info function
let's run it and here you can see we
have
all the columns there are total 32
entries from 0 to 31 so data about 32
cars
then here you can see the data types
and the memory usage
now moving ahead
let me just print the shape of the data
frame that will give you the number of
rows and columns present
I'll use this shape attribute
you can see here there are total 32 rows
and 12 columns in my data set now the c
bond Library provides a range of
plotting functions that makes the
visualization and Analysis of data
easier
so we'll cover some of the crucial plots
that are available in cball
so let's start with a bar plot
I'll give a
comment as
bar plot
now
first understand what a bar plot is so a
bar plot gives an estimate of the
central tendency of a numeric variable
with the height of each rectangle it
provides some indication of the
uncertainty around the estimate using
error bars now to build this plot you
usually choose a categorical column in
the x axis and a numeric column on the
y-axis
so
we'll create a bar plot between the
number of cylinders and the miles per
gallon
so let's start
I'll declare a variable called res which
essentially stands for result
then I'll use SNS
which is for the c bond Library
I'll say SNS Dot
followed by my bar plot function
and inside the function
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
and then
for x axis within the bracket using
quotation I'll give my column name
as cylinder so this is going to be my x
axis
and for y-axis I'll say
my data frame name empty cars
then the square bracket followed by my
y-axis column that is miles per gallon
now to display I'm going to use the
matplotally function I'll say PLT dot
show
let's run it and we'll see the result
there you go
so here you can see on the
x-axis we have the number of cylinders
so in our data we have vehicles with 4 6
or 8 cylinders and on the y-axis you can
see the miles per gallon
now what essentially this graph tells us
is that
when the number of cylinders in the
vehicle increases my miles per gallon
MPG for the vehicles decreases
and you can see these black lines so
these lines indicate the uncertainty
around the estimate using error bars
all right
now you can create the
same bar plot using another way
now we will exclusively Define the X and
Y axis columns and also pass the name of
the data frame using the data argument
let me show you how to do it
I'll use the same variable name res
which stands for result I'll say SNS Dot
bar plot
now inside the
bar plot function
I am going to exclusively Define my x
axis I'll say x equal to
I'll pass in my column as
cylinder
then I'll say y-axis
which is miles per gallon
and then using the data attribute
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars
and finally we'll write PLT dot show
let me run it
you see here we have the exact
same bar plot as the above one so this
is another way to create a bar plot now
python c bond allows the users to assign
colors to the bars
so the bar chart that we are going to
create will convert all the bars to a
particular color
so for that I am going to use the color
argument
so I'll say res equal to
sns. my function that is bar plot
I'll say X
equal to
cylinder
my y-axis
will have
MPG
and then I'll say data
is empty cars
give a comma and my final attribute I'll
say
color
equal to I'll say yellow
close the bracket
and then
I'm going to write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
all the bars have been converted to
yellow color now
you can change the color
argument let's say I'll make it to red
if I print it you can see here all the
bars have been changed to red color now
all right
now C bone Library also has the
palette argument
which you can use to give different
colors to the bars so if you go to
Google and search for
C bone palette
you have a nice link here
so here you have there are different
pallets provided by
c bond you can see here SNS dot color
palette and these are the
names of the palette
you can use whichever palette you want
all right
so
I'll say res equal to
sns.bar plot
we'll use our first method of
assigning
a bar plot so I'm using my data frame
empty cars and this time we are going to
change the accent y labels let's say I'm
using
my X label as
transmission whether
automatic or manual transmission
and then in my y-axis I'll have
miles per gallon
then
I'm going to say
palette
equal to
I made a spelling mistake here
let's say our palette is
set 2 this is the name of the palette
I'll write PLT dot show
if I run it you can see here
we have the
two modes of transmission zero is for
automatic transmission of the vehicle
one is for manual transmission and you
can see the miles per gallon for each of
the modes of transmission if you want
you can change the palette colors let me
just copy this
I'll paste it in my new cell
and instead of set to let's see we'll
use
another palette
called as Rocket
and I'm also going to alter
my X and Y labels let's see in my X
label I'll have gear
and my valuable will be horsepower
if I run it
you see here we now have a different
palette and the bars are of different
colors on the x-axis you have the gears
three gear 4 gear or five gear vehicle
and on the y-axis you have the
horsepower
so from the graph you can see
the horsepower is low for vehicles that
have four gears while it is high
for the vehicles that have five gears
now let's understand how to create a
count plot so the count plot function in
the python c-bond Library Returns the
count of total values for each category
using bars we will create a count plot
that Returns the total number of
vehicles for each category of cylinders
I'll just give a comment here as
count plot
all right
so I'll start
sns.
I'll use the account plot function
and I'll Define my x axis as
cylinders
my y-axis won't have any label or any
column because y-axis will only show the
count
then I am going to
use my
data parameter or the argument and pass
in my data frame name that is empty cars
all right
let's see I'll set the
palette
to
set one
let me run it
okay there is some error let's debug the
error
says Str object has no attribute get
okay so this should be
without the single quotes
make sure the data frame name is without
the single quotes let's run it again
there you go so you can see here this is
a nice count plot that shows the number
of cylinders on the x-axis and on the
y-axis you have the count you can see
here
there are more number of vehicles that
have 8 cylinders and there are
less number of vehicles or cars that
have six cylinders
and actually you can count it as well so
you can see here there are 14 cars that
have 8 cylinders there are 11 cars that
have four cylinders and there are seven
cars that have six cylinders
all right
now moving ahead
the next count plot will show the number
of cars for each carburetor
so for that I'm going to say
sns.
count plot
my x-axis will now have
the variable
carburetor
LC data equal to empty cars
and
my palette
I'll set it to
set 1.
let's say set two now let me run it
you can see it here
on the x axis we have the different
number of carburetors one two three four
six and eight and you can see we have
more number of cars that have two and
four carburetors and there are very few
vehicles that have
six and eight carburetor
cool now moving ahead
so the python c bond Library allows you
to create horizontal count plots where
the feature column is on the y-axis and
the count is on the x axis let me show
you how to create a horizontal count
plot
I'll say SNS Dot
count plot
I'm going to Define my y label or the
y-axis as
gear
I'll say data equal to
empty cars and
set my
palette to
let's say rocket
let me run it
okay you see here this is a
horizontal count plot if you compare it
with the above one these were all
vertical
count plot as in the bars where
vertically aligned but here you can see
the bars are all horizontally aligned
and
on the y-axis you have the gear column
and on the x axis you have the count
so if you Mark here properly you can see
there are 15 vehicles with three gears
there are 12 vehicles that have 4 gears
and there are total five vehicles with 5
gear
now you can also create a grouped count
plot using the Hue parameter so the Hue
parameter accepts the column name for
color encoding
now let's build a count plot that shows
the number of cars for each category of
Gears grouped by
the number of cylinders
so we are going to group based on the
number of cylinders let me show you how
to use the Hue parameter for that
I'll say
sns.con plot
in the x axis I'll have my
gear column
then I am going to pass my Hue parameter
that will have the cylinder column or
the number of cylinders for each vehicle
I'll pass my data frame using the data
argument
as empty cars and say pallet
I'll set my palette to set one
let's run it
if I scroll down you see here we have
account plot
on the x axis you have three four and
five gears of the different vehicles and
for each gear you have the bars that
represent the number of cylinders so for
vehicles that have three gears we have
majority of the vehicles Having Eight
cylinders
similarly for vehicles that have four
gears we have most of the vehicles with
four cylinders
and if you compare for the
cars that have five gears
so we have equal number of vehicles that
have
four and eight cylinders and then
we have
one vehicle that has
six cylinders
cool now moving ahead
so the c bond Library supports the dist
plot function that creates the
distribution of any continuous data
let's create the distribution of miles
per gallon of the different vehicles or
the cars
the mpg Matrix measures the total
distance the car can travel per gallon
of fuel so here I'll give
a comment as dist plot which stands for
distribution plot
I'll say SNS Dot
dist plot
I'll pass in my
data frame name that is empty cars
give a period and say
MPG which is my column name
then I am going to
Define the number of bins that I want
let's say 10
and then I'll use the
color argument
and I'll say let's say G which is for
green
let's run it now
there you go
if I scroll down you can see we have a
nice
distribution plot so these are all
histograms and
you can see we have a smooth curve
and this shows the distribution of
miles per gallon that is present in our
data set all right now moving ahead
you can also create heat Maps using the
seabon library
so the heat Maps will let you visualize
Matrix like data
the values of the variables are
contained in a matrix and are
represented as colors
you can create a correlation heat map
which is a graphical representation of a
correlation Matrix representing the
correlation between different variables
so in our example we will create a heat
map where you can find the correlation
between each variable in the empty cars
data set
just give a comment as heat map
I'll say SNS and
I'll use the heat map function
I'll pass in my data frame name that is
empty cars followed by
function called
Corr which is for correlation
then I'll say c bar
is equal to true
so the
c bar argument is used to draw the color
bar
then I'll see
line widths
I'll
pass it as 0.5
let's run it
there you go here you can see we have a
nice heat map and on the right side you
can see the color bar that starts from
minus 0.8 and goes up to plus 0.8 so
this ranges between
-1 and plus one
and
the bars or the cube you can see that
have
a lighter color have a positive
correlation
and the ones that are
dark have a negative correlation
so for example
you can see here
for cylinder and MPG
the color is really dark which is around
this region minus 0.8 this means
when the number of cylinders in the car
increases your miles per gallon
decreases and this
we also had seen in our first
bar plot this one you can see here
whenever
the number of cylinders increased your
miles per gallon had decreased
and this is what has been depicted
in our correlation map or the heat map
but if you see for
cylinder and displacement there is a
positive correlation
which comes around this
color bar range
similarly there are other features in
the data set for example if you compare
for the weight of the vehicle and
the number of cylinders
there is a positive correlation which
means when the
weight of the vehicle increases the
number of cylinders present in the
vehicle also increases
and the others you can also compare and
find out the correlation based on this
color bar choose from over 300 in demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit scale up
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more okay now let's
move ahead
C bone scatter plot function helps you
create plots that can draw relationships
between two continuous variables so to
understand about Scatter Plots and other
plotting functions
henceforth we are going to use
Iris plot data set so let's go ahead and
load the iris flight data set I'll say
Irish
equal to so SNS Dot
load underscore
data set
so this is our dataset is already
inbuilt into the SNS or the c-bond
library
now we'll go ahead and
print the first five rows from the data
set
there you go
here you can see here
there are total
four feature variables you have the
Supple length Supple width petal length
and petal width of the three species of
flower
that is satosha
Virginia and versicolor
so using this data set we are going to
see the rest of the c bond plotting
functions first let me go ahead and
print the different pieces of flour and
the count for each of the species of
flowers that we have in our data set
I'll say Irish
within square brackets I'll pass in the
e
output or the target variable that is
PCS and I'll use the function that is
value underscore counts
let's run it there you go so we have
50 flowers of setosa type
again 50 plus of versicolor species and
then
we have another 50 flowers of type
virginica so there are total 150 flowers
present in our data set
all right
I will create a scatter plot to show the
relationship between Supple length and
petal length for different species of
Iris Plus
so I'll say SNS Dot
followed by the
scatter plot function in the x axis I'll
say
Supple length
column
give a comma
I'll pass in my
y-axis with
petal length
then I'll say
data
equal to Iris
now let's run it
you can see here
this is my scatter plot between Supple
length and petal length
now you can classify the different
species of flowers using the Hue
parameter as species in the function
so what I'll do is
I'm going to copy my
above
code I just paste it here
and we are going to edit in this cell
itself
I'll add a last parameter called hue
and this will have my species column
let's run it and see the difference
there you go here you can see
we have a nice scatter plot
the blue dots are for satosha the orange
dots are for 4C color and for Virginia
you have the green dots
from this scatter plot you can see that
for virginica flowers the Supple length
and the petal length are higher than
your vertical around
satosha
and this region is completely for
satosha flask so you can see that the
settings of laws have
lower Supple length and better length
all right
you can also
use another
parameter known as the size
that will differentiate
the different species of flower in terms
of the size of the dots
I'll say size as PCS
let's run it you can see the result
there you go
so here you can see the
virginica
flowers are in green dots
the size is small
followed by versicolor with medium sized
dots and then we have satosha whose
sizes
large okay now the python c bond Library
lets you visualize data using pair plots
that produces a matrix of relationship
between each variable in the data set
so let me show you how to create a peer
plot I'll say SNS Dot
peer plot which is the function
then I'll pass in my data frame name
that is Iris
I'll put this
Iris data frame Within
double quotes
and we'll run it
okay there is some error here let's
debug the error
data must be pandas data frame okay
what I'll do is I'll just remove
the double quotes and we'll run it
this might take some time to create the
pair plot so just wait for a while there
you go
here you can see we have a nice pair
plot
on the
y-axis you have the
Supple length Supple width petal length
and petal width similarly on the x axis
also you have the same feature columns
all the diagonal plots are histograms
and the rest of the plots are
Scatter Plots
you can convert the diagonal visuals to
KDE or kernel density estimation plots
and the rest of the Scatter Plots using
the Hue parameter this makes the paired
plot easier to classify each type of
flower
so
I'll just copy this
cell of code
paste it here
and
I'll say hue
equal to
species then
I'll say
palette
equal to
set one
let's run it and we'll
see the new pair plot now
this might take some time
there you go
so here you have the pair plot ready
and on the
right side you can see the difference
PCS the red color dots represent satosha
flowers the blue color dots represent
versicolor
and the green color
dots represent virginica flowers
now if you
look at this graph you will find that
your petal length is the best feature to
classify the three different species of
flowers the reason being you can see
here
they are very well categorized and they
are separated
all the red dots present here in The
Petal length represents atosa flowers
around this range
all the blue dots represent
versicolor flowers and the green dots
are all
virginica flowers so out of the four
features petal width petal length Supple
width and supple length
you can take
petal length as the best feature to
differentiate between the three species
of flowers
all right now
coming to LM plot function so the LM
plot function in the c bond Library
draws a linear relationship as
determined through regression for
continuous variables
so let's create the plot to show the
relationship between petal length and
petal width of the different species of
Iris flowers
I'll just give a comment here as
LM plot
I'll say SNS Dot
in the x-axis we'll have
petal length
give a comma
in the y-axis
all right I'll pass in
petal width
and I'll pass in my data frame using the
data argument or parameter which is Iris
let's run it
you can see it here
we have a nice
plot
the line you see here is a linear
regression line
now in this LM plot you can use the Hue
parameter to differentiate between each
species of flowers and you can set
markers
for different species let me show you
how to do it
I'll say SNS Dot
LM plot
we'll say X
as our
petal length
give a comma
I'll write y
as
petrol
width
then I am going to pass the Hue
parameter
in Hue I'll see
my column as PCS
then I'll give data equal to
my data set name that is Iris and now
you can pass in
markers argument
to differentiate the different
types of flaws let's say I want to
represent satosha with
dot or o
then my next species which is versicolor
should be represented with a
star symbol
and the final
virginica species of flowers should be
represented with let's say this Arrow
mark
now let me go ahead and run it
there you go
you have three different
linear regression lines
and the circle dots in blue color
represent satosha
the orange color stars represent
versicolor flowers and
the triangles represent virginica
flowers so this is how you create
a linear relationship between the
different
types of flowers using the regression
line all right now let's
take a look at the final plotting
function
where we will create a box plot
a box plot also known as a box and
whisker plot depicts the distribution of
quantitative data the Box represents the
quartiles of the data set
the whiskers so the rest of the
distribution except for the outliers
now let's see the distribution of the
three species of flowers
based on their Supple width
I'll just give a comment as box plot
is the final plot that we are going to
see in our c bond
demo
I'll say sns.box plot
in the x axis we'll have the species
column
in the y-axis will have
supple
width
then I'll pass my data
as Iris
let's run it
there you go
we have this box plot created
at the bottom in the x-axis you can see
we have
the box plot for
Sentosa flowers
orange for vertical flowers and green
for Virginia flowers
now this line represents
median which is inside the Box
so this is also the median for vertical
of loss you can compare the
median sepal width for each of the
flowers from the y axis
this line represents the
maximum
Supple width value for satosha flower
and this line at the bottom represents
the minimum
length of the Supple with four cetusa
plus
now these dots that you see outside the
box plot are called as outliers
the extended lines that are outside the
box plot are known as whiskers
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
seabon library in Python so first we
imported our empty cars dataset
then we saw how to create a bar plot
we learned how to use the color argument
or the parameter inside bar plot
we also saw how to use the palette
attribute or the palette
parameter
then we learned about
creating count plots then we saw how to
create horizontal count plot
now moving ahead
we saw how to create distribution plot
then we saw
correlation heat map
after that we analyzed the other
functions
such as this scatter plot
then we had the paired plot
and we had the
LM plot for
finding the linear relationship and
later we saw the
box plot using the iris plot data set so
let's start with deep learning
Frameworks to start with this chart
doesn't even do the filled Justice
because it's just exploded these are
just some of the major Frameworks out
there there's uh Karas which happens to
sit on tensorflow so they're very
integrated there's tensorflow Pi torches
out there Cafe piano DL for J and
chainer these are just a few of the deep
learning Frameworks we're talking about
neural networks if you're just starting
out never seen a neural network you can
go into python in the PSI kit and do the
neural network in there which is
probably the most simplest version I
know but the real most robust version
out there the most top of the latter as
far as the technology right now is
tensorflow and that of course is
changing from day to day and some of
these are better for different purposes
so let's dive into tensorflow let's see
what is tensorflow what is tensorflow
tensorflow is a popular open source
Library released in 2015 by Google brain
team for building machine learning and
deep learning models it is based on
Python programming language and performs
numerical computations using data flow
graphs to build models so let's take a
look at some of the features of
tensorflow it works efficiently with
multi-dimensional arrays if you've ever
played with any of the simpler packages
of neural networks you're going to find
that you have to pretty much flatten
them and make sure your your stuff is
set in a flat model tensorflow works
really good so we're talking pictures
here where you have X and Y coordinates
where the picture is and then each pixel
has three or four different channels
that's a very complicated array very
multimensional array it provides
scalability of computation across
machines and large data sets this is so
new right now and you might think that's
a minor thing but when python is
operating on one computer and it has a
float value and it truncates it
differently on each computer you don't
get the same results and so your
training model might work on one machine
and then on another it doesn't this is
one of the things that tensorflow
addresses and does a very well good job
on it supports fast debugging and model
building this is why I love tensorflow I
can go in there and I can build a model
with different layers each layer might
have different properties they have like
the convolutional neural network which
you can then sit on top of a regular
neural network with reverse propagation
there's a lot of tools in here and a lot
of options and each layer
that it goes through can utilize those
different options and stack differently
and it has a large community and
provides tensorboard to visualize the
model tensorboard is pretty uh recent
but it's a really nice tool to have so
you when you're working with other
people or showing your clients or the
shareholders in the company you can give
them a nice visual model so they know
what's going on what are they paying for
and let's take a glance at some of the
different uses or applications for
tensorflow when we talk about tensorflow
applications
clearly this is data analytics we're
getting into the data science I like to
use data science as probably a better
term because this is the programming
side
uh and it's really the sky is a limit
um we can look at face detection
language translation fraud detection
video detection there are so many
different things out there that
tensorflow can be used for when you
think of neural networks because
tensorflow is a neural network
think of complicated chaotic data this
is very different than if you have a set
numbers like you're looking at the stock
market you can use this on the stock
market but if you're doing something
where the numbers are very clear and not
so chaotic as you have in a picture then
you're talking more about linear
regression models and different
regression models when you're looking at
that when you're talking about these
really complicated data patterns then
you're talking neural networks and
tensorflow and if we're going to talk
about tensorflow we should talk about
what tensors are after all that is what
tensor that's what this is named after
so we talk about tensors in tensorflow
tensorflow is derived from its core
component known as a tensor a 10 answer
is a vector or a matrix of n Dimensions
that represent all types of data and you
can see here we have the scalar which is
just a single number you have your
vector which is two numbers might be a
number in a direction you have a simple
Matrix and then we get into the tensor I
mentioned how a picture is a very
complicated tensor because it has your X
Y coordinates and then each one of those
pixels has three to four channels for
your different colors and so each image
coming in would be its own tensor and in
tensorflow tensors are defined by a unit
of dimensionality called as rank
and you can see here we have our scalar
which is a single number that has a rank
of zero because it has no real
Dimensions to it other than it's just a
single point and then you have your
vector which would be a single list of
numbers
so it's a rank one Matrix would have
rank two and then as you can see right
here as we get into the full tensor it
has a rank three
and so the next step is to understand
how a tensorflow works and if you
haven't looked at the basics of a neural
network in Reverse propagation that is
the basics of tensorflow and then it
goes through a lot of different options
and properties that you can build into
your different tensors so a tensorflow
performs computations with the help of
data flow graphs it has nodes that
represent the operations in your model
and if you look at this you should see a
neural network going on here we have our
inputs b c and d and you might have x
equals B plus c y equals D minus four a
equals x times Y and then you have an
output and so even though this isn't a
neural network here it's just a simple
set of computations going across you can
see how the more complicated it gets the
more it can actually one of the tensors
is a neural network with reverse
propagation but it's not limited to that
there's so much more you can do with it
and this here is just a basic uh flow of
computations of the data going across
and you can see we can plug in the
numbers uh b equals force equals three D
equals six and you get x equals four
plus three so x equals seven y equals
six minus four so y equals two and
finally a equals 7 times 2 or a equals
fourteen like I said this is a very
simplified version of how tensorflow
Works each one of these layers can get
very complicated
um but tensorflow does such a nice job
that you can spend different setups up
very easily and test them out so you can
test out these different models to see
how they work now tensorflow has gone
through two major stages we had the
original tensorflow release of 1.0 and
then they came out with the 2.0 version
and the 2.0 addressed so many things out
there that the 1.0 really needed so when
we start talking about tensorflow 1.0
versus 2.0 I guess you would need to
know this for a legacy programming job
if you're pulling apart somebody else's
code the first thing is that tensorflow
2.0 supports eager execution by default
it allows you to build your models and
run them instantly and you can see here
from tensorflow 1 to tensorflow 2. we
have almost double the code to do the
same thing so if I want to do with
tf.session or tensorflow session as a
session the session run you have your
variables your session run you have your
tables initialized and then you do your
model fit X train y train and then your
validation data your x value y value and
your epics and your batch size all that
goes into the fit and you can see here
where that was all just compressed to
make it run easier you can just create a
model and do a fit on it and you only
have like that last set of code on there
so it's automatic that's what they mean
by the eager so if you see the first
part you're like what the heck is all
this session thing going on that's
tensorflow 1.0 and then when you get
into 2.0 it's just nice and clean if you
remember from the beginning I said cross
on our list up there
and crosses the high level API in
tensorflow 2.0 cross is the official
high level API of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated across as tf.cross cross
provides a number of model building apis
such as sequential functional and
subclassing so you can choose a right
level of abstraction for your project
and uh we'll hopefully touch base a
little bit more on this sequential being
the most common form that is your your
layers are going from one side to the
other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional
is where you can split the layers so you
might have your input coming on one side
it splits into two completely mod
different models and then they come back
together and one of them might be doing
classification the other one might be
doing just linear regression kind of
stuff or neural basic reverse
propagation neural network and then
those all come together into another
layer which is your neural network
reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into cross
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently in the tensorflow cross setup
a third big change we're going to look
at is it in tensorflow 1.0
in order to use TF layers as variables
you would have to write TF variable
block so you'd have to pre-define that
in tensorflow 2 you just add your layers
in under the sequential and it
automatically defines them as long as
they're flat layers of course this
changes a little bit as a more
complicated tensor you have coming in
but all of it's very easy to do and
that's what 2.0 does a really good job
of and here we have a little bit more on
the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow 1 asks you to do these
different layers and values if you look
at the scope and the default name you
start looking at all the different code
in there to create the variable scope
that's not even necessary until sensor
2.0 so you'd have to do one before you
do do what you see the code in 2.0 in
2.0 you just create your model it's a
sequential model and then you can add
all your layers in you don't have to
pre-create the um
variable scope so if you ever see the
variable scope you know that came from
an older version and then we have the
last two which is our API cleanup and
the autograph in the API cleanup
tensorflow one you could build models
using TF Gans TF app TF contrib TF Flags
Etc and tensorflow 2 a lot of apis have
been removed and this is just they just
clean them up because people weren't
using them and they've simplified them
and that's your TF app your TF Flags
your TF logging are all gone
so there's those are three Legacy
features that are not in 2.0 and then we
have our TF function and autograph
feature in the old version tensorflow
1-0 the python functions were limited
and could not be compiled or exported
re-imported so you were continually
having to redo your code and you
couldn't very easily just put a pointer
to it and say hey let's reuse this
in tensorflow 2 you can write a python
function using the TF function to mark
it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph feature of TF
function helps to write graph code using
natural python syntax
now we just threw in a new word in you
graph graph is not a picture of a person
you'll hear graph x and some other
things graph is what are all those lines
that are connecting different objects so
if you remember from before where we had
the different layers going through
sequentially each one of those white
lined arrows would be a graph x that's
where that computation is taken care of
and that's what they're talking about
and so if you had your own special code
or python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using in
neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic Tools in
tensorflow before we roll up our sleeves
and dive into the example so let's just
take a quick look at tensorflow toolkits
in their hierarchy at the high level we
have our object oriented API so this is
what you're working with you have your
TF cross you have your estimators this
sits on top of your TF layers TF losses
TF metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tensorflow shines is
between the cross running your
estimators and then being able to swap
in different layers you can your losses
your metrics all of that is so built
into tensorflow makes it really easy to
use and then you can get down to your
low level TF API you have extensive
control over this you can put your own
formulas in there your own procedures or
models in there you could have it split
we talked about that earlier so with the
2.0 you can now have it split One
Direction where you do a linear
regression model and then go to the
other where it does a neural network and
maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it and then
it comes together into another layer
which is another neural network so you
can build these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around and most recently we have the TF
code can run on multiple platforms and
so you have your CPU which is basically
like on the computer I'm running on I
have eight cores and 16 dedicated
threads I hear they now have one out
there that has over a hundred cores
uh so you have your CPU running and then
you have your GPU which is your graphics
card
and most recently they also include the
TPU setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models uh neural network kind
of setup so now you can export the TF
code and it can run on all kinds of
different platforms for the most
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture we
have you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and
eighty percent of your time in data
science is spent pre-processing data
making sure it's loaded correctly and
everything looks right so the first
level in tensorflow is going to be your
read and pre-processed data your TF data
feature columns
this is going to feed into your TF Cross
or your pre-made estimators and kind of
you have your tensorflow Hub that sits
on top of there so you can see what's
going on uh once you have all that set
up you have your distribution strategy
where are you going to run it are you
going to be running it on just your
regular CPU are you going to be running
it with the GPU added in like I have a
pretty high-end graphics card so it
actually grabs that GPU processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized TPU
set up in there that you paid extra
money for it could be if you're in later
on when you're Distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for let's
say net you might be processing this at
a distribute you're Distributing it not
the distribution strategy but you're
Distributing it into a server where that
server might be analyzing thousands and
thousands of purchases done every minute
and so you need that higher speed to
give them a to give them a
recommendation or a suggestion so they
can buy more stuff off your website or
maybe you're looking for a data fraud
analysis working with the banks you want
to be able to run this at a high speed
so that when you have hundreds of people
sending their transactions in it says
hey this doesn't look right someone's
scamming this person probably has a
credit card so when we're talking about
all those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is we were talking
about that earlier where it used to be
when you did one of these models it
wouldn't truncate the float numbers the
same and so a model going from one you
build the model on your machine in the
office and then you need to distribute
it and so we have our tensorflow serving
Cloud on premium that's what I was
talking about if you're like a banking
or something like that now they have
tensorflow Lite so you can actually run
it tensorflow on an Android or an iOS or
Raspberry Pi a little breakout board
there in fact they just came out with a
new one that has a built-in is this many
TPU with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that talking about
an affordable way to beta test a new
product you have the tensorflow JS which
is for browser and node server so you
can get that out on the browser for some
simple computations that don't require a
lot of heavy lifting but you want to
distribute to a lot of endpoints and now
they also have other language bindings
so you can now create your tensorflow
back in save it and have it accessed
from C Java go c-sharp rust r or from
whatever package you're working on so we
kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going on behind
the scenes and in this case what's going
on as far as Distributing it let's go
ahead and take a look at three specific
pieces of tensorflow
and those are going to be constants
variables and sessions so very basic
things you need to know and understand
when you're working with the tensorflow
setup so constants in tensorflow in
tensorflow constants are created using
the function constant in other words
they're going to stay static the whole
time whatever you're working with the
Syntax for constant value d-type 9 shape
equals none name constant verify shape
equals false that's kind of the syntax
you're looking at and we'll explore this
with our hands on a little more in depth
and you can see here we do Z equals
tf.constant 5.2 name equals x d type is
a float that means that we're never
going to change that 5.2 it's going to
be a constant value and then we have our
variables in tensorflow variables in
tensorflow are in memory buffers that
store tensors and so we can declare a
two by three tensor populated by ones
you could also do constants this way by
the ways you can create a an array of
ones for your constant in here we have V
equals TF dot variables
and then in tensorflow you have tf.1s
and you have the shape which is 2 3
which is then going to create a nice two
by three array that's filled with ones
and then of course you can go in there
in their variables so you can change
them it's a tensor so you have full
control over that and then you of course
have uh sessions in tensorflow a session
in tensorflow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes and remember when we're talking a
graph or graph x we're talking about all
that information then goes through all
those arrows and whatever computations
they have they take it to the next node
and you can see down here where we have
import tensorflow as TF if we do x
equals a TF dot constant of 10 we do y
equals a TF constant of 2.0 or 20.0 and
then you can do Z equals TF dot variable
and it's a TF dot add X comma y
and then once you have that set up in
there you go ahead and knit your TF
Global variables initializer with TF
session as session you can do a session
run knit and then you print the session
run y
uh and so when you run this you're going
to end up with of course the 10 plus 20
is 30. and we'll be looking at this a
lot more closely as we actually roll up
our sleeves and put some code together
so let's go ahead and take a look at
that and for my coding today I'm going
to go ahead and go through anaconda and
then I'll use specifically the Jupiter
Notebook on there and of course this
code is going to work uh whatever
platform you choose whether you're in a
notebook the Jupiter lab which is just a
Jupiter notebook but with tabs for
larger projects we're going to stick
with jupyter notebook pie charm whatever
it is you're going to use in here you
have your spider and your QT console for
different programming environments the
thing to note is kind of hard to see but
I have my main Pi 36 right now when I
was writing this tensorflow works in
Python version 3 6. if you have python
version 3 7 or 3 8 you're probably going
to get some errors in there might be
that they've already updated it and I
don't know it now you have an older
version
but you want to make sure you're in a
python version 3 6 in your environment
and of course in Anaconda I can easily
set that environment up make sure you go
ahead and and pip in your tensorflow or
if you're in Anaconda you can do a conda
install tensorflow to make sure it's in
your package so let's just go ahead and
dive in and bring that up
this will open up a nice browser window
I just love the fact I can zoom in and
zoom out depending on what I'm working
on making it really easy to adjust a
demo for the right size go under new and
let's go ahead and create a new Python
and once we're in our new python window
this is going to leave it Untitled let's
go ahead and import import tensorflow as
TF at this point we'll go ahead and just
run it real quick no errors yay no
errors I
I do that whenever I do my imports
because I unbearably will have opened up
a new environment and forgotten to
install tensorflow into that environment
or something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
and if we're going to double check that
we also it's also good to know what
version we're working with and we can do
that simply by using the version command
and tensorflow
which you should know is is probably
intuitively the TF
dot underscore underscore version
underscore underscore
and you know it always confuses me
because sometimes you do tf.version for
one thing you do TF dot underscore
version underscore for another thing uh
this is a double underscore in
tensorflow for pulling your version out
and it's good to know what you're
working with we're going to be working
in tensorflow version 2.1.0 and I did
tell you the the um we were going to dig
a little deeper into our constants and
you can do an array of constants and
we'll just create this nice array a
equals tf.constant and we're just going
to put the array right in there four
three six one we can run this and now
that is what a is equal to and if we
want to just double check that remember
we're in Jupiter notebook where you can
just put the letter a and it knows that
that's going to be print otherwise you'd
run you'd surround it in print and you
can see it's a TF tensor it has the
shape the type and the and the array on
here it's a two by two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
ahead and create a variable and this is
also going to be a two by two array and
if we go ahead and print the V out we'll
run that and sure enough there's our TF
variable in here
then we can also let's just go back up
here and add this in here I could create
another tensor and we'll make it a
constant this time
and we'll go and put that in over here
we'll have b t f constant and if we go
and print out V and B I'm going to run
that and this is an interesting thing
that always that happens in here you'll
see right here when I print them both
out what happens is it only prints the
last one unless you use print commands
so important to remember that in jupyter
notebooks we can easily fix that by go
ahead and print and Surround V with
brackets and now we can see with the two
different variables we have we have the
three one five two which is a variable
and this is just a flat constant so it
comes up as a TF tensor shape two kind
of two and that's interesting to note
that this label is a tf.tensor and this
is a TF variable
so that's how it's looking in the back
end when you're talking about the
difference between a variable and a
constant
the other thing I want you to notice is
that in variable we capitalize the V and
with the constant we have a lowercase C
little things like that can lose you
when you're programming and you're
trying to find out hey why doesn't this
work so those are a couple little things
to note in here and just like any other
array in math we can do like a
concatenate or concatenate the different
values here and you can see we can take
a b concatenated you just do a tf.concat
values and there's our a b axes on one
hopefully you're familiar with axes and
how that works when you're dealing with
matrixes and if we go ahead and print
this out you'll see right here we end up
with a tensor so let's put it in as a
constant nut as a variable
and you have your array 4378 and 6145 is
concatenated the two together and
a couple things on this our axes equals
one this means we're doing the columns
so if you had a longer array like right
now we have an array that is like you
know has a shape one whatever it is two
comma two
axes zero
is going to be your first one and axes
one is going to be your second one and
it translates as columns and rows if we
had a shape let me just put the word
shape here
um
so you know what I'm talking about it's
very clear and this is I'll tell you
what I spend a lot of time
looking at these shapes and trying to
figure out which direction I'm going in
and whether to flip it or whatever
so you can get lost in which way your
Matrix is going which is column which is
rows are you dealing with the third axes
or the second axis axis one you know
zero one two that's going to be our
columns and if you can do columns then
we also can do rows and that is simply
just changing the concatenate we'll just
grab this one here and copy it we'll do
the whole thing over
um control copy
Ctrl V and changes from axis one
to axis zero and if we run that you'll
see that now we concatenate by a row as
opposed to column
and you have four three six one seven
eight four seven so it just brings it
right down and turns it into rows versus
columns you can see the difference there
your output this really you want to look
at the output sometimes just to make
sure your eyes are looking at it
correctly and it's in the format I find
visually looking at it is almost more
important than understanding what's
going on because conceptually your mind
just just too many dimensions sometimes
the second thing I want you to notice is
this says a numpy array so tensorflow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as Python's concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array because it is just that
it's going to be a numpy array another
thing that comes up uh more than you
would think is filling uh one of these
with zeros or ones and so you can see
here we just created tensor tf.zeros
and we give it a shape we tell it what
kind of data type it is in this case
we're doing an integer and then if we
print out our tensor again we're in
Jupiter so I can just type out tensor
and I run this you can see I have a nice
array of with shape three comma four of
zeros one of the things I want to
highlight here is integer 32. if I go to
the tensorflow data types I want you to
notice how we have float 16 float 32
float64 complex if we scroll down you'll
see the integer down here 32. the reason
for this is that we want to control how
many bits are used in the Precision
this is for exporting it to another
platform so what would happen is I might
run it on this computer where python
goes does a float to indefinite however
long it wants to and then we can take it
but we want to actually say hey we don't
want that high Precision we want to be
able to run this on any computer and so
we need to control whether it's a TF
float16 in this case we did an integer
32.
we could also do this as a float so if I
run this as a float32 that means this
has a 32-bit Precision you'll see Zero
Point whatever and then to go with zeros
we have ones if we're going from the
opposite side and so we can easily just
create a tensorflow with ones
and you might ask yourself why would I
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor usually we initiate a lot of this
stuff with random numbers because it
does a better job solving it if you
start with a uniform set of ones or
zeros you're dealing with a lot of bias
so be very careful about starting a
neural network for one of your rows or
something like that with ones and zeros
on the other hand I use this for masking
you can do a lot of work with masking
you can also have it might be that one
tenth a row is massed you know zero is
is false one is true or whatever you
want to do it
and so in that case you do want to use
the zeros and ones and there are cases
where you do want to initialize it with
all zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as a as the tensor
learns so it's another form of control
but in general you see zeros and ones
you usually are talking about a mask
over another array and just like in
numpy you can also do reshapes so if we
take our remember this is shaped three
comma four maybe we want to swap that to
four comma three
and if we print this out
you will see let me just go and do that
control V let me run that and you'll see
that the the order of these is now
switched instead of four across now we
have three across and four down
and just for fun let's go back up here
where we did the ones and I'm going to
change the ones to TF dot random uniform
uh and we'll go ahead and just take off
well we'll go and leave that we're going
to run this
and you'll see now we have 0.0441 and
this way you can actually see how the
reshape looks a lot different uh
0.041.15.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the 0.14
and this is what I was talking about
sometimes you feel a lot of times you
fill these with random numbers and so
this is the random.uniform is one of the
ways to do that now I just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types one of the things that
comes up of course is recasting your
data
um so if we have a d-type float32 we
might want to convert these two integers
because of the project we're working on
I know one of the projects I've worked
on ended up wanting to do a lot of round
off so that it would take a dollar
amount or a float value and then have to
run it off to a dollar amount so we only
wanted two decimal points
um and in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot of or then
convert it to an integer was one way to
round it off kind of
the cheap and dirty trick
so we can take this we can take the same
tensor and we'll go ahead and create a
as an integer and so we're going to take
this tensor we're going to tf.cast it
and if we print
tensor and then we're going to go ahead
and print
our
tensor
let me just do a quick copy and paste
and when I'm actually programming I
usually type out a lot of my stuff just
to double check it in doing a demo copy
and paste works fine but sometimes be
aware that copy and paste can copy the
wrong code over personal choice depends
on what I'm working on
and you can see here we took a float32
4.6 4.2 and so on and it just converts
it right down to a integer value
sorry integer 32 setup and uh remember
we talked about a little bit about
reshape
as far as flipping it and I just did
four comma 3 on the reshape up here and
we talked about axis 0 axis one one of
the things that is important to be able
to do is to take one of these variables
we'll just take this last one tensor as
integer
and I want to go ahead and transpose it
and so I can do we'll do a
equals TF dot transpose
and we'll do our tensor integer in there
and then if I print the A out and we run
this
you'll see it's the same array but we've
flipped it so that our columns and rows
are flipped this is the same as
reshaping so when you transpose you're
just doing a reshape what's nice about
this is if you look at the numbers The
Columns when we went up here and we did
the reshape they kind of rolled down to
the next row so you're not maintaining
the structure of your Matrix so when we
do a reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a transform
uh so when we come down here it's all
done for you and so there are so many
times you have to transpose your digits
that this is important to know that you
can just do that you can flip your rows
and columns rather quickly here and just
like numpy you can also do multiple your
different math functions we'll look at
multiplication and so we're going to
take matrix multiplication of tensors
we'll go ahead and create a as a
constant 5839 and we'll put in a vector
v 4 comma 2. and we could have done this
where they matched where this was a two
by two array but instead we're going to
do just a two by one array and the code
for that is your TF dot mat mole so
Matrix multiplier and we have a times V
and if we go ahead and run this up let's
make sure we print out our av on there
and if we go ahead and run this
you'll see that we end up with 36 by 30.
and if it's been a while since you've
seen The Matrix math this is five times
four plus eight times two
three times four plus nine times two
and that's where we get the 36 and 30.
now I know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality
so the Matrix or your Matrix multiplier
is a very commonly used back-end tool as
far as Computing
um different models or linear regression
stuff like that one of the things
is to note is that just like in numpy
you have all of your different math so
we have our TF math
and if we go in here we have functions
we have our cosines absolute angle all
of that's in here so all of these are
available for you to use in the
tensorflow model
and if we go back to our example and
let's go ahead and pull oh let's do some
multiplication that's always good we'll
stick with our av our
constant a and our vector v
and we'll go ahead and do some bitwise
multiplication and we'll create an AV
which is a times V let's go and print
that out
and you can see coming across here we
have the 4 2 and the 5839 and it
produces 20 32 618
and that's pretty straightforward if you
look at it you have four times five is
twenty four times eight is uh 32 that's
where those numbers come from
we can also quickly create an identity
Matrix
which is basically your main values on
the diagonal being ones and zeros across
the other side let's go ahead and take a
look and see what that uh
looks like we can do let's do this uh
so we're going to get the shape this is
a simple way very similar to your numpy
you can do a DOT shape and it's going to
return a tuple in this case our rows and
columns and so we can do a quick print
we'll do rows oops
and we'll do columns
and if we run this you can see we have
three rows two columns
and then if we go ahead and create an
identity Matrix
the scripts
the script for that hit a wrong button
there the script for that looks like
this
where we have the number of rows equals
rows the number of columns equals
columns and D type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity
you can see we have a nice identity
column with our ones going across here
now clearly we're not going to go
through every math module available but
we do want to start looking at this as a
prediction model and seeing how it
functions so we're going to move on to a
more of a
direct setup where you can actually see
the full tensorflow in use for that
let's go back and create a new setup
and we'll go in here new Python 3 module
there we go
bring this out so it takes up the whole
window because I like to do that
hopefully it made it through that first
part and you have a basic understanding
of tensorflow as far as being a series
of numpy arrays you got your math
equations and different things that go
into them we're going to start building
a full
set up as far as the numpy so you can
see how Karo sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works the
first thing you want to do is we're
going to go ahead and do a lot of
imports date times warning SCI Pi SCI Pi
is your
maths or the back end scientific math
warnings because whenever we do a lot of
this you have older versions newer
versions and so sometimes when you get
warnings you want to go ahead and just
suppress them we'll talk about that if
it comes up on this particular setup and
of course date time
pandas again is your data frame think
rows and columns we import it as PD
numpy is your numbers array which of
course tensorflow is integrated heavily
with Seaborn for our graphics and the
Seaborn as SNS is going to be set on top
of our matplot library which we import
as MPL and then of course we're going to
import our matplot library pipelot as
PLT and right off the bat we're going to
set some graphic colors patch Force Edge
color equals true the style we're going
to use the 538 style you can look this
all up there's when you get into matplot
Library into Seabourn there are so many
options in here it's just kind of nice
to make it look pretty when we start the
when we start up that way we don't have
to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take and we
have our mplrc we're going to put a
patch Ed color dim Gray Line with again
this is all part of our Graphics here in
our setup we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell node interactivity
equals last expression uh here we are PD
for pandas options display Max columns
so we don't want to display more than
50. and then our matplot library is
going to be inline this is a Jupiter
notebook thing the matplot library
inline then warnings we're going to
filter our warnings and we're just going
to ignore warnings that way when they
come up we don't have to worry about
them not really what you want to do when
you're working on a major project you
want to make sure you know those
warnings and then
filter them out and ignore them later on
and if we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background
so that's a little back end kind of
stuff then we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import our
specific packages that we're going to be
working with which is under Karas now
remember cross kind of sits on
tensorflow so when we're importing cross
and the sequential model we are in
effect importing tensorflow underneath
of it we just brought in the math
probably should have put that up above
and then we have our cross models we're
going to import sequential now if you
remember from our slide there was three
different options let me just flip back
over there so we can have a quick recall
on that and so in Cross we have
sequential functional and subclassing so
remember those three different setups in
here we talked about earlier and if you
remember from here we have a sequential
where it's going one tensorflow layer at
a time you go kind of look at think of
it as going from left to right or top to
bottom or whatever Direction it's going
in but it goes in One Direction all the
time where functional can have a very
complicated graph of directions you can
have the data split into two separate
tensors and then it comes back together
into another tensor all those kinds of
things and then subclassing is really
the really complicated one where now
you're adding your own subclasses into
the tensor to do external computations
right in the middle of like a huge flow
of data but we're going to stick with
sequential it's not a big jump to go
from sequential to functional but we're
running a sequential tensorflow and
that's what this first import is here we
want to bring in our sequential and then
we have our layers and let's talk a
little bit about these layers this is
where cross and tensorflow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built so from Cross we have
layers import dents from Cross layers
import LST M when we talk about these
layers
cross has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers the dense layer
is your standard neural network by
default it uses relu for its activation
and then the lstm is a long short term
memory layer since we're going to be
looking probably at sequential data
we want to go ahead and do the lstm and
if we go into
Karas and we look at their layers this
is a cross website you can see as we
scroll down for the cross layers that
are built in we can get down here and we
can look at let's see here we have our
layer activation our base layers
activation layer weight layer weights
there's a lot of stuff in here we have
the rayleu which is the basic activation
that was listed up here for layer
activations you can change those and
here we have our core layers and our
dense layers we have an input layer a
dense layer and then we've added a more
customized one with the long-term
short-term memory layer and of course
you can even do your own custom layers
in Cross there's a whole functionality
in there if you're doing your own thing
what's really nice about this is it's
all built in even the convolutional
layers this is for processing Graphics
there's a lot of cool things in here you
can do this is why cross is so popular
it's open source and you have all these
tools right at your fingertips so from
Cross we're just going to import a
couple layers the dense layer
and the long short-term memory layer and
then of course from sklearn our scikit
we want to go ahead and do our min max
scalar standard scaler for pre-editing
our data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality.csv let's go ahead and take a
quick look at that this is in Open
Office it's just a standard you know you
can do excel whatever you're using for
your spreadsheet and you can see here we
have a number of columns a number of
rows that actually goes down to like 8
000 the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row is kind of just a
random number put in going down probably
not something we're going to work with
the second row is Bandung I'm guessing
that's a reference for the profile if we
scroll to the bottom which I'm not going
to do because it takes forever to get
back up they're all the same the same
thing with the status the status is the
same we have a date so we have a
sequential order here
here is the jam which I'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time
we have our O3 CEO NO2 reading SO2
noco2 VOC and then some other numbers
here pm1 PM 2.5 pm4 pm10
without actually looking through the
data I mean some of this I can guess is
like temperature humidity I'm not sure
what the PMS are but we have a whole
slew of data here so we're looking at
air quality as far as an area and a
region and what's going on with our date
time stamps on there and so code wise
we're going to read this into a pandas
data frame so our data frame DF is a
nice abbreviation commonly used for data
frames equals pd.read CSV and then our
the path to it just happens to be on my
D drive separated by spaces and so if we
go ahead and run this
we'll print out the head of our data and
again this looks very similar to what we
were just looking at
being in Jupiter I can take this and go
the other way make it real small so you
can see all the columns going across and
we get a full view of it
or we can bring it back up in size
that's pretty small on there overshot
but you can see it's the same data we
were just looking at we're looking at
the number we're looking at the profile
which is the bend done the date we have
a time stamp our O3 count Co and so
forth on here
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done three rows
five rows ten whatever you want to put
in there by default that's five for
pandas now I've talked about this all
the time so I know I've already said it
at least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre-formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together so we want to go ahead
and start with our date time let's come
in in two columns we have our date here
and we have our time
and we want to go ahead and combine that
and then we have this is just a simple
script in there that says combine date
time that's our formula we're building
or we're going to submit our pandas data
frame and the tab name when we go ahead
and do this that's all of our
information that we want to go ahead and
create and then goes for Iron Range DF
shape 0. so we're going to go through
the whole setup and we're going to list
tab a pen DF location I and here is our
date going in there and then return the
numpy array list tab d-types date time
64. that's all we're doing we're just
switching this to a date time stamp and
if we go ahead and do DF date time
equals combine date time and then I
always like to print we'll do DF head
just so we can see what that looks like
and so when we come out of this we now
have our setup on here and of course
it's added it on to the far right here's
our date time you can see the formats
changed uh so there's our we've added in
the date time column and we've brought
the date over and we've taken this
format here and it's an actual variable
with a zero zero zero on here well that
doesn't look good so we need to also
include the time part of this and we
want to convert it into hourly data so
let's go ahead and do that to do that to
finish combining our date time let's go
ahead and create a a little script here
to combine the time in there same thing
we just did we're just creating a numpy
array returning a numpy array and crit
and forcing this into a date time format
and we can actually spend hours just
going through these conversions how do
you pull it from the pandas data frame
how do you set it up so I'm kind of
skipping through it a little fast
because I want to stay focused on
tensorflow and cross keep in mind this
is like 80 percent of your coding when
you're doing a lot of this stuff is
going to be reformatting these things
resetting them back up so that it looks
right on here and you know it just takes
time to to get through all that but that
is usually what the companies are paying
you for that's what the big bucks are
for
and we want to go ahead and a couple
things going on here is we're going to
go ahead and do our date time we're
going to reorganize some of our setup in
here convert into hourly data we just
put a pause in there
um now remember we can select from DF or
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped a couple of the
columns those ones I showed you earlier
they're just repetitive data so there's
nothing in there that exciting and then
we want to go ahead and we'll create a
second
data frame here let me just get rid of
the DF head
and df2 is we're going to group by date
time and we're looking at the mean value
and then we'll print that out so you can
see we're talking about
we have now reorganized this so we put
in date time O3 CL so now this is in the
same order as it was before and you'll
see the date time now has our zero zero
same date 1 2 3 and so on so let's group
the data together so there's a lot more
manageable and in the format we want and
in the right sequential order
and if we go back to there we go our air
quality you can see right here we're
looking at
um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own date time column we can get rid
of those these are the different Columns
of information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data
grouped it together by date and then you
can see the different data coming out
set up on there and then as a data
scientist first thing I want to do is
get a description what am I looking at
and so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our you know
describe gives us our basic data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard deviation
minimum amount maximum amount we have
our first quarter second quarter and
third quarter
numbers also in there so you can get a
quick look at a glance describing the
data or descriptive analysis and even
though we have our quantile information
in here we're going to dig a little
deeper into that
we're going to calculate the quantile
for each variable we're going to look at
a number of things for each variable
we'll see right here q1 we can simply do
the quantile 0.25 percent which should
match our 25 percent up here and we'll
be looking at the min Max and we're just
going to do this is basically we're
breaking this down for each different
variable in there one of the things
that's kind of fun to do we're going to
look at that in just a second let me get
put the next piece of code in here I
clean out some of our we're going to
drop a couple thing our last rows and
first row because those have usually
have a lot of null values and the first
row is just our titles so that's
important it's important to drop those
rows in here and so this right here as
we look at our different quantiles again
it's it's the same you know we're still
looking at the 25
quantile here we're going to do a little
bit more with this
so now that we've cleared off our first
and last rows we're going to go ahead
and go through all of our columns and
this way we can look at each column
individually and so we'll just create a
q1 Q3 min max Min IQR Maxi QR and
calculate the quantile of I of df2
we're basically doing the math that they
did up here but we're splitting it apart
that's all this is
and this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual if this was
my own project I would probably spend
days and days going through what these
different values mean
one of the biggest data science uh
things we can look at that's important
is uh use your use your common sense you
know if you're looking at this data and
it doesn't make sense and you go back in
there and you're like wait a minute what
the heck did I just do at that point you
probably should go back and double check
what you have going on
now we're looking at this and you can
see right here here's our attribute for
our O3 so we've broken it down we have
our q1 5.88 Q3 10.37 if we go back up
here here's our 5 8 we've rounded it off
10.37s in there
so we've basically done the same math
just split it up we have our minimum and
our Max IQR and that's computed let's
see where is it here we go uh q1 minus
1.5 times IQR and the IQR is your Q3
minus q1 so that's the difference
between our two different quarters and
this is all data science as far as the
hard math I'm really not we're actually
trying to focus on cross and tensorflow
you still got to go through all this
stuff I told you 80 of your programming
is going through and understanding what
the heck happened here
what's going on what does this data mean
and so when we're looking in that we're
going to go ahead and say hey
um
we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your minimum IQR
that means something's going wrong there
and usually in this case is going to
show us an outlier so we want to go
ahead and find the minimum value if it's
less than the minimum minimum IQR it's
an outlier and if the max value is
greater than the max IQR we have an
outlier and that's all this is doing low
outliers found minimum value High
outlier is found really important
actually outliers are almost everything
in data sometimes sometimes you do this
project just to find the outliers
because you want to know crime detection
what are we looking for we're looking
for the outliers what doesn't fit a
normal business deal and then we'll go
ahead and throw in just threw in a lot
of code oh my goodness so we have if
your max is greater than IQR print
outlier is found what we want to do is
we want to start cleaning up these
outliers and so we want to convert we'll
do create a convert Nan x max IQR equals
Max underscore IQR men IQR equals Min
IQR so this is just saying this is the
data we're going to send that's all that
is in Python and if x is greater than
the max IQR and X is less than the Min
IQR x equals null we're going to set it
to null why because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else it's not in
that Series so that you can look at just
the outlier and then we're going to
convert the Nan hum again we have X Maxi
QR is 100 percent Min iqrs Min IQR if x
is greater than Max IQR and X is less
than Min IQR again we're going to return
null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same value x x equals X
and you can see as we go through the
code if I equals our hum then we go
ahead and do this the that's a column
specific to humidity that's your hem
column then we're going to go ahead and
convert do the run a map on there and
convert the none hum you can see here
it's this is just clean up we run we've
found out that humidity probably has
some weird values in it we have our
outliers
that's all this is and so when we go
ahead and finish this and we take a look
at our outliers and we run this code
here
we have a low outlier 2.04 we have a
high outlier 99.06 outliers have been
interpolated
that means we've given them a new value
chances are these days when you're
looking at something like these sensors
coming in they probably have a failed
sensor in there something went wrong
that's the kind of thing that you really
don't want to do your data analysis on
so that's what we're doing is we're
pulling that out and then converting it
over and setting it up method linear
so we interpolate method linears it's
going to fill that data in based on a
linear regression model of similar data
same thing with this up here with the
df2i interpolate that's what we're doing
again this is all data prep we're not
actually talking about tensorflow we're
just trying to get all our data
set up correctly so that when we run it
it's not going to cause problems or have
a huge bias
foreign
so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in humidity
and again this is one of these things
where when we start running
um
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our outliers found
high low outliers
migrated them in we also know there's
other issues going on with this data how
do we know that some of it's just
looking at the data playing with it
until you start understanding what's
going on let's take the temp value and
we're going to go ahead and and use a
logarithmic function on the temp value
and it's interesting because it's like
how do you how do you have to even know
to use logarithmic on the temp value
that's domain specific we're talking
about being an expert in air care I'm
not an expert in Air Care
um you know it's not what I go look at I
don't look at Air Care data in fact this
is probably the first Air Care data
setup I've looked at but the experts
come in there and they come to you and
say hey in data science this is a
exponentially very variable on here so
we need to go ahead and do
transform it
and use a logarithmic scale on that
so at that point that would be coming
from your
data here we go data science programmer
overview does a lot of stuff connecting
the database and connecting in with the
experts data analytics a lot of times
you're talking about somebody who is a
data analysis might be all the way
usually a PhD level data science
programming level interfaces database
manager that's going to be the person
who's your admin working on it
so when we're looking at this we're
looking at something they've sent to me
and they said hey domain Air Care this
needs to be this is a skew because the
data just goes up exponentially and
affects everything else and we'll go
ahead and take that data let me just go
ahead and run this
just for another quick look at it
um we have our uh we'll do a
distribution DF we'll create another
data frame from the temp values and then
from a data set from the log temp so we
put them side by side and we'll just go
ahead and do a quick histogram this is
kind of nice plot a figure figure size
here's our PLT from matplot library and
then we'll just do a distribution
underscore DF there's our data frames
this is nice because it just integrates
the histogram right into pandas love
pandas and this is a chart you would
send back to your data analysis and say
hey is this what you wanted this is how
the data is converting on here as a data
science scientist the first thing I note
is we've gone from a 10 20 30 scale to
2.5 3.0 3.5 scale
and the data itself has kind of been
adjusted a little bit based on some kind
of a skew on there so let's jump into
we're getting a little closer to
actually doing our
cross on here we'll go ahead and split
our data up and this of course is any
good data scientists you want to have a
training set and a test set and we'll go
ahead and do the train size
we're going to use 0.75 percent of the
data make sure it's an integer we don't
want to take a slice as a float value
give you a nice error and we'll have our
train size is 75 percent and the test
size is going to be of course the train
size minus the length of the data set
and then we can simply do train comma
test
here's our data set
which is going to be the train size the
test size and then if we go and print
this let me just go and run this we can
see how these values split it's a nice
split of 1298 and then 433 points of
value that are going to be for our setup
on here and if you remember we're
specifically looking at the data set
where did we create that data set from
that was from up here that's what we
called the logarithmic value of the temp
that's where the data set came from so
we're looking at just that column with
this train size and the test with the
train and test data set here and let's
go ahead and do uh converted an array of
values into a data set Matrix we're
going to create a little
um
set up in here we create our data set
our data set is going to come in we're
going to do a look back of one so we're
going to look back one piece of data
going backward
and we have our data X and our data y
for Iron Range length of data set look
back minus one
this is creating let me just go ahead
and run this actually the best way to do
this
is to go ahead and create this data and
take a look at the shape of it let me go
ahead and just put that code in here
so we're going to do a look back one
here's our trainex our train Y and it's
going to be adding the data on there and
then when we come up here
and we take a look at the shape
there we go and we run this piece of
code here
we look at the shape on this and we have
a new slightly different change on here
but we have a shape of X 1296 comma 1
shape of Y train y Test X text y
and so what we're looking at is that
the X comes in
and we're only having a single value out
we want to predict what the next one is
that's what this little piece of code is
here for what are we looking for well we
want to look back one that's the um then
what we're going to train the data with
is yesterday's data yesterday says Hey
the humidity was at 97 what should
today's humidity be at if it's 97
yesterday is it going to go up or is it
going to go down today if 97 does it go
up to 100 what's going on there and so
our we're looking forward to the next
piece of data which says Hey tomorrow's
is going to you know today's humidity is
this this is what tomorrow's humidity is
going to be that's all that is all that
is is stacking our data so that our Y is
basically X Plus 1 or X could be y minus
1.
and then a couple things to note is our
X data we're only dealing with the one
column but you need to have it in a
shape that has it by The Columns so you
have the two different numbers and since
we're doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem and the reason is is that we
have what they call a Time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer so we're going
to add another reshape on here let me
just go down here and put it into the
next cell and so we want to reshape the
input array in the form of sample time
step features
we're only looking at one feature
and I mean this is one of those things
when you're playing with this you're
like why am I getting an error in the
numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on so we're going
to do is we're going to add one more
level on here instead of being 12.99 one
we want to go one more
and when they put the code together in
the back you can see we kept the same
shape the 12.99 we added the one
dimension and then we have our train X
shape one and this could have depends
again on how far back in the long
short-term memory you want to go that is
what that piece of code is for and that
reshape is and you can see the new shape
is now one uh 12.99 one one versus the
1299 one and then the other part of the
shape 432 one one again this is our TR
our X in and of course our test X and
then our Y is just a single column
because we're just doing one output that
we're looking for so now we've done our
80 percent
um you know that's all the the writing
all the code reformatting our data
bringing it in now we want to go ahead
and do the fun part which is we're going
to go ahead and create and fit the lstm
neural network uh and if we're going to
do that the first thing we need is we're
going to need to go ahead and create a
model and we'll do this sequential model
and if you remember sequential means it
just goes in order that means we have if
you have two layers the layers go from
layer one to Layer Two or layer 0 to
layer one this is different than
functional functional allows you to
split the data and run two completely
separate models and then bring them back
together we're doing just sequential on
here and then we decided to do the long
short term memory and we have our input
shape which it comes in again this is
what all this switching was we could
have easily made this one two three or
four going back as far as the end number
on there we just stuck to going back one
and it's always a good idea when you get
to this point where the heck is this
model coming from what kind of models do
we have available
and there's let me go and put the next
model in there uh because we're going to
do two models and the next model is
going to go ahead and we're going to do
dents so we have model equal sequential
and then we're going to add the lstm
model and then we're going to add a
dense model and if you remember from the
very top of our code
and we did the Imports oops there we go
our cross this is it right here here's
our importing a dense model and here's
our importing an lstm now just about
every tensorflow model uses dense your
dense model is your basic forward
propagation reverse propagation error
where it does reverse propagation to
program the model so any of your neural
networks you've already looked at that
lexan says here's the error and sends
the error backwards that's what this is
the long short term memory is a little
different the real question that we want
to look at right now is where do you
find these models what kind of models do
you have available and so for that let's
go to the Cross website which is
across.io if you go under API slash
layers and I always have to do a search
just search for cross API layers it'll
open up and you can see we have
your base layers right here class
trainable weights all kinds of stuff
like there your Activation so a lot of
your layers you can switch how it
activates relu which is like your
smaller arrays or if you're doing
convolutional neural networks the
convolution usually uses a relu your
sigmoid all the way up to softmax soft
plus all these different choices as far
as how those are set up and what we want
to do is we want to go ahead and if you
scroll down here you'll see your core
layers and here is your dense layer so
you have an input object your dense
layer your activation layer embedding
layer this is your your kind of your one
setup on there that's most common
convolutional neural networks or
convolutional layers these are like for
doing image categorizing so trying to
find objects in a picture that kind of
thing we have pooling layers so as you
have the layers come together usually
bring them down into a single layer
although you can still do the global Max
pulling 3D and there's just I mean this
list just goes on and on there's all
kinds of different things hidden in here
as far as what you can do and it changes
you know you go in here and you just
have to do a search for what you're
looking for and figure out what's going
to work best for you
as far as which project you're working
on Long short-term memory is a big one
because this is when we start talking
about text what if someone says the what
comes after the the cat and the hat
little kid's book there
starts programming it and so you really
want to know not only
um what's going on but it's going to be
something that has a history the history
behind it tells you what the next one
coming up is now once we've built all
our different you know we built our
model we've added our different layers
we went in there play with it remember
if you're in functional you can actually
link these layers together and they
Branch out and come back together if you
do a uh the sub
set up then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be coming linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things so we're
going to go ahead and compile your model
this brings everything together we're
going to put in what the losses which
will use the mean squared error and
we'll go ahead and use the atom
Optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like any of these
different prediction models if you've
been doing any side kit from python
you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model so what are we doing in
here we're going to send in our train X
our train y we're going to decide how
many epics we're going to run it through
500 is probably a lot for this I'm
guessing it'd probably be about two or
three hundred probably do just fine our
batch size
so how many different when you process
it this is the math behind it if you're
in data analytics you might try to know
what this number is as a data scientist
where I haven't had the PHD level math
that says this is why you want to use
this particular batch size you kind of
play with this number a little bit you
can dig deeper into the math
and see how it affects the results
depending what you're doing and there's
a number of other settings on here we
did verbose two I'd have to actually
look that up to tell you what verbose
means I think that's actually the
default on there if I remember correctly
there's a lot of different settings when
you go to fit it the big ones are your
epic and your bat size those are what
we're looking for
and so we're going to go ahead and run
this
and this is going to take a few minutes
to run because it's going through
500 times through all the data so if you
have a huge data set this is the point
where you're kind of wondering oh my
gosh is this going to finish tomorrow
if I'm running this on a single machine
and I have a terabyte terabyte of data
going into it
if this is my personal computer and I'm
running a terabyte of data into this you
know this is running rather quickly
through all 500 iterations but you got a
terabyte of data we're talking something
closer to days week
um you know even with a
3.5 gigahertz machine in in eight cores
it's still going to take a long time to
go through a full terabyte of data
and then we want to start looking at
putting it into some other framework
like spark or something that will the
process on there more across multiple
processors and multiple computers
and if we scroll all the way down to the
bottom you're going to see here's our
square mean error 0.0088
if we scroll way up you'll see it kind
of oscillates between 0.088 and 08089
it's right around 2 to 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics
uh you know if you're retraining this
stuff over and over again it's kind of
good to note where that error zone is so
you don't have to do all the extra
processing of course if you're going to
build a model
we want to go ahead and run a prediction
on it so let's go ahead and make our
prediction remember we have our training
test set and our test set or the we have
the
trainex and the train y for training it
or train predict and then we have our
test X and our test y going in there so
we can test to see how good it did
and we come in here we have you'll see
right here we go ahead and do our train
predict equals model predict train X
and test predict model predict Test X
why would we want to run the prediction
on trainx well it's not a hundred
percent on its prediction we know it has
a certain amount of error and we want to
compare the error we have on what we
programmed it with with the error we get
when we run it on new data that's never
see the model's never seen before and
one of the things we can do we go ahead
and invert the predictions this helps us
level it off a little bit more
get rid of some of our bias we have
train predict equals and NP
um exponential M1 the train predict and
then train y equals the exponential M1
for train Y and then we do again that
with train test predict and test y
um again reformatting the data so that
we can it all matches and then we want
to go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error
so we have our train score which is your
math square root times the mean square
root error train Y and train predict and
again we're just um this is just feeding
the data through so we can compare it
and the same thing with the test
and let's take a look at that because
really the code makes sense if you're
going through it line by line you can
see we're doing but the answer really
helps to zoom in so we have a train
score which is
2.40 of our root mean square error
and we have a test score of 3.16 of the
root mean square error
if these were reversed if our test score
is better than our training score then
we've over trained something's really
wrong at that point you got to go back
and figure out what you did wrong
because you should never have a better
result on your test data than you do
when you're training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing when you're going out
and quoting your publishing this you're
saying hey how good is my model it's the
test score that you're showing people
this is what it did on my test data that
the model had never seen before this is
how good my model is and a lot of times
you actually want to put together like a
little formal code
where we actually want to print that out
and if we print that out you can see
down here
test prediction and standard deviation
of data set 3.16 is less than
4.40 I'd have to go back and we're up
here if you remember we did the square
means error this is standard deviation
that's why these numbers are different
it's saying the same thing that we just
talked about
3.16 is less than 4.40 model is good
enough we're saying hey this is this
model is valid we have a valid model
here so we can go ahead and go with that
and along with putting a formal print
out of there we want to go ahead and
plot what's going on
uh and this we just want a pretty graft
here so that people can see what's going
on when I walk into a meeting and I'm
dealing with a number of people they
really don't want these numbers they
don't want to say hey what's I mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are you might be dealing with
a number of different departments head
of sales might not works with standard
deviation or have any idea what that
really means number wise and so at this
point we really want to put it in a
graph so we have something to display
and with displaying you gotta remember
that we're looking at the data today
going into it and what's going to happen
tomorrow
so let's take a quick look at this we're
going to go ahead and shift the train
predictions for plotting we have our
train predict plot
NP MP like data set train predict plot
set it up with null values
you know it's just kind of it's kind of
a weird thing where we're creating the
um the data groups as we like them and
then putting the data in there is what's
going on here so we have our train
predict plot which is going to be our
look back our length plus look back
we're just it's going to equal train uh
train predict so we're creating this
basically we're taking this and we're
dumping the train predict into it so now
we have our nice train predict plot
and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting we're going
to continue more of that oops looks like
I put it in here double no it's just uh
yeah they put it in here double
um didn't mean to do that
we really only need to do it once oh
here we go
um this is where the problem was is
because this is the test predict
so we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
data sets uh test predict plot length
prediction set up on there
and then we're going to go through the
plotting the original data set and the
predictions so we have a Time axes
always nice to have your time set on
there set that to the time array time
axes lap all this is setting up the time
variable for the bottom and then we have
a lot of stuff going on here as far as
setting up our figure
let's go ahead and run that and then
we'll break it down
we have on here our main plot we have
two different plots going on here the
ispu going up in the data and the ispu
here with all these different settings
on it
and so we look at this we have our ax1
that's the main plot I mean our ax
that's the main plot and we have our ax1
which is the secondary plot over here so
we're doing a figure PLT or plt.figure
and we're going to dump those two graphs
on there and so we take and if you go
through the code piece by piece which
we're not going to do we're going to do
the the
data set here
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set we're going to
plot the train predict plot that's what
we just created we're going to make that
orange and we'll label it train
prediction test predicts plot we're
going to make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth set our ticks up
let's actually just put time axes gets
its ticks the little little marks that
are going along the axes that kind of
thing and let's take a look and see what
these graphs look like
and these are just kind of fun you know
when you show up into a meeting and this
is the final output and you say hey this
is what we're looking at here's our
original data in blue
here's our training prediction you can
see that it trains pretty close to what
the data is up there
I would also probably put a like a
little little time stamp and do just
right before and right after where we go
from a train to test prediction and you
can see with the test prediction the
data comes in in red
and then you can also see what the
original data set looked like behind it
and how it differs and then we can just
isolate that here on the right that's
all this is is just the test prediction
on the right uh and it's you know
there's you'll see what the original
data set there's a lot of Peaks we're
missing and a lot of lows were missing
but as far as the actual test prediction
it's pretty it does pretty good it's
pretty right on you can get a good idea
what to expect for your ispu and so from
this we would probably publish it and
say hey this is what you expect and this
is our area of this is a range of error
that's the kind of thing I put out
on a daily basis maybe we predict the
sales are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice you
kind of flatten the um data coming out
and you say hey this is what we're
looking at the big takeaway from this is
that we're working with
let me go back up here oops oh too far
there we go
um is this model here this is what this
is all about we work through all of
those pieces all the tensorflows and
that is to build this sequential model
and we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never it never
verges into a usable model so if you
have like 30 different layers in here
there's a good chance you might crash it
kind of thing so don't go too haywire on
that and that you kind of learn as you
go again it's domain knowledge and also
starting to understand all these
different layers and what they mean
the data analytics behind those layers
is something that your data analysis
professional would come in and say this
is what we want to try
but I tell you as a data scientist a lot
of these basic setups are common and I
don't know how many times
working with somebody and they're like
oh my gosh if I only did a tangent H
instead of a relu activation I worked
for two weeks to figure that out well as
a data science I can run it through the
model in you know five minutes instead
of spending two weeks doing the the math
behind it so that's one of the
advantages of data scientists is we do
it from programming side in a data
analytics is going to look for it how
does it work in math and this is really
the core right here of tensorflow and
cross is being able to build your data
model quickly and efficiently and of
course with any data science putting out
a pretty graph so that your shareholders
again we want to take and reduce the
information down to something people can
look at and say oh that's what's going
on they can see stuff what's going on is
as far as the dates and the change in
the ispu if you are one of the aspiring
data scientists looking for online
training and graduating from the best
universities or a professional who
elicits to switch careers with data
analytics by learning from the experts
then try giving a show to Simply learn
skeleton postgraduate programming data
science in collaboration with IBM the
link is mentioned in the description box
and you should navigate to the home page
where you can find a complete order of
the program being offered hello and
welcome to this session on tableau
in this session we will start with
certain exercises which we will perform
in Tableau in order to understand some
basic concepts
now in order to learn Tableau the basic
first step is to import a sample data so
in our case what we have done is we have
imported a sample Superstore which is in
Excel format a sample superstore.xl
which has three worksheets in it orders
people and returns so by importing this
data into Tableau first of all we will
create relationships between these
sheets in order to identify who all have
placed orders and how many people have
returned the orders we will do some
analysis on the orders placed by certain
set of people and Order returned by a
certain set of people
now as we have imported uh the sheet we
will make certain joins so the first
step is to drag the orders
table the order sheet on the
relationship canvas here okay and you
can see the data sample data the first
100 rows over here
okay then now we need to create an inner
join with people's table between order
and people okay so if you see
it has automatically detected the field
names on which the inner join has to be
created so on the order side you have
region and on the right hand side which
is the people data you have also a
region okay so both these columns are
common and that's how we have made a
join between orders and people data
so if I close this box and go and check
the people's data
foreign
so see the region and the person these
two columns from the people table have
now been
joined with the orders table right so it
means that these are the orders in a
particular region which has been placed
by
in this region
let me show you the sample Superstore
Excel file now this is the structure of
the file you have a sample list of
transactions basically the orders which
are placed by customers
across multiple regions
south west of USA South Region west
region then you have a list of order IDs
which have been returned so basically
the order ID in the returns sheet
matches with those orders in the order
stable
and then you have the people
sheet in which you have region
and a person associated with that region
the sales person associated with that
region okay so basically when we are
combining joining orders with people we
are joining that
which orders
belongs to which region and who is the
sales person associated with it so what
we have done over here is we have made a
inner join means all the orders should
belong to particular region and that
region is in the people's sheet
and then in the second step
now we will make a
left join between returns and orders
not inner join we'll make a left join
between returns and orders and we will
make a join using the
order ID
okay so just edit this
click on left
and
select order ID as the join column now
what does left join means left join mean
is that consider all the orders from the
orders table and only consider the
orders from the returns table which have
data means which are returned otherwise
show null for the order IDs which are
not returned so if you see this is the
these are the two columns from the
returns table and these are null because
this is relevant to the order IDs which
are not returned okay which has been
accepted by the customer but these are
the orders for which you see data in the
returned and Order ID column it means
that these have been returned
now with these joins in place please
save your book and now we have our
relations created in the
um
in the Tableau now we are ready to
create certain reports and extract
certain kpis using this relationship
model
now we'll move to sheet1
okay
and first we will place
state
and person on the rose
sheet okay
then
I'll go to my
numbers and
put the profit or D so per state per
person how much profit I am making as a
company okay this is my goal to check
now
sort by highest to lowest
so California is giving me the maximum
profit of seventy six thousand six three
hundred eighty one then New York then
Washington so this is the sorted order
in which I have
listed my profit in descending order
now I can also check what are the number
of orders
placed
and check the distinct count
yeah
so out of 120 out of the total orders of
127 okay so this is the number of total
number of orders which have been
returned for California is 127.
it's 16 29 so the sorted order is as per
the revenue as per the profit and this
is the details of the orders which have
been returned per state
so if you see for connected for a
cancers there are zero returns
so you can also extract data
table to refresh his orders and identify
new rows using order D so as and when
new data is being added you can
refresh it now say extract
and now you can save this information
profit
by state
and click save so this is the extraction
of this particular report which is
possible in tableau
so this is the first exercise which we
have completed for
reviewing and analyzing the profit per
state highest to lowest and within that
per state what are the number of orders
which have been returned by all the
customers the distinct count of order
IDs which have been returned
now let's start our second exercise on
creating calculated fields in tableau
now in this exercise we will be doing
certain
activities like we will be creating a
set to show the states which have more
than 100 customers then we will be
creating a calculated field to show an
average sales per customer okay then we
will create a calculated feed to show
the sales goals and then show emerging
and developing stage so these are the
four kpis which we have to derive
now the first thing we have our sample
Superstore data already imported and the
relationships created in a join with
people and left joined with returns
now we have our sheet 2 in which we will
create the states a list of states which
has more than 100 customers
so what we have to do is we have to
click right click on the customer name
and click create set
okay
now we have to give the name as states
with 100 plus customers
and then go to the condition tab
select by field
and then apply condition as
count of customer name
greater than equal to
and click
ok
now we have this set created states with
100 plus customers
now to determine average sales by
customer we have to now create a
calculated field
so go to the analysis and click on
create calculate field
okay
now name it as
average
sales per customer
and now we will say average
we will use a
foreign
that per customer we are using a level
of definition function include which
means that per customer what is my
average sales right we've already used a
function aggregated function called
average so we are saying per customer
give me the total and then give me the
average per customer so we're going to
click ok
now create another calculated field you
can also create from here
and name is as name it as sales goal
now in this we are going to type the
formula if
minimum
States
with 100 plus customers equal to true
then
sum of
sales
into 1.3
else
average sales per customer into
100 so me we are saying that
if the customer belongs to the set of
states with 100 plus customers then the
sales Target should be
1.3 times the actual sales as of today
else it should be 100 of the average
sales per customer
now let's create another calculated
field which we call as
emerging
or developing state
if distinct count
of customer name
is greater than equal to 100
then
the state is tagged as developing state
else it is called as
emerging state
okay so we have now
three calculated Fields average sales
per customer emerging or developing
State and sales goals
now we will use this in our reporting
so we will drag sales goal under the
columns
and then I'll drop my state
so now this is the statewise sales goal
depending whether the state has 100 plus
customers or not
then add your customer name
make the measure as count distinct
and make it as discrete
okay so if you see this
we have the count of customers per state
and the
the sales goal
for that particular state
and now
I'll put my sum of sales the total sales
which I want
which is there per state
now go to show me and select
this particular chart
bullet graph
now to bring sales goals to column right
click on the sales access and select
swap reference line fields
now from your left hand panel drag and
drop emerging or developing straight on
the color panel
okay so a merging state is the orange
one and the developing state is the blue
one
and save the sheet as
developing and the emerging States
so if you see this it's an emerging
State because its count is less than the
customer count is less than 100
its sales goal is
57384 but the actual sales is
19511 okay
so now this is a developing State its
count is greater than equal to 100 and
its sales goal and its sales is exactly
the same it matches so that's why you
are saying the bar and the blue bar is
ending exactly where the vertical bar is
thank you
so what we are trying to depict is that
whether the state is going Beyond its
Target sales goal or it's behind it
and you can see that using this
particular vertical bar like for example
Michigan its sales goal is 71 952 but
its actual sales is seven six seven two
seven zero average sales so that's why
it is be above its Target
and it's a developing state
because it has more than 100 customers
so you can even sort
by the count of
the uh customers higher to lower so all
your developing state will group from at
the top and the emerging States Will
Group at the bottom
or you can sort by
the sales goal
so the orange bar is the sales goal or
the blue bar so depending what sales
goal
has been
derived for each state
first let's understand what is MySQL
workbench or MySQL workbench
so
MySQL workbench is a graphical tool for
working with mySQL servers and databases
you may use the MySQL workbench for
Server Administration for creating
entity relationship diagrams and for
running SQL queries
MySQL server is cross-platform meaning
that it can run on number of different
platforms such as Windows Linux Mac OS
and others
now
we will see the MySQL workbench
functionalities
so first we have SQL development or SQL
development MySQL workbench enables you
to create and manage connections to
database servers along with enabling you
to configure connection parameters MySQL
workbench provides the capability to
execute SQL queries on the database
connections using the built-in SQL
editor
next we have data modeling
the data modeling functionality of MySQL
allows you to create models of your
database schema graphically
reverse and forward engineer between a
schema and a live database and edit all
aspects of your database using the
comprehensive table editor the table
editor provides easy to use
functionalities for editing tables
columns indexes triggers partitioning
options inserts and privileges routines
as well as views
the third functionality is server
Administration
it enables you to administer MySQL
server instances by administering users
performing backup and Recovery
inspecting audit data viewing database
health and monitoring the MySQL server
performance
fourth we have data migration
now this functionality of MySQL
workbench allows you to migrate from
Microsoft SQL Server Microsoft Access DB
SCI base SQL Lite SQL anywhere
postgres SQL and other relational
database management system tables
objects and data to mySQL
migration also supports migrating from
earlier versions of MySQL to the latest
releases
and finally we have MySQL Enterprise
support
the MySQL workbench has support for
Enterprise products such as MySQL
Enterprise backup MySQL firewall and
MySQL audit
now
let's have a look at the MySQL workbench
additions available to us
first we have the Community Edition so
this workbench Edition is open sourced
and can be downloaded free of cost
it came under the GPL license and is
supported by a huge community of
Developers
then we have the standard edition of
MySQL workbench
the standard edition of MySQL workbench
is the commercial Edition that provides
the capability to deliver high
performance and scalable online
transaction processing that is popularly
known as oltp applications
so the last addition that is the
Enterprise Edition we have is the
commercial Edition that includes a set
of advanced features management tools
and Technical Support to achieve the
highest scalability security reliability
and uptime
now this Edition also reduces the risk
cost complexity in the development
deployment and managing MySQL
applications
now with this theoretical knowledge
let's go ahead and see how to download
and install MySQL workbench on Windows
okay so I've searched for MySQL download
on Google and let me go ahead and click
on the first link which is from
www.mysql.com
this will lead us to the downloads page
I've opened in a new tab and in the
downloads section if I scroll down
you'll find something called as
MySQL Community GPL downloads this GPL
stands for general public license which
is for free so we will install the
community edition of MySQL workbench
if I click on this it will take you to
another page where you have all the
MySQL Community downloads and here you
will find something called as MySQL
installer for Windows
I'll click on this
and here you can see we have the MySQL
installer 8.0 version
please go ahead and install from this
link you can just click on download
now we already have a video published on
how to install MySQL on windows so
please click on the above link to know
the steps for installation let me show
you the video so this is the video I'm
talking about which is already published
on our channel that is install MySQL
server and workbench on Windows all
right
now once the installation is complete go
ahead and launch the MySQL workbench so
here
in the search bar if I just type MySQL
you can see here I have the MySQL
workbench 8.0 version installed I'll
open this
so this is how the interface
looks like it says welcome to mySQL
workbench it tells you what MySQL is and
here I have already created a MySQL
connection now let me show you how to
create a new connection
I'll just click on this plus button and
it will open set up new connection
now here you can give a connection name
let me
type my name as MySQL underscore demo
now the connection method you can keep
it as standard TCP
now the host name will be the default
port number should be 3306 the username
I have kept it as root because this is
what I gave while installing
MySQL
if you want you can also set the
password
if I click on this you can enter
the password
I'll suggest you to give a strong
password I'll click on OK
and let's try to test the connection
you can see here it says successfully
made the MySQL connection you have the
host the port number user and
it says
a successful MySQL connection was made
with parameters defined with this
connection just click on OK and I'll
click on OK again
you can see here we have made a new
connection which says MySQL demo
I'll click on this
and it will open my query editor
so let me open my MySQL workbench where
we will perform some Hands-On
demonstrations and look at how to use
MySQL functions write different commands
and we'll see the results
so here on the search bar I'll type
MySQL
so it says MySQL workbench 8.0 version
let me open it
okay you can see I have a
local instance connection I'll connect
to this and I'll enter the password
so this is how my MySQL workbench
interface looks like let me just drag
this to the top
okay
now the white workspace that you see
here is called the SQL visual editor and
below
you will have the result Pane and the
history output window I'll show you once
I run a query and on the right hand side
you can see we have a help pin or a help
window
so if you want to
check the documentation
or the usage of a certain command you
can just type here and it will give you
the documentation as you can see I just
choose one command that is Select here
and it has returned me the syntax and
what select statement really does all
right
and here on the
left side you can see we have something
called Administration and schemas these
are the different databases that I've
already created so for this demo
we will start by creating a new database
so the command I'll write is create
database if I hit tab it will auto
complete
and the database name I'll give us SQL
workbench
give a semicolon
I'll select this and you see this
Thunder button if I click on this it
will execute my query
okay you can see here
it has returned me one row affected and
my query was successful
all right
now to move inside this database I'll
use
the command called use SQL underscore
workbench which is my database name
let's run this
you can see we have successfully entered
into our database now we can create any
tables perform any calculations
operations data manipulations retrieve
data of H data insert data and lot of
other operations
now under the schema let me just refresh
this so that you can see our new
database this is our database you can
see SQL workbench currently we haven't
created any tables if I
create a table it will show here you can
see here views stored procedures
functions and other things
so first let's get started by
looking at some of the numeric functions
that are available
in MySQL
so I am giving a comment by typing shift
and then my comment that is numeric
functions
first and foremost we'll see how to use
the absolute function in MySQL
so
for using the absolute function I'll
write select
abs
and inside this ABS function I'll pass
in a value let's say 22
now if I run this
it gives me a result that is 22 since
the absolute value of 22 is 22 because
22 we have passed in as a positive value
now let's say I'll pass in minus 22.
and let's run it
there you go you can see here
my absolute function has dropped the
negative sign and has written me a
positive value which is 22 you can try
for other values let's say I'll
select minus 50
if I run this it returns me 50
all right
next
we'll see how
the mod function works
so the mod function Returns the
remainder of a division
so if I write select
mod
and I want to divide
10 by 4.
let's run this and see the result
you can see it has returned me to
because the remainder for 10 divided by
4 is 2
you can also give an alias name to this
I'll write as remainder
the reason why I am giving an alias name
is because
the result we have got if you see the
column this is not very readable
now if I run this
you can see the difference there you go
now the output is much readable than the
previous one
okay so let's say
I want to find the mod of another
division 15 comma 3
as remainder again
I'll run it again
you can see 15 divided by 3 the
remainder is 0 let's try for one more
let's say
50.6
divided by 2
you can already guess the result it
should be 0.6 there you go you can see
this is my
remainder
now as I said
the below window is called the history
output window or the pane and this is
called the query result pane
which is part of the MySQL workbench
let me just drag this a bit okay
now moving on to the next numeric
function we will explore the power
function
now suppose I write select
power
raised to 2.
let's see the result
I'll run it it gives me
16 which is correct
let's see
I'll write select power
10 raised to 3.
you can already
think of the result it should be 1000
okay
now like how you
use the power function similarly you can
use the square root function in MySQL
the square root function is written as
sqrt
so you can
get the square root of a number by using
the sqrt function
let's say I want to find the square root
of 4.
if I run this
it gives me 2 which is the square root
of 4 I'll edit here itself let's say I
want to find the square root of 144.
where on this
it gives me 12 which is the
square root of 144.
now moving ahead
let's say you want to find the greatest
number within a range of numbers you can
use the greatest function that is
available in MySQL
I'll write select
greatest I'll give a range of numbers
let's say 2 5 18
6.
and let's say 12.
and let me run it
it returns me 18 because 18 is the
largest or the greatest number
in my range of numbers
similarly you can also find the least
number for that you can use the least
function
this will return me the minimum number
present in my range of numbers in this
case it is 2. all right
there's another function that is
available in MySQL is truncate so the
truncate function trunc it's a number to
the specified number of decimal places
so suppose I write select
run kit
22.897 comma 1.
let's see the output
okay you can see here
so the truncate function has returned us
22.8 and it has truncated the rest of
the decimal places
I want to truncate up to two decimal
places let's see the result again
you can see here
it has given us 22.89
next
we have another function called round so
the round function MySQL is used to
round a number to a specified number of
decimal places
if no specified number of decimal places
is provided to a round of function the
round of function rounds the number to
the nearest integer so let's see a few
examples
suppose I want to round the value 22.897
this time I am not passing
the specified number of decimal places
we'll see the result
it has returned me 23 which is the next
highest integer
suppose you want to
round it to two decimal places
you can give a comma and then say 2
I'll run it it has given us 22.90
so this 8 9 it has converted to nine
zero similarly if you want to
round the number to one decimal please
it will give you 22.9
all right
now
let's create a student's table and store
it in our MySQL workbench
so I'll just give a
comment called student table or student
stable
all right
so the way to create a table in a
database in MySQL workbench is you write
create table followed by
the table name that you want in this
case I'm going to create a student's
table
then you start with parenthesis and
give the
columns that you want in your table so
first I want the student ID you can
think of this as the student rule number
give us peace and then give the data
type
of the column now student ID should
ideally be of type integer I'm assigning
this as primary key
so the primary key will uniquely
identify each record in a table
and it cannot have any
duplicate values
so ideally if you think all the students
in a school will have a unique roll
number
no two students will have the same roll
next column I want is the student name
now the name is of type worker
and I'll give the length as let's say 25
then I want the age of the student age
is also of type integer
and I will write in the same line
then I need the gender
gender of the student should be of type
character and
the size I'll give us
one
then we have
DOA which stands for date of admission
and it is of type date
then we have the city to which the
student belongs to then city is also a
type
worker
all right you close the bracket and give
a semicolon let's run this
there you go here you can see in the
history window it says
the table was created successfully now
let's just refresh this again
so that you can see the table
here under MySQL workbench database and
the tables you can see we have a
student's table let me expand this
further so that you can see the
columns that we have there you go we
have the student ID the student name is
gender date of admission and the City
okay
now it's time to insert a few
records to this table for that you need
to write the insert statement now I am
going to open a notepad where I have
already written the insert statement so
let me just copy paste it here
okay so here on my notepad I have my
insert statement already written I'll
just copy this and I'll paste it on my
workspace
okay
if I go to the top you can see this is
how my insert into
command look like
you have insert into followed by the
table name which is students then you
have the values keyword and we have the
set of Records so the first
value represents the student
ID or the roll number then you have the
student's name you have the age you have
the gender then we have the date of
admission and then we have the city to
which the student belongs to
all right
now let me go ahead and run my insert
query I'll just select everything and
I'll hit on execute
you can see here you have successfully
inserted 20 rows of information to our
table
now
if you want to
check all the records in a table
the SQL command is Select start from
table name that is students
if I run this
this is my output you can see we have
the student ID the student name e gender
date of admission and City if I scroll
down there are total
20 rows of information in my table
now the star represents you want to
select all the columns in the students
table suppose
you want to return specific columns from
the table you can mention that in the
select statement itself
suppose I want to select the student
name the age of the student and the city
to which the student belongs to so I
will write select Stu underscore name
which is my column name comma the age
comma
the city
from my table name that is students
let's run it
you can see the output we have only
three columns displayed in the result
okay
now
let's see how to use the where clause in
SQL or MySQL so the where Clause helps
you filter specific records based on
certain condition
or conditions
suppose I want to see the students who
are from Pune so I want to display only
the records of students who are from
Pune City so the way to do is I'll write
select
star from
students
where
City equal to
Pune
now this Pune is a
character type so you need to mention it
within single quotes
let's run it
there you go in the output you can see
there are total four students who are
from Pune you have Joseph
foreign
all right
now
let's say you want to
filter only those students who are from
Miami and their gender is male
again you are going to use the where
clause and along with the where Clause
we'll use the and operator
so I'll write
select
star from
students
where
CT equal to
I'll say Miami
this Miami should be within quotes
I'll use my and operator
and then write the gender should be
equal to
M or meal
again
M should be within single quotes I'll
give a semicolon and let's run it
you can see here
we have Whipple
ishan
tanishq and
Amrit who are from Miami city and their
gender is male
cool now moving ahead
suppose you want to know the students
who are either from City Boston or
Chicago in that case you are going to
use an or operator
I'll just copy this
SQL command and I'll paste it here and
I'll edit in the same query so this time
we want the students who are from
City Boston or Chicago so here instead
of Miami I'll write Boston
I'll use an or clause or an or operator
and instead of gender equal to mail I'll
again write
or city equal to
Chicago
let us
run the SQL query and see what we have
so there are total
six students who are either from City
citago or from Boston we also have a
female student Eliana
all right
now moving further
let's say you want to display the
records of the students
who belong to any city rather than
Chicago
in that case you are going to use the
not operator
so I'll write select star from
students where
not City equal to
Chicago
let's run it and see the result
all right you can see total we have
returned 17 rows of information which
means
there are total 17 students who belong
to other cities apart from Chicago if
you see the result you won't find any
student who is from
Chicago City
okay
now there's another important
feature of MySQL where you can group
certain rows of information based on a
particular column or columns
so let's see how to use Group by in
MySQL
I'll give a
comment called Group by
now in this group by Clause we are going
to find the total number of students
present in each City
so the way to do this I'll write select
I want to select this city
and then I'm going to use the count
function this is an inbuilt MySQL
function
I am going to count the student IDs
I'll give an alias as
total students
from my table that is
students
then
I am going to group my result based on
each City
let's run this
and see the output
there you go you can see here
so our table has total
six cities you have Pune New York
Miami Chicago Detroit and
Boston and here on the right hand side
you have the total students that we just
created using an alias name and this
total students column has the total
number of students from each City so if
you see here
New York has four students Pune has four
students in Miami Chicago we have four
and three students and in Detroit we
have two students respectively
all right
the next class we are going to see is
having
now having and where are kind of similar
but there are certain differences
now
for our example we are going to find the
cities where the total number of
students are more than three if you see
the results pin
so we have Pune we have New York and
Miami as the cities where there are more
than three students
so let me show you how to return these
three records so I'll write select City
comma
I'll count
the students using the count function
and I'll pass my column as student ID
and I'll give an alias as total students
from
my table that is students
I'll use the
Group by Clause Group by City
and then I am going to use having
the count of
student ID
greater than 3.
let me run it
and show you the result there you go
as expected we have Pune New York and
Miami where the total number of students
are more than three
let's see
how the order by
Clause works
so the order by Clause is used to
filter the records based on a particular
order in ascending or descending order
so suppose
see I write select star from
students
and then I'll write
order by let's say City
let me show you the result first
okay you can see
the city column has been ordered in
alphabetical order
so first the city start with b then we
have c d m
and then we have n and p
what if I want to order the resultant
descending order
so again it will
alphabetically sort my result in
descending order of City so
on the top we have Pune
because
alphabetically in descending order Pune
starts with p so it appears on the top
then we have New York followed by Miami
Detroit Chicago and Boston
now it's time to explore some string
functions in
MySQL
so I have given a comment string
functions
first
let's say you want to convert a certain
string into upper case so I can write
select
the function I'll use is upper
and within this function you can pass in
the string let's say
I'll write India
if you want you can give an alias name
as let's say uppercase
foreign
and let's run it there you go so my
input was in sentence case and using the
upper function we have converted
everything into uppercase similarly let
me just copy this
and
I'll show you
if you want to convert a string into a
lowercase you can use the lower function
I'll run this you can see the result
everything is in lower case now of
course I need to change the Alias name
to lowercase
instead of using lower as the function
there is another function that MySQL
provides which is called the L case I'll
just edit this and write L case
and let's say I'll write
India in
upper case
let's run it returns me the same result
cool
moving on
let's say you want to find the length of
a string you can use the character
length function
I'll write select
use the function character length
and I'm again going to pass in my
string as India as
let's say total length
let's run it this time I'm going to hit
Ctrl enter to run MySQL command
there you go
it has given us the right result which
is 5 because India has five characters
in it now these functions you can also
apply on a table
let me show you how to do it let's say
we already have the students table and
you want to find the
length of
each of the student names
so here you can pass
Stu underscore name
and you can give the same Alias name
let's say total length
and then you can write from
table name that is students
if I run this
you can see the output it has given me
total 20 rows of information this is not
readable actually let me also
display these student names so that we
can compare their
length
all right
I'll run this again
and now you can
see the result so Joseph has six
characters nilis has six Whipple has
five and above has seven similarly if
you see Akshay has six then it has 7
raghav S6
come in size 7 rabada has six so on and
so forth
now instead of using this character
length you can also use the function
care length
it will work the same way let's see the
result
there you go it has given us the same
result you can either use character
length or care length
now there's another very interesting
function called concat so the concat
function adds two or more Expressions
together let's say I'll write select
use the function
concatenate
the function is actually concat
and I'm going to pass in
my
string values let's say India
is
in Asia
let's run this and see our result
you can see here it has concatenated
everything
let us make it more readable I'll give a
space in between so that
you can read it clearly
now this is much more readable India is
in Asia
and if you want you can give an alias
name as well as let's say merged
there you go
now the same concat operation you can
also perform on a table
I'm going to use the same students table
let's say I want to return the student
ID
followed by the student name
and then
I am going to merge
the student name
followed by a space
followed by the age of the student
and I can give an alias as let's say
name underscore each
from my table that is students
let's see how this works
okay you see here the result is very
clear
we have the student ID the student name
and the concatenated column that we
created which was name underscore each
where we have the
student name with a space followed by
the age of the student
if I scroll down you can see the rest of
the results
cool
now moving ahead
let's see how the reverse function Works
in MySQL
so the MySQL reverse function returns a
string with the characters printed in
reverse order
so suppose I write select
reverse
I'll use the same string again let's say
I have
India
let's run it you will see all the
characters printed in reverse order
again you can perform the same operation
on
a table as well let's see I'll write
select
reverse
and I'll pass in the column as student
name
from my table that is students
let's run it
it gives you 20 students and all the
names have been printed in reverse order
okay
now
let's see what the replace function does
so the replace function replaces all
occurrences of a substring within a
string within a new substring
so let me show you what I mean
I'll write select
replace
I'll pass in my input strain which is
let's say orange is a
vegetable
which is ideally incorrect I am
purposely writing this so that I can
replace the
word vegetable
with
fruit
okay
so what this replace function does is it
is going to find where my word vegetable
is within the string my input string and
it is going to replace my word vegetable
with fruit
let's run it and see the output there
you go now this is correct which is
Orange is a fruit
all right
now
MySQL also provides some trim functions
you can use the left trim right trim and
just the trim function
so let me show you how this
left trim box
left rim or L trim removes the leading
space characters from a string passed as
an argument
so say I write select
I'll use the left trim function which is
L trim
and then I am going to purposely give a
few speeches
in the beginning of the string I'll give
a word let's say India
and then I'll give some space after the
bird India
and see how the
Ultram box if I run this it gives me
India which is fair enough
but before that
let's first find the length of my string
so I'll use my length function here and
within this function I am going to
find the length of my string which has
India along with some
leading and trailing spaces I'll paste
this here
give a semicolon and I'll run it
okay so the entire string is
17 characters long or the length of the
string is
17. now see I use l trim on my same
string
what it returns me is India
and if I
run length over it you can see the
difference
as in you can see how many spaces were
deleted from the left of the string you
can see here now it says 17
and
I'm going to use l trim
let's see the difference it gives me 12
the reason being it has deleted
five spaces from the left you can count
it
one two three four and five so Seventeen
minus five was
12 which is correct similarly you can
use the r trim function which removes
the trailing spaces from a string
trailing spaces are these pieces
when you use left trim it deletes the
leading spaces which is this
now let me just replace L term with r
trim which stands for right trim and see
the result
so the length is 10 now the reason being
it has deleted
seven spaces from the right of the
string if you can count it one two three
four five six and seven
cool
you can also
use the trim function which will delete
both the leading and the trailing spaces
so here if I just write trim
and I'll
run it it gives me five because India is
total 5 characters long and it has
deleted all the leading and the trailing
spaces
all right
there's also a function called position
in MySQL the position function Returns
the position of the first occurrence of
a substring in a string so if the
substring is not found with the original
string the function will return 0.
so let's say I'll write select
position
I want to find
where
fruit is
in my string that is
Orange
is a fruit
I'll give an alias as name
the sum error here
it should be within double quotes
now let's run it and see the result okay
it says at the 13th place or at the 13th
position we have the word fruit in our
string which is Orange is a fruit
now the final function we are going to
see is called ASCII so the ASCII
function Returns the ASCII value for a
specific character let's say I write
select
as key of the letter small a
if I run this
it will give me the ASCII value which is
let's say you want to find the ASCII
value
of
4.
let's see the result
it gives me 52.
all right
so that brings us to the end of the demo
session on MySQL workbench
let me go to the top and show you the
things that we covered so first of all
we created a new database called MySQL
workbench which you could
see it here under schemas there was
a database created called MySQL
workbench then we entered into the
database using the command use MySQL
workbench or SQL workbench we explored a
few numeric functions where we saw how
to use absolute mod power square root
least greatest truncate round
and then we created a table called
students we inserted some 20 rows of
information of different students and
the rage date of admission City
we saw how to use where Clause how to
use the and and or operator
we used Group by to group our records
based on certain conditions we also used
having
we used order by and then we look at a
few
string functions such as lower upper
concat character length reverse replace
ASCII and position
all right
with that we have reached the end of
this data science tools full course if
you have any questions please feel free
to leave us a comment and we'll have it
answered for you at the earliest until
next time thank you for watching stay
safe keep learning and get ahead
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here